foreign
thank you
all right
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
this might be deadly for the unicorn's
chances right here look at that and just
like that the fist pump from Fort Nick
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives Magnus shakes his head it's
over wow Magnus loses his second game of
the entire PCL season entering its Fifth
Season 16 teams will reboot the PCL
Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
and Darius
by the way he gained what are you doing
face yeah like that was not your best
move
welcome to another exciting day in the
Pro chess League I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me my good friend
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinsky Dania we
have seen four matches conclude earlier
this week today we have two more in
store how excited are you for the action
incredibly excited Robert happy Friday
everybody no better way to start the
Friday than with some more exciting PCL
action it's been an amazing week and
it's been shepherded and performed
beautifully by lead commentator some guy
named Robert Hess so glad to be here
can't wait for more PCL
wow started off with positivity that's a
surprise but it wasn't that it is rare
uh what also it will be not so rare will
be the next team that qualifies for the
playoffs here in the protest League
because as we bring up the standings we
have four teams that have already booked
their ticket to the playoffs the Indian
yogis the Gotham Knights the Shanghai
tigers and the levitov chess Wizards and
later today we will see the Norway
gnomes and team MGD One play but Tanya
at the top there those four teams that
have already clinched the playoff spot
which one sticks out to you
gosh I'm just looking around and looking
around that is a log Jam at the top
Robert the levitov chess Wizards were my
favorites uh after week one but looking
at the way the Indian yogis have run
through the field of Gotham knights with
Hikaru Nakamura it's kind of like
choosing between you know the Warriors
and name some good NBA teams the Bucks
it's like everybody's incredibly good
and as I said at the start Robert it's
going to be about form it's not going to
be about rosters everybody has an
incredible roster at the top it's about
the form that the top players are going
to show that's going to be the X Factor
yeah for sure that is going to be the
case and Norway gnomes team mgd1 the
matchup World C one team will go up into
the playoffs the other will go down to
two and two and have to play next week
and on the other side of the standings
there are four teams that have already
been eliminated we see the unicorns the
Capybaras they joined the Bears and the
cobras who are limited a week ago to
dania I think most people would be
shocked at the start of the season to
hear the St Louis archbishops two losses
as a team that may be surprising but
they know what they have to do they need
to keep winning
well it is definitely surprising to
anyone with a knowledge of PCL history
they are multiple time U.S chess league
and pro chess League champions and it
will be surprising to anyone who views
their roster which includes Fabiano
arwano lenier Dominguez and others but
when they were oh and two Robert I
predicted that if a team is to come back
from Owen 2 and make the playoffs it is
the St Louis archbishops their top
players had been showing
uncharacteristically bad form and here
we are they won a match guess what they
win another one they're two and two so
don't count the Saint Louis St Louis
archbishops out by any means
I won't I don't think their fans will
either because as long as Fabiano
caruana the rest of the crew is playing
they will have a chance but let's talk
about the matchups we will see today
because we get a double header that's
the great thing about the pro chest
thing and we see that we start with mgd1
the Argent aragaisy LED Squad Take on
the Norway gnomes which feature David
Howell and then later today the second
half of doubleheader we get the Spain
Spanish Maniac shrimps with their great
logo taking on a fan favorite one of the
best teams in protesting history the St
Louis archbishops both teams I will try
to Stave off elimination but we are
going to start with the mgd1 versus
Norway gnomes match and what better way
to start than talking about this man on
screen Arjun era geising he's well known
to the community 2700 plus it's on a 1.5
million dollar contract with Quant box
but Dania this roster it's not all about
our generic icy what can you say about
his supporting caps far from it and we
already know that it takes a village a
big Village to win PCL matches and Arjun
has an excellent Supporting Cast at the
top we've got SL naryanan who has crept
up to almost 2700 without anybody
seeming to notice they've got underrated
players both at the bottom and at the
top of their roster I'm looking at
boscar and ariban the Beast it was 2603
but a former 2700 feet a excellent
addition mitraba guha is one of the best
Blitz players on the site he's under
2500 feet a so I would take all of these
ratings with a grain of salt and I would
say that mgd1 has excellent players both
at the top and on boards three and four
they're they don't have any weaknesses
oh okay you heard from Daniel no
weaknesses in this team's roster
construction but we have to take into
account their opponent because sometimes
chess it's a stylistic game and so as we
look at the Norway gnomes we see Chelsea
Monica a very popular streamer and the
question is will she make more magic she
has a great showing in previous week for
the Gnomes and of course David Howe I
mentioned him earlier he's a fan
favorite because he's a very popular
commentator with the Champions chess
tour so what do you make of this roster
Donna
well it's a differently constructed
roster than mgd1 each roster each team
has its own signature characteristics
obviously Chelsea Monica uh will have to
over perform her rating as she has done
already but they've got some incredibly
exciting players in the middle I'm
looking particularly at pranavi who is
by now a crowd favorite who has proven
himself and of course elham Abdul rauf
who might be an international Master but
he is an I am in name only incredibly
fearsome competitor very strong Blitz
player and Eliana of Saleh and Howell
none of those players need any kind of
introduction Robert
well done a question I have is looking
at this roster it is very International
but I see two Indian flags do you think
it's a bit awkward or maybe there's
extra motivation for pranav and Gupta I
mean Gupta not playing this week but for
pranav in particular do you feel like
he's got that extra oomph to his game
today
I definitely think he does and I think
he's also got he just kind of plays with
a chip on his shoulder you get that
sense watching him play I got that sense
watching him play when he's Untitled at
this point he's proven himself and he
already has a g and an m in front of his
names but definitely Robert I think that
when you're playing your compatriots uh
you feel that Pride you feel the pride
representing your particular team I
think pranav is arriving to this match
ready to fight
and you play much more actively than I
do but you're a renowned commentator
yourself clearly covering this match do
you think that puts extra pressure on
David Howell because most the time
people see him in front of the camera
talking about the chess games now he has
to play for himself
yeah it's it's interesting I mean David
does excellent commentary he does a lot
of it but he's also a very active player
he's he was over 2700 he's uh very
respectable 2667 now
um at this point I think he's proven
himself enough times uh competing with
the very best of them including Magnus
Carlson and handling himself incredibly
well but definitely Robert I feel that
pressure a little bit when I play uh you
know kind of proving why I'm in the
players Booth rather than the
commentators Booth so I think David is
feeling a little bit of pressure but
maybe that pressure will motivate him
even further he's an experienced player
he's a tough cookie yeah this is a
strong lineup 2700 plus Pavel El yanov
used to be 27.60 an absolute monster at
the top there but we see the rosters but
let's talk about how the teams have to
submit their lineups because you can't
just choose anyone you want you have to
have an average rating of 25.50 which
includes at least one a woman on the
lineup players over 2700 like Pavel
Eliana and argenteric icy they count as
2700 that encourages teams to have their
best players playing for them week in
and week out players under 2200 count as
2200 which means that if you want to
Stack the top boards you still need to
make that rating cap so you have to take
that into account and for the women
those that are over 23.50 they count as
just and I'm putting down air quotes
23.50 that means that you get the best
female players in the world uh the likes
that we've seen throughout the pro chess
League season a day get to occupy a spot
on the team and show their Force so it's
done specifically in this match we have
our lineups set we know who will be
playing and when you look at these
rosters from board one down to board
four what stands out to you well first
of all I did tell me it's all I believe
is a grand master elect I'm not sure if
he is over 2500 feet a live but he is an
I am in name only he is a grand master
in strength so Aditya is an excellent
board for Chelsea Monica will have her
work cut out for her I think for the
Norway gnomes it is very important for
Chelsea to score let's say at least one
upset it's crucial for Pavel ilyanov I
think to get at least three points out
of four I'm gonna Point those two as the
keys to the kingdom Robert for the
Norway gnomes great performance by El
yanov and at least one upset by Chelsea
Monica
and as we look at the ratings I mean
board four does stand out to me Dania
mgd1 with an over 200 Point rating
differential on that board whereas the
Norway gnomes have only a slight rating
lead on board three otherwise it's about
even so do you think it's going to come
down to board four or who's the X Factor
for the Gnomes
yeah it's hard to say I mean obviously
Chelsea and her ability to score upsets
is important if you pronov I mean I
always indicate him as an X Factor he
has had an up and down Pro chess league
so he also has his work cut out for him
he's facing three incredibly strong
Grand Masters I'm very excited to see
the Arjun pranav matchup that's just
going to be an exciting game so
obviously if we take the other side our
generic he basically has to carry the
team and I think for mgd1 if he scores
three and a half out of four or four out
of four he gives them every shot at
delivering the Victory and making the
playoffs but Robert this is actually a
really really even match it's very hard
to say who the favorite is honestly yeah
and as Don just saying perhaps Arjun air
guys do have to pull a Greg Jennings and
put his team on his back though but that
uh is going to be seen later we want the
community to get involved each and every
match so we have a featured question for
week four will team mgd1 play over or
under two and a half brilliant moves in
their match against the Norway gnomes
use the command to predict to submit
your predictions for a chance to win
each week of the PCL so uh that uh
voting has closed but it's what is for
this week over under two and a half what
do you think Daniel
I'm going a over two and a half you mean
with our generic I see on your team I
mean top of the buy with so many
explosive players I definitely am going
over
okay no questions about it many
brilliant moves says Dania so let's talk
about these specific lineups for round
one because we need to know what the
matchups are before we start seeing
brilliant moves and well we have no the
match score is zero zero but it is tied
don't worry everybody and as we look who
cares 1616 here yeah and you know it
doesn't matter what we start with as
long as an even score but Dania you look
at the boards here everybody wants the
white pieces Chelsea Monica purnov they
get to the top harika and Aditya on the
bottom get the white pieces so who's
board one and board two do you favorite
war that's my question
yeah I mean I mean against pranav is a
complete toss-up because pranav is a
force to be reckoned with with the white
pieces I'm excited for the Chelsea
Monica Arjun aragaisy match we have seen
Robert we've seen quite a few board four
board one upsets and I'm not just saying
it and we've seen a lot more games that
could have been an upset I just remember
Shakura mom and Yara of being one move
away uh from losing early on in the PCL
Alice Lee uh scoring some phenomenal
victories last week so wherever you look
this is not a walkover or Arjun aragaisi
I also think it's important for Pavel El
yanov to play aggressively with the
black pieces he's an incredibly strong
player uh Robert but I think for the
Gnomes to have a serious shot he will
have to take some serious risks and try
to defeat mgd1's board for Eddie Timmy
tall a DJ Mattel Drew Fabiano caruana
with the white pieces he actually had
one win two draws and a law so the board
four rating he's a grand master does
that make a big difference in these
matches
uh not particularly I think for ID to
meet all the most important thing is
confidence when you uh know for a fact
that you can compete with the top
players and draw them uh you just play
much better a d timmyself apart from
doing drawing Fabiano caruana has also
had his crack at the top guys through
all of the chess 24 events that he's
played in the last couple of years and
he acquitted himself very well he scored
many draws he was crushing me with white
and his openings are just so well suited
for the team format very solid player he
can play both D4 and E4 really wise
Beyond his years you would think he's a
60 year old you know Soviet Grandmaster
you wouldn't think he's a teenager with
his future ahead of him super exciting
player uh he is exciting and this league
is exciting the pro chess league is a
fan favorite because of the format that
we have here where it's an all play all
in a rapid time control of 10 minute
plus two second increment up to four
rounds why up two because of a team
dominates and gets eight and a half
points as a squad before the four rounds
haven't played well then the match is
over but if a round is in progress the
rest of the games continue if the tie
break is reached we will replay the
round four pairings until one team wins
we saw tie breaks uh just yesterday
excuse me two days ago in the protesting
so we're gonna get set with Arjun
aragaisi and Chelsea Monica they are
going to start the action here it's
board one for mgd1 against board four
for the Norway gnomes Dania the white
pieces Chelsea Monica do you think she's
relieved to get those white pieces or is
she just stressed she's playing a
monster in our generic IC
I think being Port four is actually not
such a bad deal because a you get great
opportunity to face players you
otherwise wouldn't face and B the
expectation on you is a little bit
lighter than the expectation on Arjun
right you score one draw you score one
win that could already be the difference
that your team needs so you've got to
adopt a growth mindset yes you gotta
expect that you're gonna lose one or two
games you have to keep your head up and
Chelsea keeping the speed up here with
an English opening causing Arjun to take
some early time and grab that pawn on C4
yeah it's interesting because I feel
like when someone takes time at the
start of a game like oh they're out of
preparation I think for Arjun eragisi
the pressure's on him it's difficult to
play against a low rated player when you
know your team needs you to score some
victory so what Arjun is doing is likely
trying to find a combative opening
rather than a solid one where Chelsea
will feel no issues
yeah solid opening isn't advisable a
narrow opening uh where you essentially
have to follow a theoretical line for a
long time is also not what Arjun wants
he's chosen a relatively unexplored
continuation this is not a very
theoretical type of position black needs
to find a way to deal with the bishop on
G2 so in these types of positions you do
see a move like Rook V8 happen pretty
often followed by B5 and eventually
Bishop B7 Black's dream is to exchange
the light squared Bishop so I think
Arjun is deciding which side of the
board he wants to play on first there's
our answer
and his Knight on D7 it's kind of
awkwardly placed right that Knight would
like to be out in C6 which means the
bishop on C8 can develop the D7 set so
Black's pieces
stepping on each other's toes in the
early going here white that's harmonious
development you have the bishop on G2
that's great that now you're developing
your Knights and I was about to say
before she played I was wondering if she
would hop her Knight to the rim then
towards the F4 Square later because the
bishop stays on its open diagonal the
engine didn't like it Dania but what do
you say
well I didn't love it I thought Knight
F3 uh was kind of the if it ain't broke
don't fix it approach because B5 in that
position I'm not gonna get bogged down
in the details there were some tactics
with Knight E5 and I think white picked
up the exchange the additional advantage
of putting the Knight on F3 was that you
could quickly open up the center with D4
which favors the side with more active
pieces speaking of active pieces Monica
saying I'm here to play
I feel like we're already in a novel
position I've never seen this before
like Knight H3 to G5 is an obscure idea
but the point is you're gonna trade off
that Knight in the center that's
actually is a thematic idea that you see
in many types of English positions so
she could just Castle right now no rush
to play 94 but once that Knight is
kicked with the move like H6 we will see
uh some Knights swap off the board and I
have to say white doesn't have any risk
at the moment and that must be a good
sign for the Gnomes
yeah this is a great position for
Chelsea she's solid healthy I mean we're
gonna have a long middle game she does
rush 94 which I really don't know
whether this was advisable because
you're right the Knight on G5 is going
to get kicked away and speaking of
stepping on each other's toes White's
Knights might be doing that soon enough
but Chelsea going full tilt on the king
side H4 as she preliminarily secures the
Knight taking the sting out of the move
H6 when she can just leave the Knight on
G5 exactly she is setting up a peace
sacrifice but this is not going to be a
peaceful Affair I think B3 Bishop B2 is
next and there will be some checkmating
threats against the black king So Arjun
plays Rook A7 which tamias doesn't
really carry a threat Donya and what if
white just plays b33 B2 and tries to
take on F6
these threats are not to be trifled with
let's pull up an announce word really
quickly and we will get to the other
games this is just such an exciting
opening if Arjun nonchalantly develops
the queen side guess what Knight takes
F6 check you can see the Evo bar
shooting up Bishop F6 the game is over
black takes back you get checkmated on
H7 that's not gonna slice that's not
gonna cut it Robert E3 the clock is
ticking for black you do not want to
make a weakening move like G6 with
White's pieces as well poised as they
are to attack the king side but I think
Chelsea she aired I mean she decided to
attack with a pawn rather with her
pieces and now that the situation has
stabilized for black I think Arjun is
much better uh because he is no longer
worried about his King getting
checkmated hit the foundation of his
position is great H5 is an overextended
Pawn later in this game so I think Pawn
to H5 by Chelsea kind of the right
Instinct but the wrong execution here
and now she is worse so while uh she
tries to figure out what to do next
let's zoom out because in the Pro chess
League every single game game is of
equal importance and as we do our bird's
eye view in the top right between pranav
and Amin Tabitha to buy it looks like a
solid Affair just to start only one
minor piece per side has been traded in
the bottom left we see what looks to my
eyes like a Caro con opening from David
Howell yeah very weird caracon and then
in the bottom right we have an exchange
Spanish between addition metal and Pablo
eliano so I think we should go to the
kerokan game between harika and David
just because this is not an opening we
see every day
no we don't and you wouldn't even be
able to tell what variation of the
karakan this comes from obviously an
exchange on D5 has occurred but in the
exchange Caro you normally see a Pawn on
C3 you're not advised to develop the
Knight to C3 now arika has learned her
basic chess principles this is just what
modern chess looks like she does have
this awkward Knight but conversely she
has the bishop pair and David hasn't
gotten his gang out of the king side
just yet but Robert to my untrained eye
if black can go 97 and Castle the
pressure on the D4 Pawn is going to get
rather annoying and the pin on the
Knight is not particularly dangerous
because you can't pressure the knight
any further so intuition here is that I
like Black's position but obviously
white is very solid and there's many
ways to defend the D4 upon if it comes
down to it
yeah you're absolutely right you would
love to be able to protect that pawn on
default with your Pawn going to C3 but
the Knight had to go out to C3 a few
moves ago if you just want to back up
there because you say the pawn is better
than C3 why not play it the queen came
out to A5 with check and just a few
turns ago and that's why the Knight went
up to C3 to protect the bishop that was
pinning the Knight so this was all part
of the plan for harika actually based on
her last move Donya I know she spent
about a minute and a half I think she's
in the realm of her preparation because
you don't make a move like Queen G4
which is naturally attacking the pawn on
G7 I feel like without knowing the ideas
in the position she's not castling she's
not developing her dark Square Bishop
instead she moves her Queen again goes
after G7 and she's trying to induce a
weakness please push your Pawn up to G6
because then give me those dark squares
I am going to go after them because you
have a Swiss cheese Pawn formation
indeed and that would make castling
kingside far less of an attractive
proposition I second your point about
preparation a lot of people think of
prep as a binary either you're in
preparation or you're out of it that's
not necessarily true you could be in a
position uh let's say harika could have
looked at this exact position but with
the black Bishop on E7 and a lot of uh
the thought that's invested might not be
what move do I play it's is the same
move that would be good with a bishop on
E7 good in this position so you try to
understand whether small differences
impact uh the move that you're supposed
to play and here it looks like the
answer is no wow King f8 by David hell
he does not want any permanent
weaknesses on the queen side on the Kink
side and he wants to kick that Queen
ASAP with Tempo by bringing the Knight
out to F6
yeah I mean the queen is not going to
stay there for long and you may say but
you just lost the right to Castle I
don't think David's so upset about that
because he's also unpinned his Knight on
C6 let's not forget about that the only
reason D4 wasn't loose was because there
was a king on the eight and it could not
legally move but now if you kick the
queen out of there D4 will be targeted
and I feel like for now white has
everything under control because the
queen can slide one square over to H4 to
stay in line with the pawn on D4 but
things can get a bit dicey I mean the
Knight on C3 is a misplaced piece
yeah it's very easy to overcook it if
you're white forget about the D4 pawn
and your position collapses I think
Haruka should play this very calmly and
she took the words she took the moves
right out of my mouth she castles King
side and after Knight F6 you can play
Queen H4 or guess what you can just go
Queen D1 and say listen I've got the
bishop air you've got the awkward King
I'm going to reset finish my development
and kind of chill so very curious to see
what kind of approach harika takes after
Knight F6 which I assume is a given but
maybe David wants to get the night out
to E7 that's also a possibility
Yeah the more he thinks the more I agree
that Knight G to E7 up to F5 or just
reinforcing the Knight on C6 may be a
good idea that he will play so while
David thinks we know he likes to think
he gets himself in time travel quite
regularly uh we will go to our other
games uh in the top right still very
closed position between pranav and
tabatabai in the bottom right what just
happened there this okay we gotta go to
that position I just saw the move 985
and B4 played so what is going on
between Aditya metal and paveliano
well let me tell you first of all what's
going on in the clock it's all is nine
and a half minutes to pavel's five and a
half minutes and we're only 12 moves in
so this might still be the realm of
preparation for me at all that Knight on
A5 is where our eyes are uh inexorably
drawn Pavel could have captured on
passant and he decided Robert that
opening the a file was in White's favor
there was a very important line there uh
if I could show that very quickly in the
analysis board after a b a b it looks
like white drops the Knight to B6 you
have to go back to C4 and you drop the
Rook but you don't have to go back to C4
you take the pawn on C6 hitting the
queen and then the Knight very elegantly
evacuates and while doing so it captures
another Pawn that was not possible
instead Pavel chooses to keep the
tension and we go back to the live board
he has decided to Castle so the big
question here Robert is the Knight a
strength or is it a weakness
but before I get into that I'll just say
it's a nuisance that's the biggest thing
that's for sure it keeps the queen tied
down to the B7 pawn and if the pawn
pushes the B6 C6 Falls so black actually
can't kick the Knight out of there very
easily
um the pawn 85 is under attack right now
so I think first step is Knight to D7
but we'll be surprised when Pablo plays
the move C5 you have double pawns which
you'd like to get rid of anyway but this
means the Knight on A5 is a bit loose
and the Knight does have the C4 Square
to return to but you don't really want
to play Knight C4 in most positions
because black will snap off that Knight
on C4 and double White's Pawn so both
sides may end up with double C pawns a
lot of strategical decisions to make
here for both sides as well as a big
tactical decision uh which is whether
and if so when to play the move d4 and
open up the center with Black's Queen uh
occupied on the queen side it might be a
good idea to try to open up the center a
d10 takes a similar approach but he he
does it without the center I actually I
usually think he might be eyeing f open
up the bishop don't fall asleep on
Black's King it might look safe now
Robert but with the queen potentially
coming out to H4 there will be some very
nasty maid threats and Pablo also has to
deal with the positional threat of
Knight takes C6 he has to decide whether
he's willing to accept further damage to
his Pawn structure
but really good eye by you that the
queen on B8 does not help the king all
the way on the other side of the board
so Aditya says let's go it's my time to
attack you and rookie ate a very calm
measured approach from a veteran
Grandmaster like eliano I think what he
a ditch is aiming for is let me take on
E6 now I can play my knight back to C4
safely at any moment and that means that
I have the healthier Pawn structure F4
is not out of the equation after that so
Daniel I think that just take on E6
bring the Knight back to C4 and then
play for F4 white should stand better
with the uh potential to open up the
position the side that has the pawn
breaks is usually the side with the
advantage but I have to take us away
here because I'm just noticing another
game
looks like it's nearing its conclusion
unfortunately for all the chess Chelsea
Monica fans out there in the top left
that game is not going her way done yet
I mean this is a position we did not
expect to see she was supposed to be on
the attack now her King is stuck in the
center and all of Black's pieces are
Marching forward
all of the horrors started with move 12
H5 Everett if she had put the accent on
finishing her Queen side developing B3
really better there we saw it according
to the Eva bar instead she over extended
herself you use that word and now the
game is over Bishop takes E4 is the
final blow oh Bishop takes F2 to follow
that up with Queen H4 and the King hunt
begins beautiful technique I mean Arjun
is a surgeon in these types of positions
you said the king hunt Begins the king
hunt begins and ends immediately yeah
you're not getting anywhere in this one
and unfortunately for Chelsea Monica she
she misstepped with that H5 move now
she's just getting checkmated a
beautiful tactical sequence at the end
here there's no choice uh for what you
have to take the bishop you have no
other Robert you're wrong
there is a choice to take or yeah
exactly okay well obviously if you were
going to play on and usually you do in
team chess I know you know us top
players we don't like to get checkmated
but sometimes you should play the
Checkmate in a team event not if you're
down all the pieces in the world sure
maybe you want to be respectful but you
know what I mean Donya it's just nice to
keep the tension whatever uh may exist
alive so I feel like she's going to you
know lose the game whether it's my
resignation or by Checkmate in just a
few turns because the path forward is
very obvious and Black's not even down
material she resigns Arjun gets that
victory for mgd1 but for Chelsea Monica
it's okay it was just the first game
it's a learning opportunity for sure so
let's uh take a look around the horn
here we haven't even given the top right
game any of our attention and pranav he
just leapt forward with his Knight to G5
he's going after the F7 pawn and I mean
Savage using his Force as well so why
don't we dive in there because the
Iranian player that means happened to
buy Dania looks like he's got everything
under control every weakness that was
targeted is now defended yeah he's got
the bishop here that's his biggest
Advantage he also has control over the a
file which is rather unimportant here
conversely white has control of this
very important score on D5 which he
would like to occupy with the Knight the
funny thing is the bishop actually has
nowhere to go this is the only parking
spot in the center so you gotta roll
with it and the big question for white
much like the Audi Tim it's all game do
you play F4 and try to open up the king
side this could very easily backfire
because it involves weakening White's
own King right now though black is
threatening to take twice on G5 so white
might not have any other choice playing
Knight F3 here seems pretty
underwhelming and it sort of allows
black to get his pieces back into the
game three and a half minutes for pranav
and let's see if he steps on the gas
pedal you don't have to tell him twice
but look at top of the buyer responding
instantly that that was the most
shocking part of that to me like you
were talking I was like okay now I'm
getting revved up and it means that yeah
no I got this under control a quick King
G7 you have to watch out because F6 can
hit you when you're not expecting it and
then where's that Knight going it can't
go to H3 because the bishop on D7 eyes
the square and if you have to go to F3
you step in front of your own Rook which
means the F4 Pawn will be in trouble so
wow what a decision there from a mean
tablet to buy I mean was it Instinct was
it calculation I don't care what it was
it was a great move and I feel like
White's position is in danger of falling
apart and pranav is now two minutes on
the clock we know Buddy's a bullet Beast
we know that he's capable of playing
with mere seconds on his clock but Donna
a mean tablet to buy is one of the best
in the world and maybe F6 will not be
fun for white
I mean it's simply not top of the buying
what white has to sell here King G7 is
one of those moves that we take for
granted from the top guys they always
maintain their composure when under
serious pressure but speaking of
composure I like to move King H2 as well
I think this is prophylaxis against F6
white opens up the possibility of
dropping the Knight back to H3 is this a
glamorous move no but you keep your F4
Pawn alive Knight H3 is on the board and
now amine has to try to find a way to
put pressure on this now I'm even
thinking about Bishop C8 and queen D7
it's important also that F5 which would
be a very desirable move is not possible
because the other Knight hangs this is
such a highly charged tens position I
don't envy either player here but
particularly not white who's quite a bit
lower on the clock
but also some similar themes to the
Eliana game that one was much more
closed than this one is at the moment
but remember we're talking about that
Queen on B8 it was very far away from
the King this time it's White Queen that
is very distant from that King on H2 and
that means that some of the pawns some
of the holes in the position cannot be
covered so I look at this game here I'm
already thinking you know is it time to
take on F4 at some moment can the F6
Pawn even go up to F5 to create maximum
chaos in the center uh Mian is on the
clock he's trying to figure this out but
I feel like we have to just take a step
away here just because I'm looking at
another game and I mentioned eliano's
game his position looking better and
better there in the bottom right Dania
yeah Pablo yanov has just worked some
magic in his last couple of moves Aditi
mittal has not gotten off the ground on
the king side in fact he just got off
the ground he finally played F4 but it's
come at a great cost he's allowed first
of all black to get rid of that nuisance
uh as Robert Hess put it on A5 and he's
gotten rid of the nuisance on B5 he's
now up pawn and white doesn't have all
that much to show for it on the king
side I would not say that black is
winning here Robert White's attack could
very easily redevelop if the f-file is
open and Pablo yanov is really feeling
the burn on the clock maybe it's time to
make white feel the burn on the queen
side with a move like C4
wow C4 just throwing that pawn forward
there's a pin from A7 to G1 the A3 Pawn
is loose in many positions uh the one
thing that keeps Addiction in this game
is the clock a Pavlo yanov is a
fantastic player but we all are not our
best selves when we have just seconds to
work out some of the complications it's
a pawn extra for black but let's let's
note that white has a potential attack
Brewing F takes E5 opens up the f file a
rook can slam down an F7 and blacks
major pieces the queen on A7 that Rook
on eight the Knight on B5 they're very
far away from that King on h8 so I could
see this one turning very quickly yeah
Mikhail tall said that his opponents can
only capture one piece at one time the
same goes for activating black you can
activate your queen or your Rook but it
takes four or five Tempe to bring all
three of those pieces back into the
defense he's trying and instead he slams
his Knight into the center Knight to D4
should Aditya take this opportunity to
open as much of the king side as he can
I think he should I think he should play
F takes E5 definitely don't want to play
F5 because the pawn storm on the king
side is going to be way too slow and C4
is coming pretty fast there we go f take
C5 on the board
but I think this is some veteran
experience here Rook takes E5 should be
eliana's move he keeps the f file close
he plays it and then the other Rook can
slide to eat your piece are getting
closer to the king side and you haven't
opened up territory for that Rook
sitting there on F1 very very good
decision by Pavlo yanov so I think that
he you know his time is not great but
his position still uh favorable with
that extra Pawn but I love the way a
ditch is playing yeah he's trying to
stir things up which is exactly what you
want to do first he chases the Knight
out of D4 now the big question is where
to put the Knight the question is
answered with Knight to D5 attacking C7
Pavel could bring his Bishop up to D6
but C4 could be a really nasty Robert
I'm looking at some sacrifices on F6 and
with one minute on the clock I think
this is anybody's game probably
definitely much better on the board can
Aditya stir up some Chaos on the clock
I think he plays C4 at any moment to
open up that Bishop but I actually like
King G2 because C4 there would have been
an automatic reply of Knight D4 even if
objectively C4 was the right choice and
now it very well should definitely is
the Pod and The Rook on E5 I feel like
black will have easier play and with
addition up on the clock here maybe a
quiet move like Queen F2 just slide your
queen closer to the king side pin the
pawn on C5 will you play C4 will you
play D4 that remains a question that
pava will have to answer and he just
doesn't have that much time so I feel
like if you're a fantastic bullet player
and we know the players in this league
often are that you just keep your
opponent on their toes don't give them
any easy choices and by the way down
after Queen F2 there may be Knight takes
F6 next
oh and there might be Knight takes F6
even here Pablo immediately sacrifices
The Exchange a worthy price to pay for
this bishop I don't think that adito
should immediately grab on E5 Robert
Knight takes up six here should be very
seriously contemplated if you're Brazen
enough I would play this move fast and
make Pavel calculate the ramifications
that Bishop is a monstrosity after The
Rook captures on F6 the Knight will hang
The Rook will hang I don't envy Bible at
all take that what baby on F6 at etia
I think he will the fact that he's
thinking here he's not just taking this
Rook on E5 I think Bishop takes E5 is a
strategically losing decision because
you just allow that Knight to plant
itself there now the king feels very
safe on h8 without the pressure on the
diagonal and then the D file will have
some pressure on as well with C7 to C6
coming so I think that Knight takes F6 a
great move and I think someone like a
mean tab to buy would have sacrificed
this Knight 20 30 maybe a minute ago I
don't know when it would have happened
but it would have happened already but
you could sense some of the tension some
of the nerves here because Pablo Eliana
is a super gym if Knight takes F6 is not
objectively good we have the eval bar we
know it's probably good adisha doesn't
if it's bad Pablo eliano will punish you
he is 2700 Plus for a reason
well Aditya might be worried about Rook
takes T3 but that's nothing to worry
about it's a one move threat you can in
fact the queen wants to slide over to
the f file let alone all of the back
rink issues the blackhead experience
with the undefended bishop you're right
I think against someone like V pranav
against the 2300 that night would have
been on F6 Millennia ago but when you're
facing a guy with a seven in the
hundreds digit of his rating just you
get nervous you start doubling triple
checking things even though your
intuition is screaming to play the
movement no he doesn't do it he lets
pibo plant the Knight on D4 and now the
bishop is fully canceled out and Knight
takes F6 is a completely innocuous move
yeah just now the attack whatever you
hope it to be is too slow
is a threat it is but at some point you
know C6 is going to happen not now
because if Knight takes up six we were
just talking about that but C6 will be
available to Black it's Queen A6 maybe
it's even better that is this great
defense bringing the queen to defend F6
but also attacking the C4 Pawn all at
once and that's what great players do
multi-purpose moves Rook F2 where's that
Rook going I think you can even Slide
the queen on over to E6 the king is
feeling extra safe tucked away in the
corner now it is and now black has a lot
of low-hanging fruit that he could put
but again you have to be careful about
accidentally allowing Knight takes F6
probably doing everything possible to
eliminate all of these Shenanigans he
brings his Queen into the center guess
what Robert he's activated all of the
three pieces which used to be stranded
on the queen side now they're in the
center actively participating in the
defense of the king he's making more
progress there goes the knight from D5
that was White's last remaining strong
piece yeah no this is a problem right
now for digimatal going the wrong way
trajectory all you know the honest fear
but let's go away from this game for a
moment because
buddy look at this game in the top right
he is completely winning against Amin
tab to buy now it's not just the eval
bar that helps us know that he is
winning as we go to that game we see
that the oh Queen G6 check wait
cold-blooded
oh but is it totally winning here after
King G7 can black Mount some sort of a
fortress with the Rook on B7 you know
I'm taking time into account perhaps
there is a way in some Universe to
defend uh but it just feels like it has
to be a win for white like just take on
D6
we're gonna get a swap but then the
black king is Frozen uh just trying to
stop that g pawn and that's a runaway
password yeah this is just gonna be a
matter of time
I feel like black has to try Rook B7 put
the Rook behind one of his pawns he
pushes it immediately white has this
tactical idea running the Jeep on up the
board That's a classic breakthrough if
you can get two of your Pawns of the six
rank you win but do you play Rook C7
first no you play Rook C7 only when you
have to
and yeah there's no there's no rush C3
uh Rook C7 you just stopped upon the
white king will go up to H4 maybe even
up to H6 and deliver Checkmate you could
have even played G5 but why play with
fire Rook C7 is cautious G5 is good you
don't fear okay but he's eliminating all
of the threats no discover check and I
mean almost let his time run out you
could even take the pawn if you want it
to be extra safe
but I'm just oh just don't get yourself
mated G7 no King H7
and then when you do queen a king G6 oh
my goodness
and what presence of mind what
cold-bloodedness by Bruno it's still not
over
no this one but it should be just with
the two pods F6 happening next to block
the check and then opponent is going to
promote so you see on meets happens by
his face he is more or less resigned in
this position and he's about to resign
uh by clicking on that button so it's a
win for pranav and look at that fist
pump he is happy there's a big smile big
smile yeah
oh that's good to see you know if tough
for it I mean but great for pranav and
MGD oh my goodness in the bottom left
the position was winning for harika just
a few moves ago but David Howell with no
time on his clock somehow he's surviving
here done it if you just click back a
few moves I mean we might have to look
after the game hariculous completely
winning
yeah she was let's we'll probably stick
to the live board for now she was
completely winning in that end game
we'll definitely look at that after this
game ends but we're approaching total
time scramble phase David Howell is
playing for the win and harika might be
losing it losing the her cool here as
she drops the pawn on D6 and now black
is playing for the win white has to push
the sea Pawn ASAP right now go C5 and
it's actually a three result game here
but should be a draw
it should be but Shoulda Woulda Coulda
and the pro Chesley in these rapid
formats uh you make one mistake and the
game slips out of your hands but the
good news for harika she's been doing
very well on the clock so here I would
like to see the move Queen D6 offer
Queen Creek she goes here Queen A1 check
watch out you could find yourself
blundering your queen for either side I
don't like this move though because it's
all about who gets the pawn to the third
rank first I think David should play E3
harika should have enough there to check
the king into Oblivion but there's no
way the black escapes the checks and no
need for David to do anything crazy he
forces the draw you you said it Robert
he was completely lost just 10 moves ago
with no time on his clock I can rewind
uh to right around move 40 54. this is a
completely winning punt end game
oh arka should have just taken here
oh and she promotes with Jack and she
can't believe it look at her she
promotes with Jack she just noted that
you could see on her face she's like
what was I thinking uh but to put this
in perspective everybody I think the
reason she didn't take on F5 is just put
that position on the board for a second
yeah the black king is inside the box so
you may be worried that the black king
will hunt down this Pawn but you always
have moves like C5 check not easy to
calculate when you don't have that much
time if she had five minutes on her
clock she would have spotted this no
issues but with just a minute on the
clock you're trying to play quickly
trying to play in your opponent's time
trouble you missed things like that so
of course she's a fantastic player she
had a winning position I guess someone
as strong as David Howell G5 and Lefty
right win slips out of her hands
yourself first taking only a second on
that move but as you said Coulda Woulda
Shoulda the round is over in the Norway
gnomes have a one point lead this match
could have been tied with a harika win
is that game Robert going to turn out to
be of crucial importance it's way too
early to tell
but every single half point in the
protesting typically is of great
importance and let's give a shout out
credit where it's due pranav buddy you
said he was The X Factor for the Norway
gnomes he beats Amin tabatabai so the
lone Indian player in the Norway gnomes
lineup takes out the lone non-indian
player from team mgp1 that is a team
based in India so he's saying hey next
year Call My Name put me in your roster
yeah you didn't draft me your loss says
for nav and that smile on his face at
the end of the game it said it all top
of the buy played a fantastic game he
had more time on the clock and somehow
prernoff kept his composure and
channeled his incredible blitzkill into
a crucial Norway gnomes Victory they
lead by a point they could not have
asked for a better start against a
Powerhouse 2-1 team
and we just saw a feature chat from team
manager Yoon Ludwig Hammer he is
thrilled to see his team with a one
point lead we'll see if mgd1 can catch
up but first we go to a break and win
return it's the second round of action
here in this protesting match between
mgd1 and the Norway gnomes
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
International Master Danny wrench Chief
chess officer back again with more chess
terms here for you today we're going to
talk about the past Pawn the past Pawn
must be pushed you hear it said often
and that's because just about every end
game you see that isn't a blowout often
comes down to maybe someone's up one
Pawn or maybe even just the first person
to create a past Pawn is the person who
goes on to win that game we're going to
talk about what the past Pawn is and to
find it for you in today's video let's
do it what is a past Pawn a past Pawn is
a pawn that has no enemy pawns stopping
it from moving forward that means pawns
either on the file in which it resides
or on the adjacent files that would
therefore capture the pawn should it
advance so if a pawn has none of those
things stopping its way then it's time
to push them baby as our boy Yasser
would say it as you hear mentioned on
many broadcasts that you would watch on
chess TV and on that note as we look at
our game examples we like to do this is
taken from Thomas chefsky versus rajaba
here white plays the move B5 5x Glam
which highlights again it's not how many
pawns you have but who's going to be
threatening to get a queen first after
black takes it white pushes forward with
gusto and because the Rook can't
blockade the pawn due to the light
Square Bishop this game is already over
black is going to have to sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn on B6 and white
would simply be up a minor piece no note
that after the first move B5 should a
takes B5 have been played white would
have pushed this pawn and then trap The
Rook on A7 showing the power of the pass
Pawn as with it protecting the bishop
this Rook is completely out of the game
and white would easily go on to win
picking up pawns and just flexing the
rook's muscles over the bishop for the
rest of the game so here we see a pass
flaw being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Arjun aragaisy board one for team mgd1
sporting the pro chess League t-shirt
let us know chat do you think Arjun can
lead them back in this match because
Arjun Eric icy and he is a known name in
The Chess Community should be no
surprises that he has had some excellent
results thus far in the protest League
he's had eight wins two draws and three
losses that doesn't include his most
recent win he's the 2022 Indian national
champion he was the winner at Tata steel
India Blitz are We Done Yet we could go
on and on and on with his list of
accomplishments his pedigree is
unimpeachable and these are just his
accomplishments from the past two years
he had an up and down a mediocre
performance at the last taught of steal
and just the fact that we singled that
performance out tells you how insane
Arjun Eric icy has been the last years
it's been one tournament Victory after
another I feel like Arjun was never 2600
it's like he went from 2500 to 20 27 30.
in the blink of an eye he is one of the
most exciting Juniors to watch everybody
agrees on that and he is such a great
asset for mgd1 and a great win to boot
in round one
he got that dub in his first game let's
see if he's able to do that in round two
because the matchups get more difficult
for the bored ones you start with board
four for the enemy team now you see he
gets the white pieces against board
three guess who buddy pranav he won that
first game he's feeling on cloud nine so
now donya's you look through the
matchups here in round two the top
boards get the white pieces whose top
boards have the better shot
well beepernov is confident and
confident vipranov is particularly scary
Arjun really obviously should win this
game he's got the white pieces he is the
heavy favorite but man when pranav is
feeling confident I mean he really can't
beat anybody he's one of those 2500s who
has the capacity and the Tactical Acumen
to score and upset against someone like
aragaisy so I'm very excited about this
game Robert I was talking about it
before the match started and for the uh
for the Gnomes fourth four Chelsea
Monica important to keep that growth
mindset and to realize that she's
playing to gain experience and even a
single draw would be huge for the Gnomes
winning chances seat belts fasten folks
round two is underway
and look at this we have a trumpovski
knight e Ford's response C5 this is the
way you play against this opening white
has already developed the dark Squad
Bishop Allah the London system but you
flick into check provoke C3 drop the
knife I feel like this opening in
particular is one of if not the hardest
to explain to newer chess players
nothing makes sense it goes against kind
of every single principle white has
moved that Bishop twice black has moved
the Knight three times first F6 then to
E4 back to F6 the queen is already
moving twice and has moved out Bishop
your Bishop back to C1 right how do we
explain this to our players who are less
Advanced utter chaos Anarchy in the
position none of the moves make sense a
lot of the moves cancel each other out I
think that's important to understand for
example the knight move to E4 and then
it was chased back with F3
mathematically the Tempe cancel each
other out because both sides essentially
move to piece twice white moves the dark
scored Bishop now three times but also
Black's Queen moved two times so you
have movement with a lot of the same
pieces Robert but those Tempe losses
essentially cancel each other around and
what we have as a result is some sort of
benoni structure but another crazy move
by black Bishop to D6 you're looking at
this and saying what the heck I was
taught not to do this what about the
light squirt Bishop what about the
lights dude is shake my head but you're
trying to take advantage of that move
Pawn F2 to F3 white has developed zero
pieces look at that uh first rank there
not a single piece is off the first rank
excuse me Black's about to castle made
by rookie 8 check perhaps the queen will
slide back to C7 Donya and hit the H2
pawn and if you want to go to pawn G3
after Queen z7 I may sack on that square
and go after the white king I honestly
look at this position and if you made me
go full Levy Rosman Gotham chest guess
the ELO
I don't know what I would say
yeah 500 versus 700 1500 versus 1700 or
25 versus 2700 that is approximately
equivalent a likelihood when you see the
course of this game I'm also stunned by
the e-ball bar but now that I see our
generic icy's last move I'm beginning to
understand why Bishop D6 might have
actually been a mistake but pranav is
banking on the quick e-file attack but I
think he's underestimated the impact of
two things a the Knight coming to C4
introducing disruptions in Black's piece
coordinations and B the elephant in the
room Robert is this bishop on CA you're
not going to win this game without
developing your queen side and it's kind
of hard to find a spot to drop your dark
squared Bishop to especially if the
queen is going to be occupying C7 so
it's it's anybody's game position is
still tremendously complex but it
appears that objectively white does have
the upper hand here despite his lack of
development
but neither side truly knows the ins and
outs of this position they're spending a
lot of time for a top player 10 moves
into the game so they're trying to work
this out just like the rest of us Knight
E2 the Evo bar going back towards the
center I think black can just play
rookie eight and just try to develop and
occupy the open file but while the
players think here let's zoom out
because all four games are underway for
the second round of action here in the
top right early going in the one between
a means having to buy and Chelsea Monica
in the bottom left the same but that's
an English opening from Pavel El yanov
and then in the bottom right well that
just got started David Howell he's
essing the Royal Lopez Spanish in the
bottom right so Daniel I feel like the
game we're on is by far the most
interesting because it's an open
position but anything of note to you in
the other games
well a means game uh is kind of
interesting because Chelsea has that
light squared Bishop on H5 which is not
standard in Italian and Lopez structures
and that is often a detriment to Black
so maybe we can briefly explain why that
is before transitioning uh back to our
top board so this came from an Italian
and it might seem self-evident Robert
that you want the bishop on this
diagonal to pin the Knight and curb uh
White's Mobility on the king side but it
actually has the opposite effect and the
reason why as illustrated by a means
last move is that after the Knight gets
to G3 this bishop actually experiences
tremendous discomfort you do not want to
hand white the bishop pair and a queen
on F3 but dropping back to G6 means
consigning the bishop to a life of total
passivity staring at the E4 pawn and
possibly even worse after the Knight
comes to H4 black can't even play H6
I'll show an illustrative line if we
could pull up an analysis board how
quickly this could get bad right rookie
8 Knight G3 Bishop GC six and white can
really steamroll black on the king side
if Chelsea is not careful can't go H6
because you dropped the bishop and the F
Pawn is pinned so is that an accurate
assessment Robert of why the bishop uh
it's actually poorly placed on this
diagonal
not all great points and I think we're
seeing in the game she's recognizing
that she could have some strategic
issues so she wants to turn this into
more of a tactical melee playing D5
let's open up the board if white decides
to say take on D5 then you're saddled
with this Pawn on D3 which can be
targeted sometimes you do just take on
D5 because it frees up the E4 Square for
your knight and the point is that
White's pieces White's forces are about
to go towards the king side and for
black uh this there are a little bit
things in the position that don't add up
well the Knight on C6 is defending the
pawn E5 and it's dominated by The Pawn
on C3 it can't hop forward so I really
like these positions for white I feel
like there are slight pluses here and
don't count out the idea of Bishop A4
you may be thinking oh my position is
very healthy as black my pawns are
defended I'm trying to open up the
center but Bishop A4 could hit you where
it hurts the Knight on C6 is defending
the pawn E5 and maybe I can remove the
guard
yeah white has ample activity on both
sides of the board Knight F1 and ig3 is
likely coming next but you point out
Bishop A4 and maybe even b4th Queen side
expansion as a sort of bonus idea I
don't see any good way for Chelsea to
transform her Central activity into
something tangible maybe you play this
classically and play Queen D7 and Rook
88 but what does that do even if the D
file opens up there's nothing on the D
file and White's Knight is going to be
on G3 in the span of two moves so the
time situation the position on the board
not favoring Chelsea in the early going
good Italian play by aminas he totally
ignores
the movement of the a pawn I thought he
would play A4
but instead he sticks to his kingside
plan
yeah I think he's just he's playing
quickly that's his goal in this game he
lost the first one so he's trying to use
the clock as a weapon and well right now
it is a I don't even know what's that a
three and a half minute lead for Amin
and Chelsea's playing very well this is
rapid so the time difference is
consequential but it's not all important
just because she has so much time
remaining and she is playing active
chess finally amine slows down so let's
zoom out for a second because I want to
point a couple things out here in the
bottom right I don't want to go into
that game just because it's standard
opening fare adichie Mattel has more
time than he started with against David
Howell so he is in familiar territory
but in the top left I know we haven't
been able to dive into the games of the
Bottom Road there between alyanov and
harika and Howell and Aditya matal but
let's look at the top left this position
is crazy Dania it's crazy and it seems
to be getting crazier even though some
pieces have come out of the gates
especially for white no Clarity is being
added to the position it's just getting
more and more chaotic uh whether you
look at the queen side the center or the
king side Robert I don't know what's
going on on either side of the board the
one thing I can say for certain is that
g is that G5 is actually a huge threat
because believe it or not and it's hard
to believe the Knight is trapped so
black has to address that Bishop B7 is
one way to address that because it
threatens Knight takes D5 but how easy
is it to play a nonchalant move like
Queen B6 oh let's increase the pressure
on the night
you will have no Knight after G5 and
it'll be good night
okay that is enough no no but that
you're honestly I need the puns because
I can't understand what's happening in
this game I mean so far it's 15 moves in
and maybe like three have made sense
that they were probably the first three
moves of the game because I have never
seen a position like this before where
White's King remains in the center
Black's King safely tucked away this
feels like what not to do when you're
taught how to play chess you don't just
throw your pawns forward and not develop
your pieces but our generic Geist he's
done it for a reason he does have this
Advanced Pawn on D5 it's kind of a thorn
in Black side I do think that black can
Target that pawn maybe with Bishop B7 as
you mentioned earlier just trying to get
after this Pawn on D5 but in the long
run right if white can safely bring the
king to F2 let's say develop the light
Square Bishop bring the Rook to E1
things of that nature maybe then we
could start talking about white having
the edge because of the control that a
lot of the pawns have but I just feel
like it's a flimsy construct I just feel
like we're going to see White's position
potentially fall apart in the near
future
we very well might but it's a big
decision right now for pranav he's down
to 524 as he and ketosis Bishop
immediately followed by King F2 the evil
bar dropping even further maybe it's
because of the possibility of C4 and
Bishop C5 but King F2 renews the threat
of G5 so how does black address the
threat and simultaneously improve his
agenda in terms of attacking the D5 pawn
and pressuring White's king that's a
hard question to answer
I think we're going to see an exchange
sacrifice so C4 looks really strong to
me you welcome the move G5 and then you
sack that Rook on E3 take on D5 the
position opens up and with a king on F2
it's only opening up in Black's favorite
now white would have extra material but
for that material black has an attack
Brewing so I do feel like C4 is a worthy
move here just go for that exchange
sacrifice
yeah I was gonna make some coffee I was
gonna Brew some coffee but with this
attack I don't need any more caffeine
this is as stimulating as it gets but
pranav it's so easy to fall into the
Trap of taking too much time there he
goes great call Robert he sacks The
Exchange immediately so rather than
advancing C4 he takes immediately the
advantage of that is that the D4 square
is still covered so Bishop D4 is not
possible if Arjun wants to keep the
bishop he has to go even more passive
and open up a potential Avenue to his
King
this is looking wild and well while we
have a moment and while we need somebody
to help us work through the
complications we're going to bring on
the Norway gnomes team captain we have
Anna Rudolph joining us Anna first of
all it's been a while how are you doing
it's been a while how are you guys doing
I've been watching the show you guys are
always killing it there's no need to
compliment you because honestly you're
like the best out of the best one you
can have as commentators so thank you
for having me thank you for letting me
join
and I just want to know we did not pay
Anna to say that so that uh
later so it's it's okay PayPal credit
card I accept that Bitcoin Maybe
well we'll work on that later you know
first we're just gonna ask you so what's
it been like you know rooting on this
Norway team you've had some of the most
exciting matches and probably some of
the most heart-wrenching matches as well
yeah um I think both hammer and me have
had um I don't want to exaggerate like
near heart attack moments but yeah we've
been sweating a lot and it's not for the
heat
um but in a good sense because we were
always so close to almost losing and
then bringing it back from the dead it
feels amazing when it's that way and not
that you are winning and suddenly you
are not so I think we even though we've
gone through a lot emotionally the
players the captains the the everyone
who's rooting for the Gnomes they know
where we have been
um but it's good that the nose always
manage to come out on top and that's
what we hope for today we are leading we
are leading
I think it's very possible and on
vipranov is playing brilliantly right
now brilliantly against Arjun Eric icy
he's in time pressure but you can see
the evil bar dropping Anna can you talk
a little bit about what V pronov brings
to the team and how exciting it is to
have one of those incredibly underrated
Juniors on the Norway gnomes
honestly it's awesome Everyone is always
like Prana Prana body and that he's so
underrated which is true and I think
it's the case with a lot of Junior
players that are still very much in the
rising um stage of their career he is so
strong already but his rating honestly I
think could be higher but right now we
we take it with what he has you know it
counts for the rating average so hammer
was really smart recruiting the players
for the team I helped with some of them
but most of the players are thanks to
Grandmaster Hammer the manager of the
team and I think that was very smart
strategy to have pranav as one of our
main carry players in terms of he's so
strong and a junior and the rating
matches perfectly the rest of the
players ratings for the average
well and I mean speaking specifically
about this match he won game one that
was great but this here in game two and
we see the eval bar saying he is just
crushing it but we all know from playing
and commentating things may be more
difficult than they appear so what do
you make of this position obviously
Black's King is safer whites has extra
material do you think it's you know as
good for black as the Evo bar would have
us believe
I sure hope so I think if I had to play
this game I uh I would be perhaps not as
confident as pranav is to say the least
but I have full confidence that even
though he is a bit lower on time and he
might be nervous that he's playing
against such a top Grand Master as our
generic guy says also a junior still
obviously very much in as we said about
pranav Arjun is also I don't think at
his Peak peek rating he's he's still
improving he's still getting to the very
very top of the of the chest Elite
um so a very scary opponent we have been
afraid of Arjun but I think if one can
upset Arjun that's gonna be proud of not
just because of what I see in the
evaluation part honestly that's that's
amazing to see but because he's so
talented and he's so motivated I think
he's especially motivated to show what
he's capable of against Arjun
that was a great description and I would
only add that I think he uses his
tremendous Blitz skill to his Advantage
as well it's so important to be able to
maintain your composure and time
pressure and that is where all of those
sweaty late night Blitz and bullin
sessions on chess.com really come in
handy
he's got a different Dragon to slay
because lack against Arjun this would be
such a big win and all he might have
gone a little bit wrong here wow
um I'm not fully wrong but yeah lots of
sweaty uh Late Night speed test sessions
on chess.com that's very true and uh oh
man I hope I hope that this is still all
right what do you guys think let me know
I I'm getting nervous
I feel like I feel like it still looks
really good for black to me and the one
thing is the time situation is evening
up it has been a huge lead on the clock
for Arjun even though it disadvantaged
on the board and Donnie I know you want
Queen A4 but there's like Knight E3
check to figure out because if you take
on E3 Queen takes B2 as an Intermezzo
perhaps I don't really know what's going
on I'm just throwing out ideas because
that's how we often play chess looks
good but you need to actually find
something concrete
yourself
I am just hoping I didn't jinx it that I
was already celebrating that if anyone
get upset Arjun it's gonna be it's gonna
be pranav I hope that I I did not do any
harm it's it's one of those three more
courses or Captain curses so I'm gonna
take it back this game is not decided
yet but I'm confident that front of
he's got this he's got this and the team
the team has got this off we have an
amazing team the players that are
playing today and the overall uh Squad
um that we have I think
I'm very biased but I'm incredibly proud
of the Norway gnomes how they have done
so far and what we are capable of for
the playoffs as well
we need to win today
I mean that is just fantastic team
spirit you of course are an amazing
captain and we know you're having a
watch party so everyone who's here you
should go check out Anna's Channel I'm
sure you already know her and are
following her because if not I'm looking
at all you but Anna we just want to say
thanks so much for joining us and we
hope you know for your sake you're such
a good person that your team brings you
uh some good news and some Joy so uh
thanks so much and we'll be looking out
for your stream and you know go gnomes
right
go gnomes thank you so much for saying
that unbiased commentators as I love to
be myself too I wish you guys the best
for the rest of the show and hello to
everyone watching on chess.com on all
sorts of platforms I'm going back to my
watch party but I hope that at the end
of the match we all gonna be celebrating
the nerves go Norway now only done
forever not biased
all right thanks so much
yeah you guys can join the watch party
after just when you're done with your
gig just come over celebrate
all right we will indeed with Anna
thanks so much and have a great one
thank you
see you guys so don't think that
I thought she was gone go team mtd1 I
thought oh she's still here what MGD one
is the best
friends
who is this guy
he's back well we were kind we were kind
while she was on screen now that she's
gone you know we could talk about her
behind her back uh you know we don't
root for anybody but we do root for Anna
Rudolph because she's amazing such a
great presence in the chess community
and she is streaming a watch party as
Hammer has been in the chat but look at
this position it's getting crazier and
crazier the King on G2 is wide open the
bishop on B7 staring through the D5
Knight towards the White Queen and then
the pawn on F3 as well so Knight E3
check is a big threat to pick up this
White Queen in the center I don't
actually know what Arjun can do here his
position looks terrible and by the way
let's we're gonna have to zoom out we'll
probably come right back here but look
at what's going on in another game we
see Chelsea Monica in the top right in a
completely winning end game against Amin
tablet
huge for the Gnomes
shall we go to that game quickly to
describe how winning this end game is
because it seems deceptively complicated
both sides with a pass Pawn the big
difference is in the is in Mobility
Robert Black's Pawn uh Black's King is
fully limiting the mobility of the
d-pawn whites King is nowhere to be
found the path for the black d-pawn is
completely clear do you see any way for
a mean to complicate the game here also
just point out that after black plays D3
the G4 Pawn also hangs with check could
potentially be important I think we
should bring up an analysis board
because my first instinct is to play
Rook E7 and after D3 play Rook takes G7
and say my knight will stop the pawn and
I'll sacrifice my knight for it but
after D2 Knight back to E3 I think I
just can win this Knight right can I
play like rookie four and take your
knight
and that's the big problem if you play
Knight D1 you lose the Knight but you're
not able to get the pawn in return King
F1 not fast enough Rook takes C3 cuts
off the king and promotes the pawn Rook
giechik useless because the king is
simply going to capture the pawn this is
game over if this position is reached I
was thinking Robert after D3 maybe you
should try Knight takes G7 with a threat
of Checkmate but here look at this line
King F1 Knight D2 check is forced mate
after Knight F3 either way and Rook G1
moves are being made though so let's
rewind back to the live board
uh okay rookie four and she just gave a
check to break the pin it was D3 and
it's over crushing
oh 83. goodness D2 and rookie one right
the key is not to promote and allow
white to give the Knight up for the pawn
and start hunting for black spawns and
even that might still be Winnie for
black to be clear but there's no point
at getting in that position you're just
gonna give up your Rook for the night
get a queen there is nothing that a mean
Tabitha body can do about it which means
he is going to plummet to O out of two
in his matches that's not what you can
expect it's not what you need you just
can't afford it from your board too and
Chelsea Monica she was a hero in the
previous matches now she is going to be
a hero once again and Dunya if you said
Arjun era geisi Amin tap it to buy with
the white pieces they're gonna lose to
pranav and Chelsea Monica
wow
this is what I said from the start as
the board for a well-placed upset could
be the difference between a win and a
loss for your team Chelsea suffering a
tough defeat in round one at the hands
of Argent aragaisi but she didn't
despair she had a good position out of
the opening of that game she let that
give her more confidence and what
confidence she is playing with in round
to 20 seconds for amine as he
desperately searches for some way to
complicate the game the only remaining
trap Robert is to play rookie seven but
Chesley Chelsea could move her Knight
back at the right moment that would have
done the sting out of 96 and would end
the game yep look at the top left the
game is in time trouble and completely
winning for Buddy pronounce there's a
king on H3 and it's about to get
checkmated it's it's made I mean he gets
one move off in Bishop to G4 but this
has to be game over
Queen F3 King H4 Arjun he is an escape
artist I've lost so many of these
positions against him H3 his King is
actually not checkmated yeah Rook F4
H5 is coming queen F2 Queen F2 which was
that queen queen
I guess the king runs to F2 but then
Queen H2 should be made and then Queenie
two rookie three rookie three
unbelievable
and you see Arjun he shakes his head but
pranav with a second huge win in a row
oh and another smile oh that's awesome
oh my goodness this guy is unbelievable
he's got swag you saw that look he's
just like yeah I just did that I think
he's in disbelief but you should all be
Believers in pranav's chess
unbelievable what a display of tactical
resilience and composure by the
scintillating Indian Grandmaster I think
we should go back to the Chelsea Monica
game because she could hammer in the
nail here with an incredible upset
Victory with the black pieces she is on
the doorstep of promoting King D7 and
she is going to basically pre-move Rook
takes C3 I mean he's gonna let his time
run out oh my goodness and another smile
I mean can't believe it
he's trying to hold it back you know she
knows that she's on camera she wants to
show respect to her opponent but let it
out come on be joyous absolutely you
just just took down one of the best
chess players in the planet with the
black pieces the Norway gnomes have won
two with black but look at the bottom
left on you harika dronavali says not so
fast we see David Howell winning with
the white pieces in the bottom right
she's just one she's one she's ended
that game so harika she couldn't finish
off David Howell in the first game she
takes down Super Jam pava Eleanor here
so great showing from the mgd1 board 3
but unfortunately for mgd1 the bad news
it's getting worse Aditya matal in this
position is about to get checkmated if
Eliana had defeated harka this would
have been a 4-0 win in round two so
harika's win is the lone bright spot for
mgd1 that keeps them in the match this
position is completely lost it might not
seem Lost Robert
but that last move F3 that's a double
exclamed move right there it gets The
Rook to H2 anytime the king steps onto
G8 it gets forked with 97 at this point
block probably has to give up The Rook
for the night but that's tantamount to
resigning 17 seconds though for David so
I think Aditya should take the Knight
and hope for some sort of mouse slip
yeah but you saw the pre-move there from
David Howe the look of determination in
his eyes he knows what he needs to do
right now his King is quite safe The
Rook can still slide to H2 and there may
be some back Rank checkmates and I don't
know about that move A5 oh it pushes G4
he wants Rook H2 Queen E7 Queen d8
checkmate
well and he can also just capture the A5
Pawn if he wants to keep things safe and
sound he goes B5 he probably wants to
take these pawns with the queen B6
creates a pass pawn and basically
decides the game
multiple ways to do it but a digital
wants a night sack he's gonna play
Knight takes G4 here it's going to be a
losing position there's no denying that
but you have to try something like that
because the position is hopeless if you
don't get some attacking chances against
the white king the problem would be that
The Rook could have blocked the check
but I agree he goes passive mode with
the Knight to E8 holding the C7 square
with everything that he's got and now
the queen comes out but rookie 2 is
going to dash his hopes of a miracle
comeback David gives a check first on
Precision what Precision by David Howell
he wants to take that Knight with check
and not give black a free move in
response adichie Mattel is losing the
Knight he's losing this game and the
Norway gnomes are seizing control of
this match he's up a full Rook right now
Anna Rudolph has to be ecstatic right
now and she knows that this last game is
in very safe hands David hell is an
incredible time scrambler
C7 here is going to make a second Queen
there's but a meaningless check on D2 C8
equals Queen
take first ah surgical surgical
Precision get the Queens off the board
and get another point on the board for
the Norway gnomes and David Howell
proving he's not just all talk he can
walk that walk and he just walked that
pawn up towards promotion he wins the
game of full work ahead so David Howell
and the Norway gnomes are dominating in
this match you see a 3-1 score in the
second round of action look at those
wins with black on the top Boards of
course David what a nice game there but
he was the high rated player it is all
about pranav and about Chelsea Monica
and even harika jonavali with the upset
it was an upset special
three upsets out of four games
can you believe that pranav and Chelsea
both win and with the black pieces at
that Robert that is I'm looking at those
results and it still hasn't sunk in a
heroic effort by Chelsea Monica bad
position out of the opening she does not
Despair and punishes a meme for playing
too quickly in the middle game showing
that she can fight with the best of them
but vipranov my hat is off for The
Talented Indian junior he is something
special
he really is underrated uh sometimes
just players get overlooked when there's
so many talented Juniors from a country
you don't see all of them and pranav is
showing that he is up there with the
best and as we see the Norway gnomes
lead by a score of five and a half two
and a half if you ask before the match
who would be the leading scorer I don't
think we'd say harika dronavali for mgd1
she's super strong but Arjun aragaisi is
an absolute boss but really what it
comes down to to me Dania is bored too
look at a mean tab to buy zero points
from two games that just can't happen if
you're playing a team like the Norway
gnomes cannot happen he has to put the
first half of this match behind him he
has to go two out of two let's not
sugarcoat the situation but the Gnomes
they're gonna say Norway Jose they're
going to try to stick the landing and
win this match in the third round they
need three points but it's at three
points that they are going to have to
get from an angry team MGD one it's all
down to a means and uh our generic icy
and whether they can score a perfect two
out of two in the final two rounds
it's gonna be uphill sledding 14 MGD one
but we have seen crazier comebacks
happen in the protest League just like
the teams we are going to take a break
we'll refresh ourselves because when we
come back it is an exciting second half
of this match between team mgd1 and the
Norway gnomes we'll be right back
foreign
what's the first word that comes to your
mind uh the musical and of course the
board game
fantastic okay it's just a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide a battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay okay that's not the first time I've
had people hang up for me thank you
chess a sport intellectually yes okay
okay kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my hello that's a great comparison
hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on poisson
chess chess chess like the gates chess I
can beat you in chess if you beat me
I'll give you ten dollars tan ten if you
beat me I bet
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you're doing
I do know what I'm doing
I don't know what I'm doing in life
all right bro let's Checkmate oh
who's Mate who's made bro I will
unbelievable you got 30 seconds for me
quick interview come on you look like a
chess player you play chess don't play
chess okay when I say chess what's the
first thing comes to your mind winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chess dancing chess climbing chest
boxing chest climbing chest climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climbing
chess books chest boxing chest boxing
you nailed it okay am I right for real
you nailed it seriously yeah of of the
two of us one of us is a World Chess
boxing champion which one do you think
it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not I mean he does get he tried
to hit another guy earlier so
oh my God she didn't even hesitate from
now on will you stop making me do things
in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord hey everybody it's Danny here
and as you may know chess.com and
chessable are now one and I'm here to
show you how you can make your chest.com
and chessable one in just a few clicks
to start let's log in and connect our
chess.com account I just scroll right
here above the browser and click login
scroll down and click continue with
chess.com now as you're already logged
into chess.com it's just gonna ask you
if you want to approve that connection
I'm going to say yes sir but after
approving it'll bring you right back to
the chessable home page now the puzzle
connect feature can be found under Tools
and you click puzzle Connect Now what
that does after you type in your
username is it's going to pull positions
from the games you've played on
chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the stakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
accessible.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter if this one goes the distance
or ends in three rounds we will have
more chests today the Spanish Maniac
shrimps take on the St Louis archbishops
both teams looking to avoid elimination
in the 2023 Pro chess League season that
one promises to be exciting as both
teams will have to give it their all in
order to stay in the league but we are
focused right now on another matchup it
is team mgd1 down three points to the
Norway gnomes Dania it has been all
Norway and pranav he has been the hero
that Norway needs
he has indeed nobody on the Gnomes has a
score below 50 percent Pavilion have
lost the second round to drone of
aliharika but they haven't needed his
A-Plus game because prernav and Chelsea
Monica have picked up the slack what an
upset Robert with the black pieces
Chelsea defeating by and really pushing
mgd1 to the wall they have a three-point
deficit Norway gnomes could end it with
a 3-1 Victory or more
and Chelsea Monica she's a streamer she
just upsets somebody 400 points 26 50
plus opponent she took down in the
previous round but now that's the past
mgd1 knows what they have to do they
need to catch up they need to make sure
the Norway gnomes do not score three
full points and Don as we look at the
lineups we get board one versus Board
two then we get board three versus Board
four so what do you think about this one
where does mgd1 get their points from
first of all someone has to stop for
another and that someone has to be a DTM
at all in this round we've talked about
how solid he is with the white pieces he
had great chances to upset Pavel Eliana
in round one I think he needs to play a
little bit more aggressively but he's
been doing okay obviously our generic
icy black against David Howe I think he
should be solid you don't need a 4-0
victory if you're MGD one even a two and
a half one and a half Victory Robert
would bring them closer uh to a comeback
in the final round but it's a means who
has to pick up his play at the very
least he's got to hold a draw against
Eliana so for example Arjun and Amin
could draw their games and harika and
mittal could win there's a 3-1 Victory
right there I think that is the kind of
thing that the MGD one should strive for
much easier said than done though
yeah I think there is the inclination to
just go all in you have to win every
single game that's how you feel but you
are correct if you can just win this
round Say by two and a half one and a
half it's seven to five now you just
need to make up the two points just as
if it's easy and of course it's not but
you will have a chance you need to stay
in the match you don't want to get
knocked out here uh in this next round
and by knocked out I don't mean out of
the protesting both these teams have a
sparkling two-in-one record the winner
makes their way through the playoffs
they get next week off the loser they
get into that tough territory of now
it's must win for all it's kind of like
a playoffs before the playoffs as you
may face the candid chest bras led by
Magnus Carlsen you don't want that you
want to secure your spot right here and
now
you do indeed an Arjun eragisi saying I
want to unbalance the game David hell
playing a symmetrical grunfeld and
instead of responding with C6 Robert on
the last move or D takes C4 Arjun
playing uh a transposition to the
grunfels by getting his Knight out to C6
David could now take on D5 and follow
that up with E4 but Arjun clearly
playing to unbalance the game in the
early going he does not just want a
solid draw which I think David would not
be against
yeah I mean David Howell sing that half
point that gets us closer and closer to
match Victory and for David he just won
a nice game he gets the white pieces a
second round in a row and Knight C6 and
that's just not something you see every
day usually you challenge the center
with pawns rather than putting that
Knight in front of the pawn so uh Arjun
he's mixing it up I think it's a smart
strategy because your team needs you
they're relying on you at this point but
don't take more risk than necessary
right that's what you were saying
earlier
yeah I mean play measured take measured
risks and I think that's exactly what
Arjun is doing the grunfeld is an
incredibly reputable opening which
promises unbalanced play and chances for
the win this is a very well explored
position white has two main moves
there's the conservative E3 and the
riskier but more topical move D5 if
white plays D5 the Knight often jumps
out to B4 white supports the center with
E4 and the grunfeld Robert is the
ultimate hyper modern opening in which
you invite your opponent to control a
larger share of the center with their
pawns and then you use your pieces and
pawns to challenge that Center chip away
at it and generate active Prospect for
your pieces David Howell it's got to put
a move on it I think he's gonna go E3
David not the most theoretical player uh
in the upper echelons of Chess he likes
less explored more positional type of
situations but really really hesitating
here and he chooses a third option which
I will confess I'm not familiar with
yeah Bishop F4 that catches both off
guard because uh he's giving up this
Pawn on D4 but Donna he might be taking
your advice to some extent like just
playing some quick natural moves D4 is
hanging sure but so is C7 so uh you may
just see some trades some simplification
uh the knights on C6 and B6 a little bit
awkward maybe the Knight on B6 will hop
to C4 uh in the near future just to
tickle the pawn on B2 and maybe reroute
towards the center but Arjun says let me
go after D4 right away by hitting your
knight in F3 he stays far away from the
immediate Knight takes D4 if we could
bring up an analysis board quickly and
then we will get through some of the
other games the immediate Knight takes
D4 uh it was not bad but if you
recaptured on D4 with the bishop then
you would walk I think right into Knight
B5 this is the kind of scenario that
Arjun wants to avoid a lot of Trades and
white gets a huge initiative with a
potential capture on C7 apparently the
best move is E5 trying to capture the
piece on your own terms and here white
has I cheated by using the opening
Explorer the move Knight to C6 saying
yeah I'm gonna give you one of my minor
pieces but you're either going to have
to ruin your Pawn structure or after
Queen takes D1 you're gonna have to
allow me to take the bishop and take the
pawn this leads to essentially a forced
draw with the opposite colored Bishops
Robert Arjun trying to stay away from a
quick draw and instead he opts for
Bishop G4 the eval bar not approving but
I like I like the way that he's handling
this opening and I like the fact that he
has a two minute plus time Advantage
already
just so uncomfortable when you feel like
you have to win the game you know you
make decisions that you wouldn't
ordinarily play and Bishop G4 I think
deep okay I was saying it he plays it D5
is a very natural response because black
was trying to win that pawn on the
Square now you push it up to
well-defended territory when the Black
Knight hops somewhere like let's say it
tries to hop to B4 then white can just
push the pawn to E4 or even think about
a move like Knight to E5 yeah you
highlighted before I could say it uh
just getting adventurous the bishop on
G2 will defend that pawn on D5 and not
much needed a third time so you don't
even need to push E4 in this particular
position I like White's position I think
David has a slight Edge and good players
even when they're satisfied with the
draw they can shift their strategy at
the drop of a head yes David was
allowing uh several lines that would
bail the position out but now he says
hey you don't want to draw I'm going to
punish you he's not just cowering in a
corner and insisting on trading all the
pieces he is adapting to the needs of
the position Bishop G4 a very dubious
move I still approve of arjun's opening
strategy but David's saying hey you want
to lose this game I'm more than happy to
crush you now it's up to Arjun uh to
demonstrate that he can put pressure on
White's incredibly menacing and
well-defended Center
yeah Knight A5 to C4 a typical way of
dancing with those Knights going after
the B2 Pawn uh but while David he
figures this out he does spend a lot of
time he's a glutton for time trouble
let's look at the other boards because
for mgd1 you need to score some
victories it doesn't matter who gets the
job done and you just need them so as
you look across these four boards down
here I see in the top right a very
awkward position of pavlo's Bishop on A4
but it's annoying for black to deal with
in the bottom left we have harika
against Chelsea Monica both kind of
Heroes for their respective squads
that's in a maruti bind structure and in
the bottom right
I don't even know what opening that is
like a little Center game from a DJ
Mattel who continues to play quickly but
pranav he's been the man of the match
two out of two he has indeed and he
wants to make a three out of three I
think his last move is a clear signal
that he is ready uh to meet the demands
of the position it's opposite side
castling this was actually a scotch so
kind of the cousin to the center game
and it's a classic question of who will
strike First bishop to B5 is the last
move developing the bishop and putting
the brakes on Black's Pawn storm but
it's important to indicate Robert that
A4 is still very much in the picture
this is standard fair to sacrifice upon
in order to give better prospects for
your Rook so should white uh start the
engine on the king side or should white
play more prophylactically with a move
like a four what do you feel about this
position
I feel like I need an engine to figure
out what's going on here because H4
played that makes sense G4 is coming
sooner or later and if I'm black I want
to trade pieces you don't have that much
space right look at Black's pieces
there's one Pawn past your own third
rank or the sixth rank here it's that
pollen A5 that for now can't easily push
forward so I'd be thinking of a move
like Knight to E5 just trying to trade
those light score Bishops because the
pieces are stepping on each other's toes
I would love to get my queen up to D7
for example to connect my Rooks and then
try to press forward from there so I
think a night move for black is
multi-purpose one you trade Bishops when
you have less space two you try to get
A4 in and 95 has just been played and
first mistake listening to Robert Hess
for now doesn't know what's good for him
I don't know what to say 95 is met
immediately with A4 DJ mitzel handling
his time well is he playing a little bit
too fast I don't think so I think he
just feels very confident in his
knowledge of the ideas now it might be
counterintuitive Robert to push pawns on
the side of the board where your king is
but I feel like that is a very important
principle to put in the larger context
of the position here A4 doesn't weaken
whites King it makes it a lot harder for
black to use his pawns to break through
and induce weaknesses and yeah on an A4
is going to be a weakness but after
Bishop takes B5 Knight takes B5 how on
Earth are you ever going to attack it
I don't have the answer so instead I'll
shout out Aquila for gifting a bunch of
Subs in the chat thank you so much to
everybody for your continued support for
your viewership we appreciate you we
hope you're having fun here and don't go
anywhere because there's an entire extra
match after this one but Donya in this
one I think that black should oh I was
gonna say SWAT Bishops and then try to
move the Knight back to D7 the F6 Knight
instead C6 and will we see B5 like the
D6 pod is hanging but pranav may be
saying I don't care about the quantity
of my pawns I'm just trying to rip open
the position and he says okay for now
let's keep it defended but there might
be a B5 move in the near future well G4
could also be a sucker punch here not
only is the pawn storm dangerous in and
of itself but the move G5 virtually
traps Black's Knight H5 will be the only
Square because the retreating squares
are occupied by Black's pieces and then
F4 could come with absolutely
devastating effect that's the problem
with having the knights in the center
like this they may look good but they're
very susceptible to being attacked dead
Aditya takes a slow roll approach he
drops his Queen back to due to insisting
on winning this Pawn on D6 it's an
understandable move Robert but maybe it
gives black a good opportunity to push
B5 and Go full tilt on the queen side
still obviously a bad position for
pranav he has to be ultra precise here
if he wants to justify the weakness of
the D6 Pawn I think I've tunneled and I
was about to say I've been so focused on
B5 that we didn't take into account D5
it has a similar idea opening up more of
the queen side where white king sits on
C1 and also the A4 Pawn you mentioned
before seems awkward to move upon there
if you play e takes D5 we'll just shows
very quickly Knight takes D5 you know
will be the response there and then
after Knight takes Pawn takes if you try
to take this Pawn on D5 you're going to
lose your A4 Pawn over there so that's
the downside of pushing a pawn like this
on in front of your own King it's going
to become vulnerable you don't have a
rook to defend it so I think that pranab
he strikes at the exact correct moment
and it's no surprise that is now slowing
down he's actually probably not liking
his position that much anymore I think
adicha totally overlooked the move C5 I
mean I did because we often assume that
a weak Pawn is immobile but in fact one
of the best techniques to eradicating a
weakness is to
essentially give it up on your own terms
print off saying I'm happy to give you
the d-pawn you're gonna have to give me
the a pawn and the C file in return
that's like when I used to play Monopoly
with my brother and he would offer like
200 for boardwalk and Park Place and
three other properties I'd be pretty
attracted to the 200
renov has just been in excellent form
and Robert excellent form doesn't always
mean you get great positions out of the
opening every game it means you're able
to adapt to whatever the position
requires of you and that's exactly what
we see pranav doing here
yeah no pranavi's doing a great job here
and I just want to shout out Tomodachi
you know gifting some subs in the
channel as well I don't want to miss you
appreciate you and I think that right
now the Norway gnomes appreciate pranav
more than anybody else I mean the guy is
just putting the team on his back saying
I'll win all my games and he might lead
his team to the postseason but you need
to look and account for all four games
so let's get out of here for now we like
the trajectory of this one for a proud
of but Donya as we look from board to
board in the top left David Howell yeah
he does have an edge with the pair of
Bishops we already looked at that game
so maybe we should zoom into another but
it looks like El yanov in the meantime
it's a buy a pretty neutral looking
position both sides of their chances and
the bottom left harika and Chelsea that
one's looking interesting to me Daniel
because we have an end game but that is
more complicated than initially meets
the eye yeah and what initially meets
the eye is the fact that the players
have the exact same type of pieces right
bishop and Knight and two Rooks against
Bishop Knight and two Rooks but peace
symmetry does not imply board symmetry
if the pieces are symmetrical you then
look at the pawn structure and the pawn
structure could not be more asymmetrical
white has that typical accelerated
Dragon advantage in the center and black
has the typical pressure on the queen
side the big question here for Chelsea
is weather and when to play the move A4
she starts by pushing the corner Pawn on
the other side Harry the H1 advancing to
H5 and Frank the F Bond following suit
Frank the F Pawn haven't heard that one
uh before but we see that after F5 if
you swap pawns on the Square then you
know white has a stronghold over the E6
square and the E file as a whole like if
you play e takes a five Rook F to E1
next and what is black exactly going to
do are you really going to bring your
king out to F6 the answer might not be
no but you're not really in the best
shape as black there's going to be an
open G file you can't use it there's a
bishop on E6 taking away the G8 Square
from a rook so I feel like I understand
the impulse to push that pawn there and
I think it may objectively be a pretty
decent idea but why can't white just
slam a knight on D5 now hoping that
black takes it to open up the C file the
bishop on E6 takes away C8 it takes away
G8 I just feel like black can't really
move that easily you can just sense the
confidence in harika's game she's
cooking with some fish oil after her win
with the black pieces against Pavel El
yanov and not letting up at all Rook fe1
is a setup move you called it I think
Knight D5 is coming to a theater near
Chelsea Monica maybe on the next move
maybe in a couple of moves white has
some improving moves that she could make
at King F2 being one of them you could
decide to close up the queen side with
uh A2 A4 uh time situation is pretty
reasonable for both sides but yeah this
this is a very uncomfortable end game
both positionally Robert in terms of the
weak squares as well as tactically the
king could absolutely get caught in the
crossfire if let's say a rook lands on
E6 sometime in the future
and Chelsea Monica she's a fan favorite
and she has a tough position right now
but she did just win that round two game
against Amin tabatabai so she is
performing well throughout this season
for the Norway gnomes you see their
lineup she's got one out of two the same
as their top board Pavel El yanov and
buddy pranav I mean he's leading the way
two out of two but his teammates are all
chipping in including Chelsea when
you're bored four has an even score I
don't care what round it is that's a
great thing for your squad especially
with her rating being 22.66 maybe she's
underrated in these quicker time
controls Dania because she plays in all
the arena Kings and has played so many
Blitz tournaments on chess.com so she's
a great player to have she's going to
fight very hard in this one her position
is worse but I don't think that bad so
why don't we let these two at it and go
to maybe another game because I'm
looking and I see in the bottom right
and the top left let me see advantages
for the white pieces we're going to get
a major time scramble in our top board
our battle between David Howell and
Arjun aragaisi it looks like a very good
position for white he's got the bishop
pair Black's position is riddled with
weaknesses that pawn on E6 in the center
is isolated and poorly protected so
David Howell definitely has the upper
hand but Arjun has the upper hand on the
clock I'm also looking at the bottom
right we're getting some clarity and
that position pieces are getting traded
the queen on D2 is hanging but there is
a pawn sitting on H6 so between those
two games Robert I'll give you the final
say where to from here
oh my goodness let's go back to our top
board game just because we haven't tuned
in in a while and as you mentioned time
trouble is coming our way but David
Howell has a great position here
black has this isolated E6 Pawn
white has a pair of Bishops White's King
is feeling safer both Kings on the same
side of the board but white just has an
extra Pawn on that flank and those
Knights where are they going for black
the C4 Square guess what you're not
attacking anything so I just feel like
David has a lovely position right now
but I say all that Dania and I actually
don't know what his plan is so can you
come up with a plan for white before
David loses on time well the concerning
thing is that David is having a hard
time coming up with a plan Bishop H3
Robert is the move that I would play in
a bullet game putting pressure on the E6
Pawn I'm wondering what David maybe he's
deciding between Bishop H3 and a move
like B3 fully restricting the Knight on
B6 there we go B3 is on the board I
can't believe he has 59 seconds after
only 19 wasn't that is crazy but David
is he's an incredible time Scrambler he
never seems to lose his cool uh even
when he's got under a minute in a middle
game position Arjun needs to strike the
balance right now Robert between playing
quickly and putting pressure on David's
clock but not treating this like a hyper
bullet game because one more mistake
such as allowing white to get the pawn
to E5 could result in immediate disaster
yeah if that pawn goes up to E5 the E4
Square vacated for a knight or the light
score bishop and B3 what a calm move
from Howell saying your knight is not
hopping forward the Knight on B6 is
completely taken out of the game The
Pawn on B3 takes away C4 A4 was already
covered the Knight can't get to D5 so I
feel like these Knights are just not
hopping to useful squares and at some
moment the Knight on C3 May hop to B5
and just cause black some issues with
some of his weaker pawns so I do like
this position for David Howell but let's
back out of this one because I see
what's happening in our board 4 versus
Board three matchup between adichie and
Mattel and pronounce let's go right to
that game it is getting very problematic
for buddy pranav has had a dubious
position basically all game long he
opened things up in the center but he's
allowed white spawn to slip into H6 wait
a second what about Queen C3 in this
position threatening mate threatening
the Knight
is there a defense to that
not well there isn't I'm easily seeing
so Queen season is almost game over but
it might also be an only move because in
this position the Knight on C4 looks
loose you can't take it because the Rook
on D1 needs The Bishop's defense so
Knight C4 is loose there and queen C3
takes advantage of it and it is in fact
played by adichie Matan look at
pronounced face he looks like a guy who
is not happy to see that move
uh done is he just drop in that night
for free he's dropping the night and if
we rewind to the previous move Knight C4
was understandable because the Knight
was hanging I think Knight D7 would have
afforded him better chances but after
Bishop F3 white still has a raging
initiative in the center and on the king
side after Knight C4 pranav of course uh
using tactics uh to eliminate the
possibility of Bishop takes Knight but
Queen C3 is a devastating double attack
the bishop will stay on E2 to defend the
Rook the queen will capture the Knight
and defend the bishop pronab trying one
last ditch effort to complicate the game
Bishop takes C2 check but not even 93
and he's gonna Fork some pieces and if
the queen goes to see through his Queen
G6 with check and you stop the Checkmate
and I'm not saying that you know black
is going to survive this game but it's
getting messy and now adichie Mattel is
under three minutes so mistakes do
happen when you're low on the clock but
I think Adidas should invest a minute or
so in the next two or three moves and
he's doing just that right he didn't
play instantly he's taking his time to
calculate Queen C3 here what he has to
see is Bishop to F3 after Queen takes G2
and that I think fully shuts down any
attempts at muddying the waters that's a
beautiful move because after Queen takes
G2 I think most of us are instinctly but
Queen takes G7 get the Queens off the
board that may still be winning for
white but with limited material and
black having two pawns for a minor piece
there would be some decent chances to
hold so this one is not looking so good
for the Norway gnomes and by the way
David Howell had a great position that's
no more let's zoom out of here because
look at the bottom left harika dronavali
against Chelsea Monica I know people
have been rooting for Chelsea she has so
many fans out there but harika is such a
strong and experienced player for team
mgd1 and if I'm looking at this
correctly Donya in the bottom boards MGD
one is winning and in the top row boards
they're not losing so they may strike
back right now well one game we have
talked about it's been level for a while
but Pavel alyanov has slipped a little
bit against the mean he is on the
defending side of that heavy peace end
game uh I think he should be able to
hold a draw but that's an important game
but I want to get us to the top board
Arjun against Hal has officially reached
a crazy time scramble Robert Howell has
7.6 seconds still with almost all of the
pieces left on the board
and he does that you know it's something
that he would love to work on I'm the
same type of player whereas I'm always
in time travel at this position though
the white king is looking pretty safe so
it's not like he's gonna call fall
victim to some attack and black could
blunder in any turn if you move the
Knight back to C6 Bishop takes E6 hits
you before you know it and The Rook on
D5 will be loose so black is a bit tied
down for the moment still can't bring
the Knight back to C6 that's going to be
frustrating for Arjun and Bishop G5 you
could slide in there with the bishop
pipe F2 to F4 just try to take some
space I feel like it's hard for black to
play here
Howell just offered a draw which was
immediately and resoundingly declined by
Arjun who senses that this game can turn
around at the drop of a hat as he grabs
space on the queen side Howell trying to
reshuffle and re-coordinate his pieces
that Bishop on H3 has overstayed its
welcome and so has The Rook on D5 I
think David is going to drop his Queen
back to E1 but you're potentially
walking into Knight C2 crazy tactics
here no time to calculate it and the
pawn a fight is hanging when Queen takes
A5 is that possible is there attack
Knight takes B3
oh my God Robert at the end of that line
Queen D1 was not Checkmate because it
could be blocked he pushes his Pawn down
I think black is the better practical
chances at this point but both sides now
in time trouble I think that with an
extra pawn and that blockaded c Pawn
that Queen takes d8 for sure
he takes the Rook oh but now Arjun can
take and take on E5 but he keeps the
Queens on the board Arjun is still
playing for a win Bishop takes E5
and that Knight will be so much better
than the light Square Bishop this is
really tough for David in mutual time
trouble David trying to play
conservatively but he's lost control of
the game and he doesn't have any
perpetuals the Knight blocks the check
here goes the C Pawn
David might have to push that ape Pawn
as fast as its legs will carry it
let's see who wins the race
he come to the rescue but the F2 Pawn is
loose you do not want to blunder that
one he goes Queen C5 to protect a good
move but David Howell Queen D2 looks
very scary with his Bishop E4 saving the
day only move you can take on A2 instead
he tickles the bishop the bishop doesn't
have a lot of squares on this diagonal
Bishop B1 might be the only move here
one second on the clock instead he drops
the queen back it almost looks losing
Queen takes E3 Knight F5 you win the E3
but the a pawn here goes very fast oh my
gosh black can't stop the pawn
Knight B6 and you put A7 to run your
king over very quickly so this is why
white is winning the King goes back but
look H Pawn do not leave yourself you
you have to do something and not allow
this capture and you can't promote yet I
think white is still winning because you
just don't promote oh you never promote
it you don't have to promote it you go
King D3 take C3 and you basically chase
the Knight off of B6 the corner Pawn is
the worst the Knight is the worst at
stopping these Corner pawns Bishop F3
also picks up the other Pawn Robert this
is now completely winning this was
incredible composure by David Hal Arjun
he's still trying but the a pawn is
going to decide the game
yeah just move your Bishop to safety
bring your key of the board the black
king too far away that allows the
blacking back with the tempo right King
F6 will hit the bishop so you have to be
very very careful here what wait wait
what's he doing
I still think it's winning
no now it's a draw Bishop G2 was the
draw was the move that led it because
the king gets a C5 now right and the
white king can't get in oh the white
king had to reach B4 with Black's King
on DC oh oh what a move oh that is
badass yeah that is such a nice draw
there by Arjun Eric geise he finds a way
by giving up his night clearing the
square but let's just go back very
quickly because it is instructed yeah oh
well we'll show it later right now there
still are other games and harika
dronavali winning in the bottom left
officially wins your game and the top
right I'm being tough to buy is somebody
winning oh he's winning the MGB may take
this round three and a half to half
this is unbelievable Rook to E5 is the
last move it cuts the white King on the
f file Robert that d-pawn the red carpet
is unrolled this is completely winning
white is not fast enough to win the
g-pawn all Eliana can do is try the back
rank checks but the king is going to use
the pawn as a shield as an umbrella and
on and on the pawn goes this is
completely and utterly winning no chance
this year no no plans what are we seeing
here we're gonna see a tied match is
what we're gonna see The Rook on E5 is
Untouchable the black pawn will press
forward this will be a win for a mean
tablet to buy so I think we're pretty
clear on this one uh Eliana Mighty
resides soon let's zoom out of this one
just because I feel like uh this one's
in the bag it's gonna build a bridge in
the top right and he's going to win the
game but look in the bottom right that
has just been a crazy game whoa and it
remains crazy white is up a piece both
sides with not the safest kings in the
world what's the material count and by
the way it means habits if I did
officially win the game there but what's
the material here the White's up a piece
for two Pawns somehow though pranav has
not only gotten a deta meets all low on
the clock but he's very much kept
himself in the game there goes the third
Pawn for the piece Black's King is the
safest it has been in a long time it's
still not safe and he's blundered a fork
with Knight D3 Aditya missed it but he
has Knight D3 on the next move I think
Knight D3 the bishop H5 is hanging but
what is there some kind of tactic
somewhere I guess I think there was
there was Queen D4 in response hitting
the Rook very important Saving Grace and
now Rook F2 for black maybe black could
actually win this game absolutely
apologize for that Queen H2 is the last
move Rook H4 would force The Rook trade
yeah and the black king is very safe now
and look at the extra pawns three pawns
for the bishop and the problem for black
is that you can't keep pushing the pawns
right if you push the B Pawn A4 is loose
the H Pawn can't get going and so I feel
like this should be a draw with best
play but with white king probably being
the safer of the two with the extra
minor piece that could be trouble for
black in the long runov would be more
than happy with the draw here that would
maintain the lead for the Norway gnomes
both players might be playing for the
win at the same time but Aditya has
built up a nice construction on the
queen side 95 loses the knight to queen
E1 check I would play King A2 and talk
that King away so that the Knight has
greater Mobility instead he's going
hither and vither with his Queen turn
off opening up the queen side Robert I
don't know about that but probably you
know it was missed there instead of
taking three white Bishop B3 getting the
bishop in touch with the F7 Pawn he
doesn't now but it's a little bit too
late because black isn't a great
defensive posture if the Queens come off
of course black is never losing this
game and look at this now using the H
Pawn as a weapon I know it sounds crazy
but a detail has to be very careful here
it's easy to walk into a fork lose a
minor piece it's easy to let this H Pawn
slip maybe he should have traded queens
and acquiesce to the draw but boy was he
completely winning he's still trying to
muddy the waters Queen G5 and H2 and
who's playing for the win here watch out
for Knight F4 this is getting crazy
yeah it is I mean the King on G7 is very
safe I would just trade the Queens uh
maybe the match situation you know up a
point just play for that and that is
what has happened so black can no longer
lose it draw has been offered by Buddy
and agreed to him so this was crazy but
Dania I do think it's most instructive
if we go back to that how will our
generic Icy game because I think people
can learn a lot from it we will pull it
up here white was winning but it wasn't
very clear because it took a long
journey so if you just dropped the
bishop back that was fine and if the
white king goes up to C3
King D6 King B4 right you get there
first if a king goes to C6 you have
Bishop to uh back to G2 check to make
sure it doesn't get to B7 and then after
King C7 you go King B5 and unfortunately
for black you are lost now because if
you move your knight the pawn promotes
if you move the king you drop your
knight you have no good moves it is
wrong white wins this position
same would go after King to C7 Bishop G2
isn't to check here it doesn't matter
there is a force field around the B7
Square King B5 really illustrates uh
after a move like Bishop after you love
these types of move Robert just awaiting
move inducing zugsvong the domination
that the bishop can exert over the night
and the utter incompetence that the
Knight displays when there is a corner
Pawn on the seventh rank can we blame
David for instead fianchetto and he's a
bishop first we absolutely cannot it's
so easy to forget why the C5 square is
important it's important because it
opens up an Avenue to the A7 on a big
save where arch and aragaisi but mgd1 is
right back in this match they are
because harika dronavali can't stop
won't stop since allowing her opponent
to draw in game one she has won two in a
row she takes on Chelsea Monica she did
have a better position throughout that
one Amin type of Dubai he has stopped
the bleeding in a huge Way by taking
down super Grand Master Pablo El yadav
so withdrawals on the other boards done
it we're in a spot where we see a one
point differential between these two
squads it was three now it's trimmed to
one we're gonna have an exciting last
round we will indeed mgd1 could not have
asked for a better third round I mean
they could obviously DT metal was
completely winning you could see the
exasperation on his face as he leaned
back in his chair in frustration he did
not pull out the win but it's not the
end of the world it's only a one-point
game and this is what the PCL is all
about who has the better nerves Robert
who can display the better play in the
final round oh this is gonna be awesome
it certainly will be with playoff
qualification on the line both teams
certainly nervous this has been a pretty
back and forth matchup we'll see can
mgd1 complete the comeback but first we
take this break and win return it is the
fourth and final round of action here in
his protesting matchup
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I cover the entire 184 185 Spectrum so
all the openings that arises after our
one E4
I had a lot of experience in this I've
played several games of prominence at
the game against Levon aronium from the
world team championship I also hit a
game from Gibraltar against Marcus
ragger which is the game that I'm going
to show here
the key here when this happens when your
opponent buys resource of playing F4
or you reach this position in your
calculations don't panic
[Music]
foreign
and there's the board one for team mgd1
repping his sponsor Quant box at his
origin era geisey the 2700 plus
Superstar now Dania it hasn't been his
best day he lost a game he only has one
half out of three but he got a very
critical half point in the previous
round as he goes on to take Pablo eliano
here in the last one indeed everybody
has their good days but the real MVPs
are defined by their performance when
their form isn't the best in Arjun
showing that he is willing to fight
through his subpar form and deliver
critical points he's currently on 50 a
win would go such a long way toward
ensuring an MGD one comeback they are
down by one point you need eight and a
half points to win the match so a 2-2
tie would result in a victory and a
playoff qualification for the Norway
gnomes who need pranav to continue his
MVP Ron as he faces coronavaliharika
Adriana baliharika who is on fire after
scoring two incredibly important
straight wins
both of those players on board three
were circling that matchup normally
we're like hyping up the top boards but
board three for both teams has two and a
half out of three that is an
unbelievable score no matter what board
you are on these two players with their
2500 rating playing like the 2700s that
we know they're capable of in smaller
sample sizes right over the long stretch
you expect the stronger players to you
know make their presence felt but right
now it's been all about board three but
as we head in to the fourth and final
round we start at board one our generic
I see one half out of three Pavel El
yanov just one out of three and we know
how strong he is we know how solid chess
player he is but he can't get himself a
Time trouble again oh yeah I love this
we're seeing a jibava London which is
one of my favorite openings and Pavel
responding with an ultra solid system
playing an early E6 of course Knight B5
Robert is not dirty Bush League tactics
it is actually a positional move you are
forcing black snide to occupy a very
massive square and rejoining Society is
very hard for this night you often see
it move back to C7 but from C7 it hits a
dead end because all of the juicy
squares are occupied by pawns I actually
think this particular line is
practically speaking very very
comfortable for white
I like it and Bishop before it's a
classy move shown understanding Bishop
takes A6 probably would scare a lot of
people but when you say Pawn structure
is overrated I don't know who said that
before I don't know you know who's let
us know that that's the case but Pawn
structure is not always the most
important thing black has a pair of
Bishops rapid development instead of
moving the same piece over and over
again so Donya you have a lot of
experience in this opening do you like
what Pavel is doing or do you think
Arjun has a small opening plus I think
it all boils down to whether or not this
is still arjun's prep because Knight E4
is a very menacing move Idol threatens
to win everything on the queen side the
automatic response would be Queen D3 but
I actually don't think that's the right
way to handle the position I think what
we're seeing from Arjun is the right way
to handle it he simply castles he says
you want a pawn hey go take my Pawn what
does white get in return for that pawn
let's quickly bring up the analysis
board if Pavel takes with the Knight and
the bishop after Rook B1 look at the
queen side black Frozen the bishop
Frozen the bishop on C3 vulnerable Queen
D3 Knight G5 coming in White's got
advantages on all three parts of the
board if Pavel takes first with the
bishop and then with the Knight that
provides very little relief after Queen
D3 the Knight has to move away and
White's dominance over the dark squares
gives him overwhelming compensation
after something like C4 love the way
that Arjun has handled the opening and
he's clearly still in his comfort zone
and probably still in his preparation
yes and we see that Pavo eliano he is
down over a minute on the clock at the
moment thinking do I grab this Pawn on
C3 is Donnie was just highlighting a
white gets very rapid play and look at
it those double A pawns are you really
up a pawn that's the big question and I
like what Pavel did I have to say he
took once because that Knight was no
longer pinned after White Castle and
left it there if you spend time
defending it with a move like Queen of
D3 then black can even make the move
Pawn to A5 and try to develop the bishop
via A6 give my Bishop that new diagonal
because the pawn on E6 is blocking its
initial path so let's create a new one
for it well that's definitely going to
be the X Factor in this position can
black find suitable arrangement for the
light squared Bishop either through A6 I
also highlighted the move C5 which could
open up a secondary developing square or
a pathway through D7 to B5 if black
solves the problem of his Bishop not
only will he fully equalize he might
even be contending for an advantage so
the next couple of moves in this game
are going to be important but I think we
should leave Arjun to contemplate this
very important next move because all
four games have been started and all of
them are in very combative territory
even the public end game yeah I was
gonna say top rise of Berlin end game
which uh we'll see how that one goes
bottom right just getting started let's
go immediately to the bottom left
between pranav and harika because that
position is one I certainly have never
seen before and it's a fun one look at
this Pawn structure black with his
double isolated B pawns white somehow
with a Pawn on F6 clearly took a knight
over there Dania I think we should go
back and see how we got here I'm totally
on the same page this got out of control
really really quickly it was a hyper
accelerated Dragon the drawback of which
is this move Queen takes D4 an
additional line that you don't allow if
you play Knight to C6 then of course
you'll allow the rose salimo so this is
standard fair but Bishop B5 I have never
seen before Robert I'm pretty sure that
E5 is standard Fair Bishop B5 takes the
sting out of Knight C6 but A6 is met
with E5 and here we go buckle your
seatbelts EF Knight to C6 kicking the
queen away and E takes F6 would ruin
Black's Pawn structure and open up the
e-file arika instead goes B4 what a
level-headed move Robert to restrict the
development of the Knight she says take
my pawn and E7 you will only be helping
me develop runoff castles and E6
highlights the fact that the F6 Pawn
could be more of a weakness than it is a
strength it cannot be defended because
Bishop G5 is obviously met with H6 and
G5
based on time consumption this wasn't
some kind of overwhelming preparation
from Pronto he's like I have an
interesting idea but now he's out of
book that's good news for harika and
we've been praising print off he
deserves it I don't think we've given
harika the attention she deserves she's
two and a half out of three against this
crazy strong Norway gnomes lineup she
beat Super Jam Pavlov she beat Chelsea
Monica she almost took down remember
that king of Pawn end game against David
Howell so harika dronavali is pretty
much the sole reason that mgd1 has a
chance you look at their team scores
she's outscoring everybody on her own
roster and she along with print off have
the high scores of the day so Dania now
into this specific position after the
move C4 Queen takes F6 it snags upon but
I think what white is going for is rapid
development with a knight D2 to E4 and
Bishop coming to G5 the Swiss cheese
formation for black on the dark squares
will be a problem
it will absolutely be a problem and
soharika not taking on F6 immediately
but what are the other candidate moves I
don't really see anything appealing
other than Queen takes F6 I mean you're
going to have to take this Pawn
eventually you cannot let it sit on F6
and expect to be safe after you Castle
so maybe bishop C5 uh to accelerate the
development is an option but the Knight
would come into E4 and that Bishop would
only add more fuel to the fire so I
think drone Molly should take on F6
quickly and focus on bringing her Bishop
out castling while keeping the dark
squares as protected as possible there
she goes yeah she takes on F6 Knight D2
very quick we saw a feature chat from
Greg shahadi saying this is pretty much
all Theory but basically black should be
fine now that's good when you have the
engines you're pressing the space bar
getting through the evaluation of the
moves but in an over-the-board setting
or an online team tournament it's not
easy to figure out what to do here
because Knight E4 is happening the D6
square is vulnerable the F6 square is
also vulnerable so harika has her work
cut out for I think she'll probably put
her Bishop on E7 and the Tucker Queen
back to G7 feed Kettering the queen it's
awkward but it does cover all of the
dark squares that are vulnerable
you could even follow up with a move
like F7 F5 whether or not white snide is
on e4 you either chase the Knight away
or you control the E4 square and if you
Castle kingside you bring all hands on
deck in terms of guarding that
all-important F6 Square no question in
my mind that White's compensation is
insufficient objectively but harika is
going to have to take some time to
navigate the complexities in the next
couple of moves that could send her into
time pressure so I think that pranav has
gotten the type of position that he
likes very Dynamic and long-term
attacking chances I would not put too
much stock into the Eva bar here
I'm with you and I won't but let's head
away from this one as harika trying to
figure this out let's go to board four
because Dania it's not the first time
today we've seen this from Chelsea
Monica in the first game against Arjun
eragisi she threw her pawns up to
kingside and it backfired here in the
fourth round playing against Aditya
matal Aditya didn't win against pranav
but he was ever so close look at this
position the Knight on F5 it can't be
kicked because White's best move might
be putting that pawn back to G3 like
come on let's let's get that one back
there
yeah that would change the landscape of
the position completely this Knight is a
bone in White's throat it is White's
King Side Pawn progress has just ground
it to a complete and shuddering halt if
we rewind a couple of moves I think
Chelsea has made a similar mistake uh to
her game against Arjun aragaisi she
sacrifices upon with E5 which is
interesting because that allows white to
jump start a king side attack but Robert
there's no Supporting Cast you know the
actors have not arrived to the set why
does no other pieces on the king side
and the pawns alone are not all that
menacing G5 the Knight drops back to G8
What a mature positional move as the
Knight reroutes to this golden F5 square
and by the time Chelsea brings her
pieces out it's too late and the King
side has completely fizzled out it
actually took me a while to realize that
white is down a pawn that is one of
White's biggest problems here I didn't
notice it at first and I think that her
opening Choice was not suitable for her
style because she had a closed position
before she played E5 so she opened it up
voluntarily but now it comes at the cost
of a pawn so I actually think this was
not a good choice for her style she's
such a great player and she if she loves
dynamism it wasn't the opening to get
that type of position so this is good
news for mgd1 Aditi matal he is up a
pawn you can sense it right he knows
that he's got a good position but he's
going to try to create maximum chaos she
sees Knight H4 you can have that Bishop
on G2 that's not important the Knight on
e4 is a stable block hater in the center
B4 is coming let's try to pry open some
files so why don't we leave these two to
it we know mgd1 has an advantage on this
board and if that's the case then they
might be able to even up the score so
where else do we see interesting games
we haven't gone to the top right because
of the Berlin I don't know if you want
to look at it but it is a Berlin defense
we have a queenless position David
Howell actually surprisingly up two
minutes on the clock yeah it took me a
second to just you know just confirm the
fact in my head David has seven minutes
and white has five amine has had an up
and down uh mostly a down PCL run but
scoring such an important Victory with
black over Eliana in the last round I
vote we take a quick look at that Berlin
Game to see who is pressing for the win
if anybody or is the position completely
dead and equal as it usually is in the
Berlin end game Robert I actually think
that is uh the more accurate
characterization characterization this
seems completely equal whether or not
the Rooks come off the board Rook 88 or
Bishop D5 might lead to some sort of a
repetition or a quick bailout do you
think there's any life left in this end
game
yeah I think we're just saying Bishop D5
Knight back to C3 Bishop back to E6
Knight back D4 we could see a repetition
of Swords but one of the big questions
that David Howell is trying to work out
is Rook to d8 if all the Rooks come off
the board right if we just get a clear
exchange of Rooks down the D file is
black going to hold that end game and
why do I frame it like that black has
these doubled C pawns which means it's
hard to create a pass pawn and white has
an extra Pawn when you cut the board in
half that said the pawn on E5 sticks out
like a sore thumb because it doesn't
have a pawn defending it so if black can
remove the defender with an eventual
Bishop D5 then perhaps white is the one
who's in some trouble so I like the
decision from Howell some of the queen
side pawns will be a bit vulnerable he
could push his own Queen side pawns and
black actually is apparently with the
edge in the end game
I think Amina slept walked into a very
very nasty end game you called it the
pawn 95 is a problem the pawn on A2 is
also a problem because with the Rooks
off the board you can trap the bishop
with B3 but the bishop can evacuate
through B1 Knight C5 right there was the
only move that avoided losing the game
and I think David can actually drop his
Bishop back to C8 play B6 to chase the
Knight away he can also drive a wedge uh
into the queen side with C5 and then
redeploy the bishop either on B7 or back
to E6 he's got all of the he's having
all of the fun in this end game Robert
the knights are just kind of powerlessly
Waltzing around the board but they've
got no footholds and obviously the
Knight on F3 will have to stay tied down
to the pawn for the foreseeable future
and David needs to make a quick move
Bishop C8 is obvious to him he knows he
can safely Retreat then play B6 King E7
maybe even bring the king up to attack
the pawn E5 but this is a moment where
as such a great Blitz player as he is he
needs to know that you should play for
the clock use the clock as a weapon
James Canty likes to say the clock has a
piece so use that piece and I think that
David could have made that move in four
seconds instead he played it in 41
seconds and he allowed Amin the time to
think that all that said Dania with B6
happening I'm not sure where that
Knight's gonna go if you go back to E4
the bishop comes out to F5 hitting the
94 and the pawn on C2 behind it I really
like David's chances in this end game
ahead in the clock and with the better
position so that's good news for the
Gnomes
good news for the Gnomes and uh good
news for mgd1 on the bottom board if we
could swing back to the bird's eye view
I need him it's all uh is extending his
advantage over Chelsea Monaco who's
playing some beautiful moves but
unfortunately she is running out of gas
she sacked a bishop on A5 now delivering
a discover check on F6 but when all is
said and done black will have two
incredibly dominant minor pieces for The
Rook so you can basically Robert score
that one or MGD one it's all is
completely winning it materially and
positionally
yeah I I just think that for Chelsea
like she just needed to play a different
opening because uh she just started
playing all these fiery moves in a
position that didn't call for it and you
can see in the bottom right she has just
a rook and airplane has two minor pieces
and more pawns that's bad for the Gnomes
also bad for gnomes the top left Donya
yeah Arjun eragisi just brought his
Knight into B7 and if you look at the
material you would say I could count
right black has seven pawns white is six
up a pawn that's good news but look at
your pawns on the a file you might drop
both of them there's a past C Pawn for
white it's firmly blockaded by all of
Black's forces but Knight D6 oh was it
crushing threatened
what's going on here Avil is getting
crushed here I mean he's getting crushed
positionally and Arjun could bring the
Knight around to D6 it's not a fork
anymore but the queen just doesn't have
a lot of comfortable squares and if
Pavel drops the queen on H5 Robert Queen
to B7 could be absolutely devastating
look at those minor pieces they are
sitting ducks without the support of the
queen talk about sitting ducks white
could also gobble up some a pawns Arjun
style move would be just Rook takes A6
keep the tension keep all of the
advantages of the position there we go
oh this one is looking just so promising
for Our Generation I would be very
surprised especially as he drops down to
three minutes if Pablo eliano is able to
survive this white has simple moves
white has elegant moves but the A7 Pawn
is blunted it's blockaded you're
probably gonna be able to win that the C
Pawn can be stopped but that Knight can
always drop back to D6 if it ever feels
like it's in any danger so yeah this is
really good for team mgd1 and another
board that's good for mgd1 as we hop out
of here because every game is of equal
importance look in the bottom left
pranav he played an enterprising opening
but the hero for mgd1 the MVP harika
dronavali she continues to play good
moves now Dania I see the eval bar I'm
going to push back against it a little
bit because Black's King is in the
center Black's Bishop on C8 is not
developed and can't even move on this
Turn The Rook 98 not helping out in the
middle of the board either so black is a
pawn ahead and has the bishop pair but
is behind in development and Rook E5 in
some positions already looks like a
pretty scary threat I could not agree
more I think this is a complete 50 50
position both sides have their attacking
chances right now white has to deal with
the threat of rookie five there are two
main ways to do that you could play the
move D6 to control that square or you
could play B6 which I like a little bit
more to take the sting out of the move
Rook E5 so that the bishop is protected
arika plays a third move she plays F6
but obviously Robert that weakens the
king side tremendously you have your
eyebrows raised I don't think you like
this move and neither do I
I just wasn't expecting it I mean I was
thinking D6 perhaps
um some other moves like that but F6
maybe it makes sense right you're just
taking away the E5 Square you're
protecting G5 which was under attack
from three of White's pieces and I if
I'm printing off here I'm playing Bishop
E3 and I'm doing it quickly I'm just
trying to take over all of the dark
squares if I can I am a little bit
worried about some back rank ideas in
certain positions you have to keep an
eye out for that but I think that Bishop
E3 taking the dark squares is a good
start there's a hilarious tactic if we
could pull up an analysis board Bishop
E3 after Bishop takes C3 it's a big
decision Fe is actually very interesting
to open up an Avenue to accessing the up
button after Rook take C3 uh I can't
resist showing Rook takes day two out
evil bar didn't change maybe this move
the problem is that Black's Queen gets
stranded on the queen side and white
could exploit that to dive into C7 here
I would take white any day of the week
including Friday so arika's work is cut
out for her especially after after
Bishop B3 has been played on the board
oh man we are in for a barn burner of a
Time scramble here Robert
we are and I just have to I'm sorry to
keep doing this but every single game is
of equal importance of course for the
scoreboard let's go to the look at the
top left of our screen here all of a
sudden Pablo Eliana he's equalized the
position but that's dynamic equality we
don't talk about this in terms of a draw
both sides have chances because Pavel
has pushed his H Pawn is going for an
attack so maybe we should dive back into
that one uh there this position Bishop
going into D6 maybe Knight H4 threatened
Checkmate in one and try to take over
the light squares and we could get a
repetition there Bishop can drop back to
G3 Knight F5 Etc Arjun ended up losing
the plot on the queen side he Dilly
dallied a little bit too long and
allowed Pavel to increase the intensity
of his King side pressure Rook to F7 is
pavel's Choice the ball bar is not a fan
of this move I think Knight H4 was
called for this gives Arjun a crucial
Tempo but what is he gonna use this
Tempo to do how does he patch things up
on the king side King H1 would be very
much Arjun style type of move but maybe
there's something better
it's actually quite surprising because
is Eliana playing for a win of some sort
I mean Knight H4 if we bring up an
analysis board very quickly uh The Rook
was under attack on f8 but if you play
Knight H4 you're threatening Checkmate
in one and either you bring your Bishop
back to stop it in which case you go
Knight F5 you repeat the position that's
great but if you play G3 oh my goodness
I mean Knight F3 check the Queen's going
into light squares you might even just
find yourself Checkmate in a few moves
so I don't believe in that type of move
I think Bishop G3 was forced and well
maybe eliana's look at the Evo bar now
after arjun's last move maybe he really
does believe in his chances because
Queen went back to E1 and done there's
an argument for Knight H4 in the near
future or right now he's played it
Bishop G3 Knight F5 I think Pavel is
fine with the repetition here so maybe
he didn't like the look of G3 but Arjun
he keeps backpedaling will he go for the
repetition something tells me he's gonna
go for the win and he does and he does
it with the move F3 very
counter-intuitive looking Robert but I
think one idea the main idea is to
prevent H4 that's why he put the queen
on E1 what a forward-thinking decision
by Arjun incidentally he moved backward
but a forward-thinking move nonetheless
yeah so this is going to be a tough one
between these two I'm not even sure I
see the eval bar it's going up just
slightly better for white but it's a
messy position as the bishop gets out to
B5 so finally some activity some life
for Pablo's pieces but we do have to
back out of here because I'm seeing some
action on other boards and we're gonna
have to try as best we can to go around
the horn look in the top right David
Howell in time trouble but if I'm
counting correctly he is up a pawn with
the black pieces so that one could go
the gnomes's way
it absolutely could he has a four on two
on the queen side now yes this Pawn
structure there is crippled with the
doubled C pawns it's harder than usual
to create a past pawn and the second
asset for white is his King position the
King on G5 attacking the pawn on H5 I
mean trying to get a four on two of his
own but right now that Knight on B5 has
to make a decision does he go for it and
grab A7 no he goes back to C3 plummeting
is the eval bar in goes David house King
he is winning
but okay we needed it out very very
quickly just show what should have
happened because I don't blame a means
having to buy he should have taken on A7
but who makes that move when your knight
gets shot after C6 King takes H5 you
just see the king walking over and it
should be a win of a piece and a win of
a game but I guess white has
compensation because of his past H Pawn
and things like that will happen F5 H5
and so on so it's way way too
complicated for a blitz scramble so I
don't blame him but his teammates aren't
going to be happy with him if he'd lose
this game and if we go the live position
Dania completely losing at this point
yeah black has everything defended now
the queenside pawn start rolling and the
King for black will enter via D5 in the
near future light squared domination on
both sides of the board the Knight is
also dominated and David instantly
playing A5 there's really nothing to
calculate here black can close his eyes
play C4 B5 B4 create a pass Pawn white
has not even an Iota not a scintilla of
counter play on the king side you can
play G4 big deal black just takes on G4
nothing that white can do this is
resignable
wow this one looks winning for the
Gnomes and if they get two wins they win
the matches go to our bird's eye view
because look at this done in the bottom
left buddy pranav is suddenly Sky High
evaluation oh but the last move Queen H5
apparently a mistake everyone is in time
trouble by the
wayanov yeah he's suddenly winning where
he's up a pawn he has great winning
chances there and basically no risk he's
got that past past and extra Apon our
generic icy has been losing the threat
of that game for a while but they're in
a Time scramble and with the Knights on
the board absolutely anything can happen
let's go back to the pranav game because
the evolver has shot up once again I
think harika with 30 seconds is just not
able to keep control over the game E6 is
collapsing her whole position Robert is
on the verge of collapse here it is but
she's holding steady I mean that's crazy
I mean look at this she's just
protecting E6 uh The Rook on G6 is great
because not only does it defend E6 but
through the pawn on G5 it aims at the G2
Pawn don't forget about the bishop on C6
helping out here I feel like this one's
any one's game and this is an important
one for mgd1 because on board four we
know Aditya matala is winning they need
to hold and win on some other boards
because David Howell now he's completely
winning in that one so this we're gonna
stay here for a little bit until
something needs to be analyzed from the
top right oh we see finally a win for a
digimatology that was a long time coming
but in the top right David Howell
getting the job done in this end game he
is up a pawn and it's a passer and in
the bottom left it looks like almost
right
let's go back to that
oh my goodness she blundered her Queen
oh my gosh Bishop takes G2 what's game
over
oh
Brook takes you two was
oh it's a terrible blunder
so this position Robert Queen takes C4
check I apologize that was the winning
move that was all she had to do to get
the queen out of the range of the night
then you take the queen she forgot to
play the move she saw it she forgot to
take the punch instead she took honey
ate immediately and blundered her Queen
back no way gosh oh my gosh and now it
is winning for white let's go back to
the bird's eye view because that was a
tragic blunder for mgd1 oh yeah did you
see it Eliana Drew David Howell wins in
the top right you see the black's gonna
be attacked entered the pawn goes
forward no it is not going to be a tie
it's going to be a win for the Gnomes oh
the Gnomes
mgd1 if harika had found that she would
have won but now she is lost it is
heartbreaking first she resides and
buddy pranav gets it done he seals
victory for the Norway gnomes maybe it
wasn't the game that he wanted but it is
the game that he had and he had the
match of his life he has been all smiles
today Robert and the last two games how
many have been the most impressive he
was dead in the water against Aditya
mittal he drew he was dead in the water
for one move against Haruka yes good
players are lucky more fist pumping and
smiling he deserves it arika dronavali
is going to take a while to live that
down one move stood between team mgd1
and a tiebreaker but it was not meant to
be in the Norway gnomes they stick and
they keep their lead after round one by
their hair on their chinny chin chin
thanks to the efforts of pranav they get
into the playoffs yeah I have to say
that a ditch your Mattel taking down
Chelsea Monica that was never really up
for debate in the early stages he's a
200 plus Point rating lead against her
and the position was in his favor but
the rest of the boards were topsy-turvy
originara geisey had his chances then
Papa ojanov had the same that game
finishes the draw David Howell wins a
Berlin end game Daniel was like no
please don't show me that and David says
I will show you the team mgd1 he gets
the win and finally last but certainly
not least maybe first and foremost
pranab gets a win harika unfortunately
for her she had a tactical shot that won
her the game she messes up a move order
she goes down and that is the difference
in this matchup as the Norway gnomes win
9-7 thanks to their boards two and three
buddy pranav underrated David Howell
showing why his rating has crossed 2700
and then on the other side Dania harika
Jordan Valley she led the way but just
what she had that win in her sights she
let it slip time travel
well rare is the occasion when your
board one scores under 50 percent and
the rest of your teammates carry uh
Carey and pick up the slack this is what
we love about the PCL every game matters
for exactly one point Chelsea Monica she
scored the upset that she needed she
defeated I mean Top of the Bay that was
one of the key differences in this match
probably enough did what he had to do he
held Arjun aragaisy with the black
pieces in the last game so it wasn't
that everybody played well nobody played
as well as pernav Robert but everybody
delivered at the right moment even
Chelsea and Pavel who were struggling
they got half a point a full point at
exactly the right moment and they Propel
this incredible Norway gnomes team a
well-assembled team with no weak spots
into uh the playoffs they're very well
deserved trip to the playoffs indeed and
it's the beauty of the pro chess League
because typically we see the super gems
playing each other in round robin
tournaments of the same cast and then we
see maybe some a bunch of draws a few
wins here and there in the protest
League we see that some of the best
players in the world don't quite have
the 2700 rating but they can take down
their opposition and that is what pranav
did that's what the Norway gnomes were
able to accomplish including as you said
Chelsea Monica she had a rough board a
round four game against Ford four but
she got a huge win over a meeting time
to buy earlier and now we see it a fifth
team has stamped their ticket into the
playoffs the Norway gnomes joined the
levitov chess Wizards and the Shanghai
tigers from this week's action and a
week ago the Indian yogis and the Gotham
Knights were able to secure that playoff
spot while team MGD won they dropped to
two and two and well done you I mean
it's a shame for them it's sad but they
will still have the chances next week
they absolutely well and that is the big
bright spot
as I said at the start of this match in
all of these teams at the top that have
won two matches have excellent rosters
they don't have any obvious weaknesses
so really it comes down to the form of
the players I mean something to buy at a
very rough week but I think the captain
I think he might believe and I mean to
redeem himself next week and that is one
of the key narratives that we watch in
the PCL who is able to redeem themselves
week after week who is able to use their
bad performances as motivational fuel
and there will have to be plenty of
motivational fuel Robert to go around in
this next match because one of the two
teams that will be featured next is
going to be eliminated
yeah no it's a tough spot for the
Spanish Maniacs rooms in the St Louis
archbishops both teams they have some
great players on the roster but they
have two losses to their names and they
cannot afford a third so that is the
match that will we will see next it
promises to be hopefully just as
exciting as the one we just saw so we
have great action and it's unfortunate
that some teams have been eliminated but
the players you will see them once again
because while their regular season has
come to a close for those teams that
have had three losses there will be the
arena Roy Al it's been difficult to
watch so many great teams get eliminated
from the main season these past few
weeks even the teams with a losing
record have exhibited incredible play
all season long so to celebrate all of
the talent in this year's PCL we're
hosting an arena Royale on March 24th
all 16 teams are eligible to play with
up to 10 players competing from each
team it's going to be an epic Showcase
of this season's Superstars some looking
to redeem themselves some looking into
cement their legacy all gonna have a
good time you do not want to miss this
use the command Royale in chat for all
the details and Dunya before we head to
break and go to our second match I gotta
ask you will you be playing in the arena
Royale I will absolutely be playing in
the arena Royale my team is out but that
does not mean uh that we can't do a
little Encore performance Arena Royale
is such a nice addition to the Full
Slate of PCL action I have marked it on
my calendar I will wake up in time
Robert and I can't wait for March 24th
gonna be a super exciting addition to
what has already been an epic PCL
regular season
can't wait to see that slugfest between
all the players but first we will have
to go to break and then come back for
the Spanish Maniac shrimps against the
St Louis archbishops it's Friday you're
not working anyway keep watching the
protesting we will be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
in competitive chess the weight of a win
draw or loss is all on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is bad
once again in chess teammates matter
this might be deadly for the unicorn's
chances right here look at that and just
like that the fist pump from Fort Nick
welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives Magnus shakes his head it's
over wow Magnus loses his second game of
the entire PCL season entering its Fifth
Season 16 teams will reboot the PCL
Legacy with a new format and new
schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
and Darius
by the way yeah what are you doing face
yeah like that was not your best move
foreign
hello everybody the teams are changing
but your commentators are not I'm still
Grandmaster Robert Hess and he is still
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski Donya a
pretty epic first match of the day
between mgd1 and the Norway gnomes but
now we're set for the Spanish Maniac
shrimps and the St Louis archbishops
you're pretty pumped about that one I am
but first of all but very unprofessional
behavior to assume that I didn't change
my name in the five minutes between the
two mesial matches I expected better
from you but I expect a lot of these two
teams because both of them have their
backs against the wall and from the
commentator's perspective what is
stressful for the players is
scintillating for the commentators and
the fans which team is going to stay in
the contest that is the most exciting
question Robert that we could be asking
before the match begins
for sure and get your glasses your
telescopes whatever helps your vision
you will not see the teams on this
standings page we have five teams locked
in for the playoffs the Norway gnomes
they have secured their playoff spot and
they beat the team mgd1 who drops the
two and two and we'll have a chance next
week but Diana today we're going to
focus on the back half of the standings
because we just saw that match take
place now we are going to get into the
bottom half because it's about teams
staving off elimination
it is indeed and you lose three games uh
you lose three matches you are out of
the contest and as we've been
highlighting so many times the St Louis
archbishops have not had the kind of run
that they were expecting the multiple
time PCL Champions have their back
against the wall but Robert they were
Owen too so they already have a win
under their belt and their lineup today
might be the strongest that they have
fielded yet so man oh man am I feeling
bad for the Spanish Maniac shrimps
because they have their work cut out for
them
it's not going to be easy it never is
but they do have a pretty powerful
lineup the maniac shrimps they have a
roster that you look across it they're
like oh Spanish Legends and then they
also have some players from other
countries they have Allen to show from
Argentina Lance Henderson from Andorra
and leads players who all lower the
globe so Dania when you look at this
roster Eduardo terizaga he has a wealth
of experience in Pro chess League
Seasons past but what are their names
stand out to you well Jaime Santos is
the top seed but he is not playing today
and he struggled mightily in the maniac
shrimpses lost to the Garden State
passers but a long piece show I really
think that he is the Mainstay of the
maniac shrimps roster he is a noted
Blitz and Rapid player he's incredibly
aggressive and he's one of those guys
who can really explode for three and a
half or four out of four if the stars
align correctly and some of the lower
rated GMS are incredibly strong Jose
Carlos Ibarra is a name that should be
familiar to anybody who watches title
Tuesdays he is not to be trifled with
despite the fact that he's under 2600
that's what I love about the PCL robber
you're able to discover new players who
might not have the most eye-popping
ratings but who definitely have an
eye-popping way of playing the game
and Donna I mean they had their back
against the proverbial wall to begin
with they had to qualify for the protest
League season the only team that made it
through via the qualifiers so is this a
situation where they've been here all
along and we should expect them to
continue playing like they have been but
how do you you know get it going against
a team like the archbishops well I think
they should lean into it right as you
said they had their back against the
wall just to get into this thing and
even the way in which they got into it
they had their back against the wall in
that qualifying match which was one of
the craziest matches that we have seen
and that was just to get into this thing
so I think the maniac shrimp should
basically tell themselves listen we're
in this thing we're lucky to be in this
thing let's just enjoy the experience we
weren't expecting to be in the PCL in
the first place so let's do what we can
to stay in this tournament I feel like
the pressure really is on the St Louis
archbishops who are undisputedly the
favorites and uh if you have any doubt
about that then you won't after you look
at their roster
and the maniac shrimps they won last
week that could have even won against
the Norway gnomes earlier in the season
if it were not for a mouse lip but no
mouse slips can be made against a team
like the arch Bishops we know Fabiano
caruana we know lenier Dominguez but so
far this season especially after last
week it's been all about Alice Lee she
has taken the protest League by storm
and when you have a board four like her
who can beat Matthias bluebound the
board one for another team Dania she is
a rising star in the world of Chess
nobody wants to face Alice Lee right now
she is underrated she is confident and
she struggled a little bit in the first
week she had all good positions I think
it was against the Shanghai Tigers but
instead of using that uh to bring
herself down she used that to pump
herself up I was better or winning
against four Grandmasters she told
herself and that translated directly
into a scintillating performance that
knocked the Berlin Bears out of the PCL
contest Alice Lee will have to repeat
that incredible performance along with
of course Fabiano caruana Benjamin Bach
and Nicholas Theodore the incredibly
powerful Trifecta that will have to
arrive and deliver if the archbishops
are to stay in this contest
well you said they need to deliver so
let me ask you about two players that
you just named we have Benjamin buck and
Nicholas theodoro the two players who
don't have an American flag they're not
from the US but they're playing for this
American Squad so what do you think what
what's it like for them is there
pressure on them to score big points
like we just saw pranab do for the
Gnomes well I think the majority of the
pressure is fielded by Fabiano caruana
he is the guy who really has to go at a
minimum two and a half out of four but I
really think he's angling for a three or
three and a half performance Benjamin
and Nicholas are both incredibly strong
Raptor players I think you get
tremendous value out of their ratings
Nicholas being below 2600 is a travesty
it's a crime against humanity Robert he
breaks to the table some incredible
opening preparation super fast in time
scrambles he really has the whole
package so I'm very excited to watch
Nicholas theodoro and I'm really curious
to see if he can score uh two and a half
or more I think that might be the key to
the kingdom for the archbishops or to
the church
yeah and theodoro is an Olympiad
medalist that was a team event different
type control that was classical chess
but here in Rapid you know anything can
happen so let's look at the lineups that
these two teams are trotting out we see
that Allen P show is board one for the
Spanish Maniac shrimps and water
retirezaga just one rating Point behind
the show and then Jose Carlos Ibarra a
very strong player at preps underrated
and of course Sabrina Vega Gutierrez the
international master from Spain so
Daniel we look at this we have the
lopsided matchups in the first round
boards one and two play the opponents
three and four but I'm looking at those
middle boards that for me is where the
juicy matchups are total toss-up games
really it's hard to speak of favorites
to turizaga Theodore super evenly
matched I give theodoro a slight edge
with the white pieces but idrisaga as a
rock solid opening repertoire and we
have seen him deliver time and time
again the same goes for Jose Carlos
Ibarra very dangerous one E4 player and
Sabrina Vega Gutierrez if she can score
at least a draw I think she's going to
buy herself a trip to Las Vegas to
celebrate that let's see how the board
force uh perform in this match you got
that right I didn't see your facial
expression change at all just making
sure that you understood what I did
there
I understand you know sometimes I just
you know I'm multitasking so I'm
listening but I'm not always listening
I'm just gonna be honest you know other
things that I have to do you're not
missing out trust me well you'll have to
you know give me more puns later in the
show but Alice Lee put on a show a week
ago she gets the white pieces against
Alan P show so when you see that match
up on paper Alan is the big favorite but
do we think we'll see more of that upset
special from Alice Lee
honestly with white she is incredibly
solid she's not just she doesn't just
play for tactics a lot of young players
they're tactically oriented but Alice is
actually a one D4 player and what has
been most impressive to me has been her
positional handling her win over
Matthias bluebomb last week was largely
a positional effort she displayed the
tactics when she had to but she
outplayed him positionally so I think
Alan P show has to avoid the temptation
to play an overly dubious opening
because Alice has shown an ability to
punish that kind of play he has to play
what he normally plays I think he plays
the nimzo Indian so we'll see what the
show brings to the table but he's got
the unenviable task robber of really
having to set the tone for the Spanish
Maniac shrooms they cannot afford to
suffer a single upset
and we're not in a stadium but I think
peacho knows that the world is kind of
against him here nothing personal he is
a great chess player who does have many
fans but I think we've seen week in a
week out that everybody is kind of
rooting for Alice Lee I mean that's just
what happens when you see a youngster
who's just trying to make her name and
one that's a Mainstay in the world of
Chess and I don't know who Alan P show
is talking to maybe he's telling me to
shut up right he's like don't you talk
about selling his mom or parents let me
play I'm playing a PCL match you have do
I have to take out the trash now or can
it wait another 10 minutes
it's gonna have to wait because Alice
Lee she is not going to let Alan B show
have an easy day of it and actually the
quest I went in the background there
don't know who it was but Alan's like I
have to play right now let's focus in
the chess
this is a PCL match we are with our
backs against the wall and
H6 is that what we are seeing here H6
really Riley I mean it's a move I've
seen it before I think
yeah no this is the type of move that
Magnus plays right he just plays this
sort of ambiguous Pawn push either A6 or
H6 is does take away the G5 Square uh
from White's Bishop so it makes perfect
sense uh you know it's understandable
early stages here but Donna I think if I
were a team captain or manager for St
Louis if I would one of her teammates I
would just be like Alice you're so
strong don't get yourself into huge time
travel it's early right now she's
playing in a perfectly normal Pace but
that's just one thing you can't afford
when you're playing against these very
experienced Grandmasters like Alan P
show what's he doing by the way
yeah I'm
activated by his various facial
expressions and contortions
and he's taking on C3 that's what he's
doing on the board pre-moving D6 as a
consequence and what we have have what
we have as the Smoke Clears Robert is a
pretty typical nimso Indian structure
generally black fianchetta is the bishop
what's 997 I think Ellen has gotten what
he's wanted it a non-theoretical
position with a lot of pieces on the
board and definitely chances to play for
the win
yes you have these Double C pawns so
what's a common idea here for black is
it Go Knight C6 Pawn B6 bring your
knight out to A5 and Bishop to A6 Donnie
has all the arrows there you just go and
Target this Pawn on C4 but all those
moves I just stated were on the queen
side so white will have time to play E4
and try to expand the center and go
after the king side Allen playing this
very creatively E5 immediately he
doesn't even prepare it by bringing the
Knight out so what's the catch here
if white takes twice on E5 could this
still first of all be preparation by P
show do you play such a move uh
instantly without preparation can you
help me tease out the concept what is he
doing if white takes twice I think he's
just giving away a pawn at least
temporarily and saying you now have
doubled isolated C pawns I will likely
be able to get one back later and if
that's the case black will get rapid
activities so instead of playing a
passive structure or giving white a free
hand on the king side says let me strike
in the center here's your Pawn just to
bring up an analysis board you know just
or we don't even need it really just to
show what it looks like just play D
takes E5 I'll put it on the board trade
and then Queen E7 at the end for example
like you look at those double isolated C
pawns Rook coming to d8 that once the
Knight moves back to F3 the Knight can
come to C6 and Bishop to G4 for black
and just very straightforward play and I
feel like that is something that Alice
would like to avoid yeah I think this is
a great way to take a measured Risk by a
long piece show he's not sacrificing a
piece or doing anything Brazen he is
unbalancing the position in a very
strategic and thoughtful way Alice is
going to continue pondering whether or
not to accept the pawn on E5 I would
play E4 and keep the structure we'll see
what she decides but we have decided to
go back to the bird's eye view because
all of the games are underway in this
fascinating second PCL match of the day
and allepin Robert on the top right
between theodoro and its rizaghan
exchange Lopez on the bottom left and a
good old-school Sicilian in fabi's game
against Sabrina
but it's funny because in fabi's game
and I hear Sicilian you think Fabi has
the white pieces but 500 carwana playing
the system with black clearly he's
playing the rating differential he wants
a win for the archbishops and you see
players uh play openings that we're not
accustomed to seeing from them because
of the highest level for so many years
now Fabiano he's played the Petrov or
the Spanish from the black side here
he's playing with Sicilian I love
watching these lopsided matchups not
only because the low rated player gets
the chance to score the upset of his or
her lifetime Robert but also because of
what you said top players in the PCL
these games are not rated they allow
themselves more Liberties in the opening
than we usually see from them right we
usually see neat and tidy berlins and
petrovs here they go out on a limb and
play stuff they don't usually play a
sicilian from Fabi but he seems to know
exactly what he's doing as he still has
almost 10 minutes on his clock this is
called the sky God I'm terrible
pronouncing this I think it's
okay our producer Bic probably is
cackling behind the scenes what a fool
this guy is
oh okay no but you're just saying that
to make me feel good dick come on give
your honest assessment oh big did I
don't know if you could hear the second
part he said yeah that was terrible but
uh yeah you know whether or not you
pronounce it correctly you know the
ideas behind it and well for Fabiano
either he knows all the ideas or he's
pretending to something that the top
players do extremely well is they know
when to play quickly not that they're
bluffing completely not that uh they're
trying to just play random moves as fast
as possible but sometimes they just know
when their opponent feels like they're
trusting and so for Sabrina here she's
playing great moves as white she just
brought her Knight back to B3 why white
has more space let's not just trade off
pieces because what does black want
black wants a bishop on C6 and guess
what you can't do that because there's a
knight on C6 so a trade would have
allowed some more flexibility from the
blacks minor pieces you're not getting
that I like the way that this game is
starting there's a traffic jam on the
queen side which exacerbates matters for
black who is already cramped White's
ideas are pretty straightforward Sabrina
could bring her Rook into the game she
could deploy her light squared bishop
and stare at that H7 pawn and eventually
you see white playing either E5 or F5
you don't have to tell Fabby twice he's
saying I'm going to strike first I'm
going to open up new prospects for my
pieces and B4 is a very typical move it
weakens the A6 spawn yes but this Knight
on B4 is pretty monstrous Robert and it
can't be easily chased away as white
cannot put his Pawn or Pawn on top of
the Knight
and there's an easy blunder that could
happen and she made E5 she's getting
that interest no I was gonna say a
blunder would be if you play Rook C1 and
just drop the C2 Pawn anyway because the
Rook on B8 stares down at the Knight on
B3 so because there were some tactical
possibilities for black maybe even
Knight takes C2 now is possible you give
up the Knight and F6 you simply take
that pawn back there two pawns for the
piece to start with but don't know if we
just put that position on the board kind
of everything is hanging in the position
after Pawn takes F6 Bishop takes F6 here
The Rook on A1 the Knight on B3 the
knight's also hitting that Bishop over
there on E3 but Bobby he says you know
what I don't want to calculate all this
mess Let me just Retreat my knight he
believes in the uh formation that he has
started with and he thinks that it's not
worth getting into these tactical Waters
and he didn't even spend much time
calculating it this was a purely
intuitive decision he doesn't want to
enter the kind of 50 50 position in
which upsets are scored 98 is on the
board Sabrina has now a massive space
Advantage but we know that with a great
space Advantage comes comes great
responsibility and it's very easy to get
over extended now Sabrina has to decide
whether she wants to take on D6 and
maybe plant a bishop on D4 unfortunately
the Knight the Black Knight would have
traveled to F5 instead she centralizes
her Knight simultaneously defending C2
she's playing Amazing so far Robert
I love it and the reason Fabi didn't
take on E5 to begin with was the F5
would have opened up so instead of
opening up more lines when your king is
the one being attacked leaving the pawn
F4 felt important but this is a tough
moment for Fabiano because you look at
the position white just brought the
Knights of D4 so many pieces are aiming
towards the black king and watch out
because if you're not paying attention
F5 could happen in some position for
white and then the wheels come off it
gets really hectic black is incredibly
solid for the time being the Knight on
E8 is an important defensive piece it's
guards G7 it takes the sting out of a
potential Bishop H6 which by the way
would have also been possible if black
had prematurely traded on E5 but right
now the ball is squarely in Fabiano's
court because his engine on the queen
side has sputtered the C2 Pawn is
protected the B2 Pawn is hard to access
unless you move the Knight away from its
active post and if you do Robert there
could be typical ideas such as Knight F5
and Knight D5 White's position is full
of tactical potential Fabby has decided
to to trade on E5 but what is this
follow-up going to be is it to retreat
the Knight back to C6 that would be my
prediction
but one thing that we haven't mentioned
is the A6 Pawn is just hanging like in
many of these positions try to snag that
pawn over there so if Knight C6 it's
possible that Rook takes A6 is even the
move I mean there is a lot to calculate
with B2 hanging whoa
whoa whoa whoa Bobby plays F5 the eval
bar does not react which means it was
the best decision if you take on passant
a queen trade will happen that is hard
to evaluate I mean we could see that the
Queens will come off the board I
actually don't know who's better the
Sabrina it's up to her to figure it out
but yeah this is a really really tough
position so I think while she Ponders
the ampasan or maybe bringing the Rook
to the center with Rook 81 we should go
out of this one look at all three other
games that are in progress because Dania
we haven't looked in the bottom left but
the eval bar it's in bedroom box favor
the position though is anything but
simple Benjamin bot kind of doing
Benjamin Bach things securing the bishop
pair this was an exchange Rue Lopez in
which white hasn't shown the usual
compensation for the bishop Perry Barr
trying to complicate the game by pushing
his Pawn to D5 perhaps Robert we could
take a closer look because that game is
definitely heating up with a pawn
appearing in the center now D5
positionally allows black to rectify his
Queen Side Pawn structure what is
ibarra's idea is it to recapture with
the Knight and pin his hopes on that
active Knight on D5
I'm just sorry first of all looking at
the couch in the background of ibar over
there like you know it just
yeah I can't really see it clearly I
think it is better it's a bed yeah
that's a headboard you're right he's
just in the corner of his room but he is
fully focused not on sleep but on
perhaps putting his opponent to sleep on
the board knocking him out but D5 in
ambitious move from Jose Ibarra and
Donna it's one of these positions where
it's gonna open up and the Bishops are
going to shine only black has a light
Square bishop and already there's a
tough choice here because black is gonna
play H5 in the near future and open up
the king side flank
and I would imagine that he bars initial
ideas to take on D5 with a knight I was
looking at his camera there and there
was a little bit of hesitation he does
take on D5 with the Knight what is the
drawback of that move well it leaves the
E4 Pawn unattended why is that important
black can actually swing the queen over
to A4 it to Pawn on e4 and
simultaneously open up an x-ray against
White's Queen on D2 as solid as White's
position appears I don't think it would
be an exaggeration Robert to say that
it's on the cusp of crumbling
and you called it and it's played Queen
A4 so what is White gonna do bring the
Knight back to C3 but then the black
queen just moves over to score like C4
now this looks a very bad for white this
is like one of those positions you see
and you're like how did we get here
because we're only 15 moves in but
you've handed your opponent a pair of
Bishops we know how we got here it was
an exchange Spanish on C6 and now the
pawns are in doubled the pieces are
coming to life and that's just great
news for Benjamin Bach and the
Archbishop so this is a rough start for
Jose
to top off our analysis here before
going back to the bridge side view you
could bring up an analysis board I think
Queen D3 might be the only sensible move
because Knight C3 opens up a direct line
of fire against white screen and now I
think Benjamin's gonna play a very
benjamin-esque move he likes these slow
but very nasty positional moves 97 get
the Knight off the board and as soon as
the knights come off the board the Queen
can no longer keep contact with the E4
Pawn once you lose the E4 Pawn you
basically lose the game because black
also has two very powerful Bishops as I
speak Queen D3 has been played Benjamin
responds with a five second think and 97
Robert is on the board he is on a roll
so far in this first game yeah great for
the archbishops Benjamin Bach has so
much experience from the rapid Chess
Championship last year playing Blitz all
the time he's a streamer go follow his
channel but we are gonna go follow some
of the other action we'll see for big
move there by Jose he's just trying to
keep that Knight steady in the center
but things are going to open up as you
see Bach in the bottom left he already
took that night there so how about Alice
Lee she is playing against Alan P show
we actually haven't looked at the game
between Nicholas Theodore and etorizaga
um honestly I feel like the Alice League
game is more exciting to my eyes and wow
the Evo bar going up in her favor so
maybe this is the right time to tune in
I will uh just point out we will go to
the Owl City Game Sabrina Vega Gutierrez
took four minutes to decide and finally
took on passant against Fabi so we're
gonna see likely an end game in that
game but we'll have plenty of time to
consider it let's go to the Alice League
game because stuff's happening pieces
are getting traded we're gonna have
opposite colored Bishops here
and that usually benefits the attacker
robber but let's not forget the white is
up upon Alice Lee did end up capturing
the sacrifice Pawn on E5 and C4 is an
excellent move restricting the bishop
and depriving it of this very important
parking spot on D5
because F3 is about to happen quick
analysis board somebody can instruct you
a little bit here if instead of C4 had
um white decided to start with the move
F3 you'll notice that the bishop can
just slide safely back to D5 or even
into D3 but why not park on D5 and the
C4 square is blacks for the taking so
the big difference between the analysis
board and the game is that if black
decides and if you go to live position
to put a bishop on D3 then you just
slide your Rook to C1 you defend that
pawn and now black doesn't have control
of some of the key squares so a great
move there from Alice C4 it seemed
irrelevant what are you doing all the
actions on the king side first let me
take control of the queen side then she
could play F3 maybe right now is a good
time to do it but I'm starting to get
worried about her clock that was her
undoing in her performance against the
Shanghai Tigers she would get low on the
clock in the middle game and she would
start to make mistakes she's played
excellent chess so far can a lonely show
keep the tension up long enough to get
Alice Lee under a minute I think a move
like Rook D7 is what you want to do if
you're a lawn don't start making one
move threats uh because that's actually
counterproductive in your opponent's
Time Brush unless of course you can make
the tactics work Rook D7 is on the board
and Alan is going to keep the pressure
up in the center and he's going to look
for an opportunity Robert to put the
queen on G5
but if black plays Bishop G6 here does
F4 trap the Knight on E5
oh my God that's Epic like the knights
looks great it's in the center it's
covering a lot of the key squares no way
G6 takes away its Retreat and if you
play Bishop H7 you still play F4 because
then your knight has to step in front of
you okay
it might just happen but F4 here
probably will if you go Knight G6 then
Knight F5 you are allowed to jump into
the D6 Square the eval bar just shoots
up maybe there's a tactical solution
here Robert Knight takes C4 oh it caught
my attention I didn't notice that the
bishop was hanging I was gonna propose
Rook a to d8 here but the bishop
actually hangs so this I think is what
Elon is putting his hopes on by the way
the game here is not over white now has
a huge attack because Black's Queen is
offsides but does Alice have enough time
to calculate this I don't know Rook F3
try to trap I guess that's not the move
okay let's see one minute now for Alice
Lee
yeah really hard to assess that position
where there she oh I missed it quickly
oh he's playing too fast he's losing
he's playing too fast he has four and a
half minutes what are you you should
have spent some of the time there
he he played that instantly obviously G6
is the only uh retreating square but
take 15 seconds a lot and he would have
seen Knight take C4 you have to spot the
hanging Bishop on A3 but that's basic
Betty for someone of his caliber the
eval bar shoots up in White's favorite
Robert is it really plus four
yes I think that's why trade Rooks on D7
so pre-move Rook takes D7 almost then
play Knight D6 the B7 Pawn is loose
Black's minor piece is doing absolutely
nothing over there on the king side so
just trade Rooks there Knight D6 how are
you going to protect the pawn Rook to B8
then I go Rook D1 perhaps and just take
over the D file and now I have all sorts
of threats in the position and look at
Black's minor pieces how awkward they
are they're doing nothing the bishop
will swing back to B2 you're gonna try
to provoke the move F6 white is
dominating all three sides of the board
Queen side Center kingside Alice Lee
really is a couple of accurate moves
away from what would be another
unbelievable upset but with one minute
on the clock we know that absolutely
anything can happen let's settle in
Queen d8 is on the board
yes and she needs to pick up the pace
she's down under one minute Alice you
know has a great position she's doing so
well but now to 50 seconds I mean that
is not a lot of time especially it gets
a speed demon like Elon P show so uh
she's she's really She's Gotta Move
Dania she has to move she's down to 40
seconds now she's hesitating and when
you've got five seconds you just can't
control the flow of the game as she
drops her Bishop back to B2 it's an
excellent move
great choice
sorry go ahead no no go ahead
I should quickly say of course she was
going for the G7 Pawn now it's defended
by F6 and the if Eva is going higher and
higher because the weaknesses around the
black king I just want to zoom out for a
second just to keep everybody updated
every game is equally important here in
the protesting look in the top right
Eduardo oh my God the veteran
Grandmaster originally from Venezuela he
is a huge advantage against Nicholas
theodoro because Black's King is on F6
but there's no Checkmate and black is a
rook and a piece up and for the record
that is exactly what I was gonna say so
as usual we're on the same page I was
gonna say Nicholas has sacrificed the
entire house he has thrown the kitchen
sink that's a black king but he has
nothing to show for it other than a
couple of measly pawns Rook to G8 is the
last move securing the Knight on G6
Nicholas throwing everything that he has
left at Black's gang but it's futile
it's futile black and bring the queen
into the defense Eduardo has plenty of
time here to make the few accurate moves
that stand between him and a victory
with the black pieces and look at him
look at how he's evaluating this
position he's digging deep here he's
concentrated he's also up a rook in a
minor piece but with little time on your
clock mistakes happen right ahead on
time white with the safer King so as
long as black can keep the king safe
eduarding turizaga is in charge but
Donna I mean so much action is happening
right now I know that this game is
interesting but in the bottom left we
won't dive in just yet Benjamin Buck has
an advantage although letting it slip a
bit with that last move the bottom left
you see the bishop pair for black
staring across the position their pins
Galore it's going to be an interesting
one let's go back to our game with Alice
Lee and Alan P show because Alice only
has 25 seconds remaining and this would
be a huge win for the archbishops if she
can convert this Advantage but Daniel we
say this often right just because the
eval Bar says one thing doesn't mean
it's that straightforward this position
is not easy at all it most certainly is
not 23 seconds no position is easy easy
when you've got 20 seconds G3 might be
necessary to secure the F4 do not give
that pawn away but Alice is just taking
too long and she's going for it with
Knight to D6 but what is her idea after
Knight takes F4 do not play Queen G3 and
blunder the fork on E2 very easy to
blunder in time pressure Robert I hope I
just didn't Jinx or queen F3 might be a
wiser move but she's down to 10 seconds
before
and if the key point is that there are
swap of Queens of Rook B8 you do have
Rook d8 check to save your minor piece
Rook dhek
gotta do it Rook D7 also possible but
now your Rook is tied down to the Knight
and Alice is completely losing control
of this game
but still with very good chances to hold
because if we do a quick material count
uh right now black has Five Pawns white
has six if I'm counting correct very
awkward pawns whoa that's what's the
point of that one not taking on e4 he
can take it again
I really don't see what he was trying to
do maybe Knight of Fate robber but then
the Rook has C7 So you you're not gonna
win the Knight
and look at how it's protecting the
Ponce oh she wants Knight D6 great moves
87 Pawn is targeted and by the way the
G7 square is a bit tender we do have a
result by the way it looks like Benjamin
Bach and Jose Carlos ibar they drew
their game which is shocking considering
that black was better throughout and I
think a draw not the result the
archbishops one especially with Theodore
in such trouble most certainly not and
Benjamin losing confidence in his
position it appears that Fabiano caruana
is very very close to winning his game
but let's stay here because Alice Lee
has regained a measure of control in
fact I think she's better again because
look at her pieces they're much better
place than black a Long Beach show he
wasted two Tempe with a move 96 and now
he's paying the price
but where's that Bishop going there's
maybe some night tricks because the Rook
on B8 is hanging uh through that Bishop
excuse me through the Knight on D6 but I
think that for a lot of his show he can
probably bring his Rook active and I
think yeah with the trade of wait let's
repeat one check that really scared me
there I was like I just wondering as
well by the way Eduardo tourizaga has
indeed converted that massive material
advantage scoring a victory for the
maniac shrooms who are currently up one
and a half to a half this game is going
to be pivotal I think Alice Lee has it
under control if she plays Rook d8
Robert the one thing you cannot afford
to blunder is Rook to B2 if you lose G2
you lose the game and she's giving away
the checks she needs to Rook D7 and she
goes after the bishop very smart Bishop
C6 keep keep chasing the bishop a bit
but if he shows playing for a win here
he wants Rook B2 and to win the g-pod
and here comes the king but G4
Bishop D2 maybe oh she goes up there
oh she takes G7 I didn't even see that
she just wins a pawn
just just like us he slaps his head but
great recognition from Alice Lee and she
is now up upon her King is feeling safer
it should not be winning according to
the eval bar but she does have the upper
hand with that past t-ball but I don't
like the direction because she's dropped
the a pawn she couldn't defend it but
she's gone a little bit too passive I
think she wants Rook C3 but the bishop
easily blockades the pawn oh and Alice
blundering a pawn of her own on H4 she's
losing the thread here still a drawable
position but a lot is going to push his
ape on Robert and I feel like this is
just too much pressure and White's uh
given White's clock situation yeah and
the bishop on D6 it looks great it's
protecting this Pawn G3 just push that
pawn gotta try it you watch out for a
back ranked mate though The Rook isn't
trying to go to A4 A1 H1 if you can put
them look at which one now that would be
checkmate Rook C7 though Alice not going
gentle into that good night she can push
C6 simultaneously stopping the a pawn I
don't like that move though she stops it
with a rook no it's gonna be the
Checkmate that I talked about Rook C1
Rook H1 is made oh no yeah
Rook C1 G4 maybe G4 staves it off but
then you're gonna lose that pawn Robert
to Bishop E6
at the very least the king F7 played if
we get a check we're gaining a little
bit of time and by the way five minute
car one did win his game with the black
pieces against Sabrina Vega Gutierrez
this game
he's letting the pawn go sh is there
before six it's not even made
G4 by Alice clearing up the G3 square
but she is going to drop that pawn
however she can win A4 and reach C7 with
her passer
King age four three can you throw this
rookie E4 maybe so she goes back to H2
and she just wants C7 she's giving up G4
black love connected past Pawns of the
king side but look at the bishop on D6
protecting the passer and stopping the
enemy one
and there's a mate on H1 and Bishop
takes G3 you take back with check and
play Rook C3 Allen delivers in the
clutch oh or does he or does he smoke
too soon
and she finds it
Rook A4 now you take the pawn
just go Rook takes A4 and the pawn
cannot promote the bishop on H2 does
everything all at once a king up to each
you go up to E3
but this should be sufficient and now
you pursue the bishop if Alan is not
careful he can lose this Alice has to
avoid getting too passive Alice has to
avoid allowing black to put the pawn on
F4 Bishop F4 and Rook C1 that is a drone
Rook C1 Rooks oh loud F4
she has to trade Rooks
he traits Rooks it's a draw immediately
Bishop F4 she
idea Allen didn't push his F1 when he
had the chance
but now he can do now he does he has but
somehow could be one rookie one to B4
she's getting too passive
he's getting too passive F2 pre-move and
Black's Bishop stops the pawn which
gives The Rook the freedom to move
and okay
oh it's made oh that's a nasty move
Alice going for stalemate but there is
no stalemate
no there is not an
H4 is now hanging this is a win 4p show
a huge win for the maniac shrimps the
game is over he is just you know feeling
fortunate to have survived that one
Alice had the upper hand time was not
her friend and the scoreboard is a
friend of the Spanish Maniac shrimp LMP
show we just watched him win Eduardo
terizaga he dominated that game against
Nicholas Theodore Fabiano caruana gets
the job done with the black pieces
against Sabrina Vega Gutierrez Madonna
Benjamin Bach agreeing to that draw
against Jose Carlos Ibarra that's what
separates the two teams it most
certainly is Benjamin was borderline
winning out of the opening he held all
of the cards but he slipped up he lost
his confidence and his advantage and
Ibarra slices away at what seemed like a
Surefire Victory St Louis archbishops
are trailing after one round Alice Lee
did everything she could to pull that
game off she was completely winning but
ultimately the enemy rears its ugly head
again her time management has cost her
so many games in the Pro chess league
but hats off to Alice Lee we're playing
on completely even terms with top GM's
over 2600. yes he's been a great find
for the archbishops in the world of
Chess at large but the Spanish Maniac
shrimps they don't care about fan
favorites they want to win they want to
Stave off elimination right now they
have a two and a half one half lead and
right now Donya Knight will take a quick
break because when we return round two
of this great match between the maniac
shrimps and the archbishops continues
here in the protest League
and instead the gloves came absolutely
off the wheels came off wow the sip of
tea the celebratory
when I saw that reaction I felt what you
were feeling like I felt this this
transfer of energy of like that kind of
moment that kind of of upset is uh is so
exhilarating so can you just talk a
little bit about like how you're feeling
in that moment what was going through
your mind uh what it means to you
yeah I mean it was very difficult to
believe
like I don't know I just didn't see this
scenario happen where actually it was
funny we were in trainings Camp until a
few days before this with the German
national team and all the guys from my
team were there and we were at lunch and
I said for fun okay don't worry I will
take care of Hikaru
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
obviously it's just like it's another
day in the office she didn't even blink
I was blinked twice if you're in trouble
right like we're being told by Chad
Alice has no mercy she gonna convert
this one I mean with her eyes closed she
could put it in blindfold give her an
extra five minutes she'll do a blindfold
right G4 right here that was beautiful
wow resignation resignation oh my
goodness
upset of the protest League James Alice
is truly in Wonderland today she is
killing what a girl what a player
foreign
but last week against the Berlin Bears
she had one win two draws and just a
single loss from board fourth in fact
she took down Matthias bluebound whose
fide rating is 2650 Plus at age 13 she's
the second youngest player in the Pro
chess League I mean Dania she already
has such an impressive list of
accomplishments and she's just getting
started it's such a crazy time in the
Chess World we're talking about 13 year
old Alice Lee who already has several
over-the-board wins against IMS and GM's
uh in her belt she's played in Charlotte
quite a few times so I've been familiar
with her really since 2020 when her feed
a rating was something like 1900 you
knew that that one would be replaced by
a two and the hundreds digit would be a
three pretty quickly as it is now Alice
does not give her opponents any leeway
yeah I got you but Donya you know she
just lost that game that's tough on any
chess player uh do you think you know
she's young do you think she has the
resolve to bounce back and score some
points for the archbishops she
definitely does and I think she
displayed that even in her first week
match against the Shanghai tigers where
yes I believe she lost all four games
but she didn't till she was better in
all four of those games it's important
to keep that growth mindset right you're
coming in you're you you know that
you're gonna lose some good positions
you know that you have some issues with
your time management so it's important
not to get down on yourself and to
realize that what is required of you and
what is expected of you is really only
one half point if she can pull out one
draw one win she gives the St Louis
archbishops the Boost that they need and
I just want to say that in week one she
lost game four because she refused the
repetition she knew the team needed her
to win so she said I'm not splitting a
point so Alice Lee we'll see if she can
bounce back but the entire St Louis
archbishops will need to score some
points in the second round a Long Beach
show he just won that time scramble
against Alice Lee he gets white against
Nicholas Theodore with theodoro he got
blitzed by Eduardo atarizaga who himself
gets white against Alice Lee and then
down there the bottom two matchups
Fabiano with white bedroom Bach with
white Dania who's more likely to take
this round between the shrimps and the
archbishops this is a really really
interesting round for Eduardo itsurizaga
it's essentially a must-win game with
white against Alice Lee big X Factor
game to me is P show against Theodore
neither of those players really played
to their level in the first round he
show he made a lot of mistakes that
level is just not going to cut it
against an angry Nicholas theodoro who
lost in his own territory he is armed to
the teeth in the elephant Sicilian but
something went terribly wrong against
utsuri Saga and Rob another game that
I'm so excited for is Fabiano caruana's
game against Jose Carlos Ibarra who has
scored so many upsets in title Tuesday
he's defeated Fabi uh in title Tuesdays
but can that transfer over to a slightly
longer time control game
that's the big question and we just saw
in game one that buck had an advantage
he was not able to convert it uh but
that's a thing of the past you have to
have short-term memory loss and we see
that a lot of show gets white against
Nicholas Theodore now on paper Donna
their ratings quite similar I mean and
this is not an upset if Theodore wins
they are very close in strength but we
are seeing a sicilian from Theodore with
an early E5 and we're getting a
speshnikov so early stages both players
well prepared
what do you know about Theodore's
opening choices you've played him
countless times on chess.com
yeah Nicholas is Sicilian player at
heart he also likes E4 E5 and his
headlines in the real Lopez here he
sticks with what he mostly plays uh in
over the board classical chess which is
the smash nikoff he also plays the
Knight or so any kind of Sicilian he is
going to be armed to the teeth with both
colors now he was on the white side of
an elephant in the last game here we
have an open Sicilian nice vashnikov and
Alan pisho essay Robert a line that was
very popular made even more popular when
Fabi played it against Magnus Carlson in
their world championship match the queen
comes out to A4 early and you could get
checkmated here in like one move if you
fall asleep
and Theodore has not fallen asleep he
brings his Queen over to B8 and these
positions get super sharp black will
strike with F5 I'm not sure if now is
the right time to do that you play A6
first to kick the Knight out of there
but at some point black is going to push
that pawn up to F5 very likely and then
you see when you cut the board in half
white Pawn Advantage Queen side black
pawn Advantage King side and that's
where the action will take place
I was trying to draw the two squares but
they are moving way too fast for me to
draw any sort of art on the board the
pawn moves first to A6 chasing away the
Knight now to A5 grabbing space and
chasing away the queen big decision
where is it gonna go there's our answer
to B3 black completes his kingside
development and prepares the castle we
are going to see F5 I would bet a silver
dollar on that the question is when
and then for white you know what's the
question is F5 F4 is that threatening
the bishop on E3 has the B6 Square
unlike in many other positions the
bishop would have to retreat here the
bishop can hop forward and speaking of
hopping forward the Knight is saying
give me that B6 Square I feel like this
position tamias looks very pleasant for
white you have control of the B6 Square
you may toss in the move C5 just to try
to get more advanced with your pieces I
like picho's opening yeah this is a cool
position but it does seem like for the
time being white has struck first on the
queen side you can't castle that walks
right into Knight B6 with a fork but
Knight B6 is a huge Standalone thread
because the Rook just says no squares
Rook A6 C5 and you can basically resign
so Nico might have to play a damage
control move like Bishop d8 but the last
thing you want to do is give up your
dark Square Bishop because then the D6
Pawn becomes the Sitting Duck and
whatever King side play you can whip up
becomes a lot less effective if you
don't have both of your Bishops so once
again Nicholas is struggling in an
opening that he's usually very well
prepared in
not pleasant for him uh and while he
sits and he struggles to find a move I
think we should zoom out because there's
a funny opening that happened in the
game between Fabiano caruana and Jose
Ibarra oh yeah left so it's starting to
look familiar to a certain Daniel
narodisky just because he played this
recently against Jose Martinez better
known as Jasmine and by the way all four
games have officially started we see
Bach playing C4 in English in the bottom
right but if we can dive in to karwana
against Ibarra I just want to show
Black's first move like I I really just
want to go back and show how this game
went look at Black's first move here
nemesevich
you ever see at the highest level
instead of putting a pawn forward trying
to control the center you play uh Knight
C6 and 50 gave him the opportunity to go
into a Spanish right play E5 let's get
to familiar territory Ibarra says nah
man like I don't want to go into a
theoretical discussion with one of the
best prepared players in the planet
I call this the pp the provocative
Pirates because it is a pirates you play
Knight F6 and G6 what's the provocative
part well you're walking right into D5
Fabby says you don't have to tell me
twice the Knight drops back to B8 but
just like in all hyper modern idea
because the idea to make white
overextend himself just because you have
more space in the center does it
necessarily mean that you're much better
and after Castle's castles we see uh the
secondary idea black is starting to chip
away at White Center with the move C6
this also repairs Queen side expansion
with B5 is black worse in this opening
absolutely I can confirm that Robert
because I've played this pretty
extensively in my last few rapper
tournaments against Hari Krishna uh in
AIM chess I played E5 which I think is
the best objective move but C6 I think
is the most popular continuation any
borrow follows that up by deploying his
Knight to C5 I think he's doing okay
yeah it's not you know a position that
he has to be too concerned about he may
end up with some double pawns but that's
not the end of the world uh he's not
gonna cry about that and he's playing
very quickly so the worst thing you can
have happen against a superstar like
carwana is to have a position that
you're not comfortable in and to be
using all the time so Ibarra he actually
is dictating the opening choice now he
has to think because the Knight went
back to D2 E4 Pawn is very well defended
uh B4 at some moment Maybe not
immediately because the bishop on G7 is
staring through that Knight enough six
across the board but B4 may just be
kicking Black's Knight back and getting
even more space
Fabby I was just distracted by fabi's
background he looks like he's in sort of
greek temple like the pantheon with
whatever statue of Hippocrates or
Pythagoras that is in the background
that looks like some distinguished
philosophers not a telescope on his
right what is that
um I don't know it might just be a mic
stand that's oh yeah that is not a
telescope man my brain is in this in the
skies right now
well Fabiano caruana's rating has been
in the skies for a long time we expect
uh nothing short of Excellence from him
and his teammates are probably expecting
the same so this one is early uh I think
they're gonna slow down at this point
but I just noticed uh one game that has
been speeding along is the one that we
started with in the top left of course
in the top right Alice Lee has the black
pieces against Eduardo eterozaga early
in that one but look at the top left
Dania the Queens are gone and we're in a
queenless middle game where white has
double pawns and black is the first of
the C file black is the first of the C5
that is important because I always like
to point out when there's only one open
file you want to make sure that you are
the side that controls it Bishop B2 is
the last movie show completes is minor
piece development and in order jumps
into F4 Robert I think it's safe
the worst is far behind him
I like Theodore's position we may get
Bishops of opposite color but because
black is first in the open file and
there are some pawns that white will
need to tend to I like what Theodore is
doing so we don't have to dive into that
one we just just want to make note of it
in the bottom right Benjamin Buck
Sabrina Gutierrez there are no Queens on
that board and Black's King is in the
center and no it's not some kind of
delayed bomb Cloud it just was a queen
trade that happened and now it's Bach on
the clock
that was smooth AF Bach on the clock I
mean you're performing poetry and
commentating the games I mean you're
making me feel seriously inferior here
now Black's position I think is a little
bit inferior because white has better
control of the center right that pawn on
C4 really clamping down on the D5 Square
Bishop G5 comes to mind it threatens
Knight D5 track but that's a pretty easy
threat to Perry black and play C6 which
in turn weakens the D6 Pawn so I think
this is how white has to play here
massage the position try to induce a
pawn weakness and maybe Castle queenside
to jump start your pressure on that pawn
this clamp is so annoying I've had so
many positions like this from the black
side we're like I should be okay right I
have no weaknesses uh I'm gonna develop
easily but then coming up with the plan
is not simple and that pawn on B7 that
can be such a sore point in Black's
position because the bishop on G2 is so
superbly placed aiming across the
diagonal and so I just feel like Buck
should be happy about his opening and
yet he's the one down a minute and now
nearly 40 seconds
yeah I mean Benjamin really investing
some time trying to figure out I think
two big questions where to put the
bishop and the second question where
should he Castle he decides to attend to
the second problem first the Castle's
gang side a very modest approach and now
I think he has to solve the first
problem maybe bishop B3 Bishop D4 uh
should be considered as well to take the
sting out of Black's strongest piece and
then Knight enough six is stuck because
as soon as the Knight moves Knight D5
check happens and he I think what
Benjamin's doing here is he's saying no
C6 for you I'm already targeting the D6
Pawn you need that little chain there
but if you don't play C6 the bishop on
G2 is happy if you do play C6 the pawn
on D6 is not happy so you just have to
give and take in this game and while the
King goes back to f8 let's take a look
at another game just because this one
does feel like it's more methodical it's
going to be about maneuvering and I'm
looking across the boards in the top
right we have not looked at eternizaga
against Alice Lee so why don't we tune
in there as it looks like Alice Lee with
the black pieces doesn't really have any
concerns at the moment not at all and
she doesn't have any minor pieces either
Tori Saga you could say the same thing
about him there's a mere pair of Bishops
there are two Rooks and there is a queen
queen A3 was itsuri saga's last move I
like that move he is trying to punish
Alice for having her Queen far away from
the queen side and we're getting more
liquidation here Queen takes A7 is the
last move wait a second Robert can
blacklight D take C3 and emerge with a
better position with White's King a
Sitting Duck or am I seeing things
I just like had tuned in a couple moves
ago when I first saw it and that was a
queen on A7 but what are you seeing when
you but the way you sing Oh it's gonna
be D3 isn't it some kind of it is going
to be D3 you always have to note the
Rooks on forkable squares D3 the eval
bar doesn't change so we know it's the
right move that blunder is the bishop no
it does not here you do not play D2 if
we could pull up in an L sport this is
Worth showing because here white plays
Rook takes you oh but I get two queens
yeah but you also get checkmated on the
back rank so you need to find the
Intermezzo Rook C8 to B8 oh is what
makes this machine run this is an
incredibly hard move to find Robert and
moreover Queen D7 stops C2 now you tail
the queen want to get once again of The
Rook Queen moves away and now you play
D2 you're gonna emerge up in exchange
with a big Advantage if Alice Lee finds
D3 if Alice Lee finds D3 I tell you oh
boy
and I actually think itarizaga has
spotted it the way he was looking up
before leads me to believe that he sees
his opponent's tactic now some of the
players have their opponent their zoom
camera like attach their screen so they
can always see it with their periphery
others ignore their opponent altogether
but Alice Lee She's calculating here so
what moves come to mind your Bishop's
under attack Bishop D5 that looks like a
very safe and sound move but if she
plays D3 here iterizaga is in huge
trouble that becomes a protected
passport she takes on E3 I change Mr
Robert you know you never really jinx it
I just feel like that's a hard tactic to
spot when you don't have the evil bar
telling you you have a good chance so I
think her position right now the reason
why she may be slightly worse is white
has outside past Pawn potential you see
that black has an extra f-pawn white has
an extra a pawn so it's even material
but white in end games can push outside
past pawns that will be used as a
minimum a decoy and a maximum maybe a
new Queen
and I can totally see why Alice was
attracted to this for the same reason
that I initially thought that black was
better I was looking at this E3 pawn and
I was saying the fact that the White
Queen on A7 is locked away for the time
being because the Blackwing defends F6
V6 the problem is that black does not
have the Firepower nor the horsepower
literally or no more Knights he would
love a knight on F5 or a night on G4 the
bishop on D5 is dulled by the pawn and
E4 it's not doing anything it's under
Fire the queen out of six already has a
job that's defending B6 so Queen G5 here
would be great but it enables white to
capture B6 and defend E3 so it's a
logistical problem here where Alice just
doesn't have sufficient pieces to
perform all of the tasks in her position
successfully she's gonna have to stay
passive but with three minutes and 50
seconds I'm starting to get a little bit
pessimistic here about or prospects here
in in the second game yeah she's
spending a lot of time in the Eva bar
may say it's still Level yeah but I'm
saying no to this one Donya I mean the
evil bar suggesting she should be okay
but I just feel like practically
speaking easier for white the E3 Pawn
that does look like a weakness very
difficult to get to as you just showed
that the queen can capture the pawn on
B6 defend the E3 Pawn behind it so yeah
this is just not a moment that I think
that Alice is going to be thrilled about
uh but she should be okay but it's just
going to take a bunch of accurate moves
so while she sits and thinks why don't
we bring in a special guest for you all
someone who has a vested interest in
this match we have Nemo the captain of
the Archbishop with us Nemo how you
doing
I'm doing great how are you both
Donna you're good absolutely well Robert
I don't want to speak for you
that you know despite my co-common I'm
doing I'm doing okay you know suffering
suffering through the round Nemo you can
you can relate yeah
it's okay
just keep me out of it I'm gonna go away
Donna you keep happening come back come
back Robert
oh no he's just decided we love you
Robert
what do we need to do Nemo to get him
back on this chair what do we need to do
how do we speak
I think we just need to have some very
interesting positions happen because
well you know I'm the team captain for
the St Louis archbish Chef so I'm always
rooting for St Louis win and um the two
and a half to one and a half score from
the previous match unfortunately means
that it's not going our favor right now
um I know Robert also knows a few people
on the team we don't we're done we're
not playing favorites here I assume but
I I would personally like to see a St
Louis come back this this round
yeah I feel that Nemo uh but you know I
think a lot of the people who are
watching this match they're rooting for
Alice Lee what's it been like having her
on the team because she's very young
she's an improving player and it seems
like she's gaining many new fans
yeah absolutely I mean she seems to have
you know had
attracted people coming in since day one
the first the first match that she did
play in
um everybody was commenting on you know
her age she's quite young obviously
she's super strong and then last week
she actually beat
blue ball Matthias who is a very strong
Grandmaster from Germany and you know it
it just means that there's a lot of
potential for Alice and not that she's
all right not already really really
strong but there's even more potential
since she is so young
well you also have a lot of potential
Nemo on the top boards you have that
Trifecta of Bach theodoro and haruana
can you talk a little bit about what
it's like to have two super Grand
Masters you also have some dude named
Leonard Dominguez what does that bring
to your team and what kinds of
expectations do you have of your very
top players
personally I'm expecting Fabi to win
every single game
um and if he doesn't you know I'm sure
yes I'm sure we can have a talk with him
no but but actually Fabi has been having
a great performance so far the very
first week that Dominguez played
unfortunately he did not perform the
very best I believe he scored one and a
half out of the four games he played so
you know
um a little tweak there we put Fabian
and now Fabi has just won his previous
game although his opponent dip blunder
he did win his previous game
um and currently his position actually
you know he's he seems to be doing just
fine
in this in this round too
yeah he's got a big time advantage and a
better position against Ibarra more good
news Nemo for your team if you go back
to the bird's eye view Benjamin Buck he
is solid as a rock shall I say solid as
a buck but he's not solid this game he
is bloodthirsty this game he's got a
Pawn on C5 if we zoom into that game I
think the game is nearly over and the
clock isn't doing Sabrina any favors
either Nemo this looks like a point in
the bag for your team
yeah absolutely I mean when you get a
opening like this you get all this peace
activity and you just seem to be very
familiar with Theory I I did
interview him after the match last week
and he said that he's going to put in a
lot of prep going to study a bit more
for this week because we are in a
must-win situation uh we do have to win
this match in order to proceed to the
next round so
it's great to see him putting in work
yeah well he's putting in great work I
mean he had a good position in the first
game it ended up in a draw but it looks
like he is in the driver's seat just
going to win a pawn in the near future
and well while this one looks good for
St Louis there are other boards looking
good for y'all as well this might be a
great round for you Nemo I don't want to
jinx it no commentators curses here but
as we look in the top left Nicholas
Theodore with the black pieces he is no
worse in that opposite colored Bishop
position in the bottom left five
undercarwana the eval bar loves his
position and you said he needs to win
otherwise he's kicked off the team and
then in the top right Alice Lee
completely holding her own against Grand
Master Eduardo iterizaga so I feel like
your squad they're living up to the hype
and they know you're on camera they know
you're with us here anymore I feel like
they might be doing this for you
you know I'm sending sending them luck
sending them some ideas by the brain
waves obviously
um but yeah Alice Alice being able to
hold this game is going to be absolutely
amazing she's played really well so far
I feel like her score in the PCL does
not reflect the nature of her games I
think she had the potential to have a
much better
score and I'm really I'm really excited
for this game 10 and a draw you don't
hear that very often but I I would be
very happy with the draw here
oh it would be a great result for Alice
and she's actually making improvements
here to her position if Eduardo
overpresses this absolutely could result
in a loss for him Alice's kingside Pawn
mask is more mobile and she could
actually play G5 and try to get a four
and Robert I'm maybe being a little bit
over optimistic but the biggest problem
the biggest enemy for Alice has been in
her clock management and here we see her
fall below a minute once again this is
what's starting to worry me because when
you've got 10 seconds you can lose
anything
a calmer move but I I feel like it's one
of those moments where when a player's
improving they're told you know focus on
the classical chess you know take your
time but Nemo Dania I feel like this is
a situation where like play more bullet
like you know you need to get that Mouse
speed down
yeah I don't know I don't know how good
she is at Blitz
um she's definitely stumbled a few times
before
intense time control situations but I
feel like she's also getting the
practice in now I mean she's she's this
is her third match I believe and she's
played a couple of 10-2 games I I
believe in her speed her King might look
a little bit exposed but
you know
um why can't exactly attack the king
there's not enough material to threaten
Checkmate the e-pawn is still slightly
weak and the queen is holding everything
together or was maybe now she's just
going for a queen to G5 Queen trade and
exactly as you've highlighted Robert
yeah I think Alice is still holding her
own but maybe white can find a way to go
G4 this is going down to the wire which
means that we will let you watch the
games in peace Nemo you are the captain
of the archbishops a resurgent our
Bishop archbishops we wish your team the
best of luck as they attempt to mount a
comeback and make it to the playoffs
thanks Nemo
thank you so much
always great to have Nemo on stream with
us she is streaming right now if you
don't already follow her have you not
been paying attention to chess for the
last few years go follow Nemo stream
let's drop the link in the chat but
right now her team is doing well in the
second round they enter with it oh
I'm sorry to cut you off we have to go
to the Fabi game let's go right oh my
goodness look at the bottom left
everybody there's a bishop on G7 and a
queen on H6 A3
it's made into Bishop 8 shade is made
into what a beautiful mating
construction I'm sorry for cutting
cutting you off fire but this was worth
looking at and we got courtside seats to
a beautiful mating construction by Mr
caruana yeah don't apologize for cutting
me off Bobby just cut his opponent's
king off that is decapitation on G7 and
that is sick Bishop h8 you were
expecting queen h8 I'm sure that's uh
what Jose was looking at maybe the you
know give a check the king runs F7 I
could survive for a little bit but there
is no stopping mate after Bishop h8
that's really nice I gotta rewind a
little bit you mentioned decapitation
Leonardo decapitation he first
decapitated the a pawn then he came back
then he took G7 he bar said okay I'm
doing fine I'm just gonna play King
takes G7 on the NATO what was that on
which movie
there is the mate threat of course Fabby
could have taken the Rook but Bishop h8
can I say that is a sexy move to finish
this game off and score another very
important point for Nemo's Saint Louis
archbishop's Fabi is firing on all
cylinders thus far and let's go back to
our bird's eye view a big win 4-5
undercarwana you look in the bottom
right we know the buck is in charge now
he's completely winning it seems as
black is going to lose a piece the 996
will be pinned in five different
directions but look at the top left game
both players are in time trouble between
Alan picho and Nicholas theodoro so in
their time to I think we got to go there
for the scramble let's go there for the
time scramble opposite colored Bishops
draw Shannon sees yes but Nicholas
Theodore has just declined to drive he
feels that he's got the winning chances
I don't think he really does Rookie 6
check was a really nice move to keep
blacks King at Bay I think Alan just
needs to make a couple more accurate
moves to hold this together yeah the
only chance black has is to put the
bishop on E7 go King E5 and push her
deep on but it's hard to get that
arrangement of pieces but you need to
somehow get that Bishop back towards the
E7 squared nope the game is a drop Fair
result indeed let's get on out of here
no more to analyze this point is split
that is reasonable and look we have two
games going in the bottom right no that
game is finished it was ready this one
you see the Rooks doubled up on the D
file and then the top right we of course
have Alice Lee with the black pieces
against Edwards and done it we have to
go into that one because Alice Lee has
just sacrificed her B6
pawns is there a repetition is she
relying on an epon going oh what a move
what a move
I thought you should push the E Pawn but
she's trying to open that King up I was
positive she would move for open but she
has to be so careful where she steps
with her King I think she should go Full
Tilt with King H4 Robert Queenie seven
King G3 is Checkmate not for black oh my
God for white this is actually a three
result game and Robert Queen F2 takes
takes and then H2 is a crazy position or
white actually can stop the pawn I think
Eduardo should try Queen F2 check here
oh my gosh Queen F2 wait you think he
sticks hands up the pawn barely that's
so scary though barely barely barely I
think that should lead to a repetition
Eduardo has to see that move or I think
he might lose
yeah no his position is one where if he
does not play Queen F2 the game may be
in Alice's favor uh right now the
archbishops have a four to three lead
they're taking control in the second
round itirizaga needs to at least 10
seconds at the point he goes for it
there you go now Alice has to be very
accurate H2 is followed by G3 check
vacating the G2 Square for the king if
black steps onto H3 the bishop retreats
to F1 we're gonna see that and Alice
needs to use her e-pawn to win White's
bishop or she will lose
so King G2 uh you're gonna have to play
E3 and get your king up to F3 once the
king for white takes the H2 Pawn so uh
maybe you even throw an H1 check by the
way and take the G3 Pawn right away
Black's King activity allows her to
survive this game and don't know just
one thing to point out the A2 Pawn goes
to A8 that's a light square there's a
light score Bishop so there is no Bishop
sacrifice for the B Pawn that will not
do the trick
that's a great Point Alice trying to
force her iPod up the board but she's
let the king step onto F1 oh my gosh you
might be losing the threat again or is
she she's getting her King back to the
rescue this has gotten really scary
now this is very scary but E2 that
that's great recognition by her E2 would
not have worked the King goes to the D2
Square so she's stopping the pause
Bishop F7 ends it Robert Bishop D1 you
can even play E2 and just sack your
Bishop for the B3 Pawn you can even play
Bishop takes B3 immediately she finds it
and this game is going to be a draw
short you know and water makes the right
decision not to take the bishop because
now he could still maybe try to Hope and
win but King B3 King takes A3 is
automatic Alice Lee takes a half point
off a grand master Eduardo itarizaga
with the black pieces it was no joke we
said this in week one she may have lost
all four games but she had an advantage
against the likes of weigi and the rest
of the Shanghai Tigers last week she
beats Matthias bluebound draws two other
games now she was an up and down battle
in the first game against P show she
draws eduaro iterizaga and with that
draw the archbishops take the second
round three to one Bach gets the job
done carwana gets the job done and the
other two boards with black they split
the point Donna you couldn't have
written this up any better no you could
not as someone in the chat said St Louis
archbishop's cooking up some shrimp
scampi this round especially on the
strength of karwana and box wins with
the white pieces Alice Lee doing her job
I was so impressed with her playing time
pressure navigating the complexities of
that end game with 10 seconds left not
making a single mistake that was amazing
and Nicholas theodoro doing his job he
plays a solid game with black and draws
from a position of strength the shrimp
scampi the vanish Maniac shrips one
point lead is nowhere to be found now
we've got a one point lead for the other
team the archbishops Robert they put
themselves in a position where they
could take this match in the next round
all they'd have to do is win 4-0 pretty
easy
and it's a lead for the archbishops you
know of course uh you're just joking
around a little bit here but as we look
at the results from the top through the
bottom of uh the lineups here Fabiano
and Benjamin Bach they're getting the
job done for the archbishops P show and
ichirizaga they're doing quite well but
it's about Alice Lee down there she took
a half point from a top two board so
that's the difference right karwana and
buck at three and a half for the shrimps
the top it's only three so good job from
Alice Lee they're scoring a half out of
two against the top two boards and guess
what now she gets to play Boards three
and four so she is putting herself in
position to score some more points but
it's just a one point spread right now
the maniac shrimps are right in this
they could turn this one back in their
favor they did win the first round after
all so I think we will take a break just
like the players are doing they're
stretching their legs they're looking at
some chests we will very much do the
same and we're in return it's more from
this epic matchup between The Maniacs
rims and the arch push-ups here in the
process League
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
thank you
[Music]
in this video series I cover the entire
184 185 Spectrum so all the openings
that arises after our one E4
I have had a lot of experience in this
I've played several games with
prominence at a game against Levon
aronium from the world team championship
I also had a game from Gibraltar against
Marcus ragger which is the game that I'm
going to show here
the key here when this happens when your
opponent finds a resource of playing F4
or you reach this position in your
calculations don't panic
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this matchup of the St Louis archbishops
and the Spanish Maniac shrimps it's been
a close one first the shrimps were in
the lead then the Archbishop stormed
back so currently we see the archbishops
lead by one point it is four and a half
three and a half Donya from top to
bottom there have been some great
results some great games from the
archbishops but the Mania shrimps
they're still very close right in this
thing
they are absolutely in this thing I mean
these rounds could have gone either way
these games are at a knife's edge they
are going down to the wire Robert Alice
Lee pulling out a huge draw against
Eduardo itarizag and Fabiano caruana
just doing his thing we heard it from
Nemo she was she is expecting a four out
of four performance well well begun is
half done and Fabi is halfway to a
perfect performance I think you'll need
to keep delivering if he wants to keep
the St Louis archbishops on top
and I think you should keep delivering
the poetic justice that was awesome that
rhymed there don't think I missed that
but we don't want to miss a single game
and coming up is round three of this
match and all play all format Benjamin
Buck gets the white pieces and gets a
lumpy show live in a car wanna gets
white against Edward utirizaga Alice Lee
Nicholas Theodore get black but Fabiano
caruana white Eduardo eats her Saga
black that Rings a familiar Bell because
in anticipation of this matchup I had a
flashback to 2018 and I remembered this
final position when Fabiana carwana took
down Eduardo itarizaga in the protesting
the final move played was the white Rook
back to F5 because if the black Rook
takes it the Knight takes back with
check and mate and if the Rook moves
anywhere else then the white roof picks
up that pawn in behind the black king
for checkmate it's a five minute caruana
with a nasty final position of victory
over itarizaga he would like history to
repeat itself so Dania for the maniac
shrimp what does itarizaga need to do
differently how can he fend off against
the mighty caruana
well we see the man himself I think
durizaga has to try to get Fabiano in
time pressure Fabi has improved his
Blitz and rapid play exponentially over
the last few years that's a narrative
that's an arc that we have been
following uh and that is so admirable
for somebody at this level to change
their way of playing in Rapid and Blitz
is amazing but first and foremost before
we talk about anything else Eduardo has
to get a reasonable position out of the
opening and we know that Fabby is armed
to the teeth he's played D4 Robert which
is a surprise Fabby going for the
Catalan not a frequent guest in his
tournament practice
no but he does escalate his opening
every now and then an A5 so this opening
from the black side you want white to
trade Bishops because when the black
pawn ends up on B4 the Knight on B1 is
stuck in place a bit the a file would be
open so that's why you see the players
ignore the bishop Saron until a turizaga
long last brings the bishop back so done
it they're moving very very quickly
clearly both familiar with this opening
who do you like it for maybe not so much
objectively but in terms of style
I mean I think it's hard to say because
Eduardo is a positional player at heart
he's pretty versatile in the sense that
he plays the Sicilian against E4 but
with white Eduardo likes the English he
likes methodical maneuvering play and I
think both sides are happy here Fabi has
gotten uh the kind of quiet position
with a safe King that he clearly wanted
Eduardo has gotten a positionally rich
situation with a lot of maneuvering
potential so it's very hard to make any
conclusions just yet but one thing I can
say Robert is that White's man plan here
is to prepare a quick E4 so I'm
expecting either an ibd2 or the more
adventurous Knight cc3 which does come
with a price tag you have to be ready to
sacrifice the C4 pawn and I actually
think that's what Fabi is deciding
between maybe 95 is also possible but
I'm expecting Knight bd2 followed by a
quick
well as Jessie J sings forget about the
price tag Daniel who cares with opponent
C4 you want to play E4 as white yeah he
does maybe he's just just trying to keep
the status quo because he feels like
that Knight on D7 the Superfluous
Knights for black right the 997 blocks
in the bishop on C8 the 97 also can't
jump forward because of that pawn on D4
so he's enjoying the spatial advantage
that he has but for black I think Bishop
before I could even finish my thought
Bishop A6 very important
aim at that C4 pod try to gain some
space maybe black will play B6 to B5 in
the near future and Challenge on the
queen side
I call this the hyperfin keto it is
standard fare in this line of the
Catalan the Knight has appeared on E5
Fabby trying to punish black we're
leaving the C6 Pawn unattended Eduardo
immediately grabs the Knight and
generally you see why playing D takes E5
and trying to shove that epon up the
board to E4 Robert this could actually
explode really really quickly if we
could pull up an analysis board if white
placed cdcd and E4 this may look
overwhelming for white but don't fall
asleep on the C file I feel like Rook C8
a well-timed rook C8 could come with a
great effect you could also explore the
positional Pawn sacrifice something like
D4 to keep White's Bishop closed either
way I think we're gonna see a very rich
middle game coming right up and that
position you have on screen there with
D4 I'm gonna steal one from your
playbook I'm gonna do a pun that's a New
York jettison of a pawn you give that
pawn up you go for the C file you get
your queen out of the pin that it's in
and the E5 Pawn later in the game will
be something that white will probably
not be able to hold on to so I like this
idea for iterizaga I think for Fabiano
he's trying to figure out what to do and
he plays H4 what's the relevance of that
move well I think it's a pretty bad sign
I think Fabi relied on e4 but perhaps he
underestimated that positional pontac
instead he doubles back or more
precisely he delays the move E4 I think
he's trying to discourage G5 which as
Brazen as it sounds was a threat Robert
because you do not you do not want to
lose the E5 Pawn that is the Cog that
makes your entire position run G5 is
still possible for what it's worth but
now it comes with a and even a heftier
price tag I don't know who you
referenced now I'm trying to remember
but there might even be some sort of a
sack on D5 if black dares to play G5
yeah there very well might be a sack on
that square so Fabiano that's not
preparation because he spent about two
minutes at this point but we'll leave
iterizaga in the think tank just because
that position is wild and three more are
underway in the bottom left we see Alice
Lee She essays the uh Caro Khan It's a
closed position there in the top left
the game between Benjamin buck and Alan
P show that game just looks hectic it's
still opening preparation from P show
but Benjamin Bach caught off guard and
the bottom right we have a closed
position uh from the Sicilian so I think
we could leave the bottom right for the
moment that one will probably last how
much longer let's go to the top left
with Bach having the white pieces but
now a three minute disadvantage of the
clock
oh we know all is right in the worlds
when we see that microwave of the
chessboard on top of it but right now A
lot of people are trying to put White's
dark squared Bishop in the microwave and
Bishops and microwaves don't go very
well together black wants to play H4
which does not trap the bishop but after
Bishop E5 you could continue pursuing
the bishop why does that want to give
the give up the bishop pair here
Benjamin Bach already taking pretty
Extreme Measures to curb the flow of
this game what's most disturbing is the
speed of pisho's play this is not the
kind of position in which you want to be
cut with your pants down but one of the
big issues here that I'm having as I
recall a certain game I'm pretty sure
carwana had the black pieces in this
exact position he eventually had a rook
lift with Rook to H6 so these types of
games can be quite sharp uh it's really
a lot to take in air and well already
now P show is out of his preparation so
that's a really good news for Bach and I
think we'll see Bishop D7 and after
Bishop takes Knight on C6 black will
throw in Bishop takes Knight on C3 so I
feel like black is still holding on to
everything and I tend to prefer the
activity that we see on the king side
but if you're not actually accurate
black could be a huge strategic danger
because you're over extending your pawns
you're over extending your pawns uh
you're leaving the king uh very much
unattended even if it Castle's King side
that pawn cover for the ponza G5 and H4
does not exactly Inspire confidence I'm
splitting Harris here but maybe it's
worth eliminating the Knight on C3 first
because if you enable white to bring the
Knight out to E2 Bishop takes C3 is
isn't going to come with quite as much
of an effect because it can be
recaptured with the Knight so a lot of
decisions to be made on both a strategic
and a tactical front really for both
players I like that move Bishop takes E3
has played it will be supplemented by
Bishop D7 no first he plays H4 we're
gonna get some fireworks here whoa whoa
whoa what is the deal here can't first
wait live I would take on C6 first just
to make sure that Black's Pawn structure
is doubled and then played Bishop E5
because I know Bishop E5 will be met by
Bishop D7 and then I don't get to hurt
the pawn structure so I think just first
take the Knight then Bishop B5 I like
Benjamin's position and P show he made
that move in two seconds I think he
could benefit from a longer thing
that's been his near undoing that could
have been his undoing against Alice Lee
but it's just not gonna fly against
Benjamin there was no need to rush H4
he's given Benjamin unnecessary perks
that Bishop on E5 coupled with a queen
that could land on A3 and prevent black
from castling I'm with you I think white
now has firmly the upper hand yeah and
you can just develop right Knight F3
hits the G5 Pawn Yeah that probably has
to play g4's response your night goes to
D2 and then B3 and then C5 like that
white knight is gonna get very active it
could also hop into E5 at some moment
after Bishop F6 and 95 so I really like
this position for buck strategically it
looks strong for him the tactics uh it's
not so sharp anymore so P show will have
to figure out if he can hold this one
but let's go away from uh this board
between Bach and P show just because all
the other games are interesting the
bottom right position between Sabrina
Vega Gutierrez and Nicholas theodoro
still very closed but then it was
happening in the bottom left between uh
Alice Lee with the black pieces and Jose
Carlos Ibarra
yeah my guess is as good as yours it's a
very convoluted Pawn structure the
position is very gummied up it's closed
the center is closed the queen side is
closed and the King side is also closed
but White's typical plan in these types
of structures is to run that F Pawn up
the board but Alice is going to say Over
My Dead Body she's gonna play G6 at the
right moment that does of course weaken
the dark squares but those squares are
nicely protected by black snide so I
think just visually white is better
Robert because black is very cramped
Alice has a hard time getting her Bishop
out and castling is illegal but it it's
not entirely clear to me how Ibarra is
going to continue pouring oil onto the
fire
well Alice has a show on chess kid
called Alice's Pawn Palace and I'm
seeing two different palaces here from
A7 to C5 and then F7 to D5 she has two
nice Pawn chains and she doesn't want to
really move any of her pawns she might
have to play G6 as a reaction to F4 but
for now she's just trying to say the C
file may open I control that break white
does not want to take on C5 that's clear
Pawn 65 would oh sorry oh I see what
you're doing I'm just gonna say the take
on C5 would be bad but then when you
freaked out I realize what you're aiming
at C4 for white could be nasty
I just saw a crazy idea Barra playing
the much more level-headed and better
Knight A3 I just have to show this
because this is cool C4 is a thematic
idea and I was just attracted by D5 Ed
E6 the pawns fall like dominoes and here
black is probably better after 95 so
this doesn't work anyway but Queen takes
G3 you take the Knight with Chuck no
actually in this final position white is
worse because black has this massive
font Phalanx in the center but these are
the types of ideas that you have to
consider when the center is closed the
side that strategically reopens the
center and is better prepared for it
often it prevails Alice says I'm not
going to give you the chance to play C4
she locks the center and the queen Side
Up herself she plays C4 and we settle
down here
into a maneuvering struggle and the
evaluation bar can be misleading in
positions like this it's really high up
there and white objectively is not just
for choice but is substantially better
but with the closed position sometimes
it requires a series of active Maneuvers
like you just have to slowly but surely
improve your pieces then you play G4 at
the right moment something like that for
white and you already see the First with
Queen E3 a very logical move to stop
Bishop H6 I keep saying this when you
have less space you want to trade pieces
say you're not going to get Bishop H6 to
trade your Bishop that way let me move
my Queen off the G file may put F3 Pawn
to G4 and so on but that might have been
a step in the wrong direction and black
Donya maybe A6 at the right moment just
trying to Chisel at White's control over
there on the queen side
well in ancient Babylonia a wise man
once said that the player that controls
the pawn breaks as a serious positional
Advantage uh I think his name is
robertus hessis or was it ancient Greece
don't remember but Bishop E7 by Alice I
think that allows white to take and hop
the Knight into B4 which stops A6 but
also aims for C6 and I actually think
that we are going to see F4 F5 the issue
being that white can still play F5 even
with black spawns binding on the F5
Square because of the tactics related to
Knight takes D5 being a fork I think
Alice is on her last legs here and she
is not going in the right direction
literally but you know what she wants is
that let's say you make a random move
just like Queen back to E1 just some
pretty bad move then black will play the
move probably A5 so that way you kick
the Knight out of there and if you take
on passant the Knight is ready to
capture back and if the Knight has to
hop backwards then instead of sorry in
the instead of taking on passant yeah
then Black's saying okay you're never
getting back into C6 that was the one
weak spot in the position you can't get
back in there
but the problem is that it's a little
bit the day late and a dollar short I
think that Ibarra without hesitation
should play F4 and A5 well evil bar
disagrees my idea was after A5 here the
email bar agrees B take oh I guess F5
immediately you can just shove that pawn
down the board and you don't care about
the knife the Knight has done its job
because look at that freaking King side
white is just chomping at the bit here
after Queen G5 you're gonna skewer the
queen this is game over I feel like F4
is the human move if you throw in a
check yeah
no I agree with you but I I think first
of all we gotta zoom out of this one
because Fabiano caruana I was asking you
know could history repeat itself the
answer looks like no right now whoa it's
a terrible position in the top right
against eturizaga so St Louis
archbishops had a great round too here
in round three look at this position
Daniel it's even material but black has
all the activity
Ollie cannoli and Holy Cannoli goes the
evil part a little bit after Bishop to
D4 The Rook on C8 is hanging and yes
both players see that the light squares
though are devastatingly weak if white
grabs that Rook which is why Fabi is
leaving it untouched he's chasing the
bishop away now his own Rook is hanging
this is a ridiculous position I've got a
headache yeah so it's exchange Sacrifice
from both and I wonder what the Miss was
there from iterizago because now the Eva
bar is going up more towards the center
and I agree with that because black has
extra material
and I don't think white you know now you
can take on C8 so and you should you
have to watch out for your light squares
right the point is that after Queen
takes eight the Queen's gonna try to go
where the bishop has been to H3 Knight
G4 checkmating attack but I think that
white does have time to slide the king
up to G2 there's no denying black is
better and more active uh but I wonder
what it was before that the Eva bar was
kind of on a seesaw about
I think it was Queen E8 to G6 at the
right moment which actually threatened
the pawn on G3 if you imagine why it's
Pawn being on E2 I'll actually show this
on the board since Bobby is thinking
about whether to take the bishop Queen
G6 here was the top move and if you
greedily grab then you greedily grab and
need uh need I show more in this line of
course Fabi would have probably played a
move like E3 and here Knight H5 piles on
the G3 Pawn this is a very hard move to
play Robert leaving D5 hanging leaving
C8 hang can't blame me tourizaga for
playing it more simply yes but but what
is Fabi doing go to the live board for a
second Knight A4 whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa in what Universe do you let the
queen into age oh he wants queen takes
E5
and and then after 1988 Queen takes D5
Queen G2 oh I completely you know what's
funny I saw Queen E6 check I didn't see
Queen takes D5 okay let's just show that
very but you're right no Rob but there's
a very simple Improvement that Fabio's
missed he is losing his mind here
whoa wait wait did he play that he
played Bishop D4 what is
[Music]
Queen H3 is game over Queen takes C5 now
Knight G4 is a blunder right takes and
you go back but all you have to do is
the elementary Rook to E8 the queen
can't keep contact with the pawn the
game is over white has to give up his
Queen to avoid getting Chuck mated
instead
Robert am I seeing what you're seeing
yeah look at the look what just happened
in the game oh and look at meterizaga he
is beside himself he's like what did I
just do there he had plenty of time on
his clock the last move just go just one
half move there right yeah Bishop E1 it
clears the second rank the idea for
black is Knight G4 and queen A2
Checkmate the problem is after Knight G4
the F Pawn pushes forward to F3 and you
cover the squares over here maybe F4 is
better I'm not sure but either way the
queen Saves the Day for Fabi F3 has been
played and we're gonna fast forward to
the live board we have this position
Knight to E3 I think you're right F4
might have been better because it would
have vacated the F3 Square for The Rook
so this game is far from over but it
would have been over Robert after
Bitcoin H3 I can't believe he missed it
I'm just I was laughing not because of
the action which is because ichirizaga
just demonstrated what a head scratcher
looks like he was you know just what am
I doing Bishop D4 that's getting too
fancy and you can't afford to do that
against someone like Fabiano caruana
because he's a great calculator he's now
up two minutes and has time to think
about how to save his King the good news
for iterzaga is The Rook on F1 cannot be
saved if you go up to F2 you're blocking
the bishop the G3 Pawn will hang with
check all of your pawns will collapse so
that's not available to Fabio so it's
going to be in all likelihood a
situation where either the Knight
remains on E3 because it's stronger than
the Rook or at some moment it will be
two minor pieces for said Rook on F1
which is ultimately what I think we're
gonna get but I think in most end games
I would handle the minor pieces here I
had rather handle the minor pieces
because of the weakness of a lot of
black spawns including B6 uh which could
fall with A5 to follow me to rizaga
trying to deploy his Rook to see to
excellent move there he's finding some
really tough moves Robert and he misses
the easy mate there's a great idea here
for white Rook F3 to meet Rook C2 with
Rook takes Knight oh
just give me all of your pieces for my
queen now suddenly white has a rook and
two minor pieces for a queen in one Pawn
the evil bar actually says it's equal
somehow this is crazy
just because of the weakness of whites
King coupled with the counter play
afforded by the d-pawn maybe something
like Queen F5 I agree I think it's
easier to handle white here and great
call by you Rook up three has been
Uncorked by Fabiano caruana who now
feels confident that he can turn this
around and take the full point
wow this has been a wild game it's hard
to leave it but all four games are of
equal importance yes they're not even
playing bullet they have time but these
these calculations are difficult when
you don't have the evil bar at your
disposal so let's look across the board
here in the top left Benjamin Buck he is
down to 31 seconds what is the clock
Management in that game in the bottom
right the Evo bar is all the way down in
favor of Nicholas theodoru and in the
bottom left Alice Lee against Jose
Carlos Ibarra Daniel that's a position
where black is on the defensive I think
Alice is doing a great job
she just does not go away and that F
Pawn is still on F2 that is the ultimate
piece of bad news for Ibarra he did not
find an opportunity to shove that one
through to F5 that means Alice is
holding her own she smoked ibarra's
Knight out of G5 she is making progress
she's still worse she's so cramped but
this is much better than it was a couple
of moves ago
and we see in the top right the email
bar going higher and higher for Fabiano
caruana and so he was given a second
lease on life in that game and it looks
like you know he is getting a bigger
Advantage by the turn so four
interesting games on our screens should
we go to the bot game just because he's
really down on time we absolutely should
you talked about playing bullet Bach is
playing a bullet game with the white
pieces I think he also has an advantage
he has stabilized the king side
situation blacks pawns are immobile he's
got the C file control I think he's
better objectively Robert but I do not
envy him with 28 seconds to handle a
position of this complexity I don't
believe you you definitely envy him I
know you're a bullet addict so don't
give me that you wish you were playing
with I live on your clock yeah I got you
but look at this Rook C1 double up the
Brooks and there could be Rook C7 I know
you're giving up both your Rooks for the
queen and he plays it because the D6
Pawn was hanging in that position so
instead can white just scoop up A7 now
and go up a pawn
I thought a launch should have invested
a little bit more thought into the
prospect of getting two Rooks now he's
just a pawn down you can't take on E3
because the Rook on E7 is pinned and if
you take on A7 White's Queen goes back
and forth to A3 defending E3 Benjamin
calculating really well with no time
It's All About the Benjamins he's trying
to get that money and that Victory the
Eva bar keeps going up in his favorite
show once again he's not investing
enough time in critical moments he's a
huge lead in the clock but let's zoom
out of this one because we may have a
result any second now uh there are mere
seconds on box clock but look in the top
right Fabiano caruana's evaluation is
through the roof I know in the bottom
right Nicholas Theodora has been getting
it done for the archbishops we haven't
given that game the attention to
desserts just because it's been so
one-sided but look in the top right it's
a wild position Alice Lee by the way
dropped under a minute play the move F5
in the bottom left it's like she's
playing checkers and light squares but
this has been crazy from board to board
it absolutely has and the craziest of
all has been Eduardo's game he crushes
Fabi out of the opening he has literally
made in three moves with the easiest
move that you'll ever get to beat
someone be on his caliber he overthinks
that he gives up his bishop and now he
is tilted even further if we go to that
game for just a second Fabi has two
pieces for a rook which is generally
double-edged uh Robert but that pawn on
D5 and also look at Eduardo's clock I
don't see him pulling this out with 10
seconds
no I wasn't even looking at the clock I
was just looking at the board just
because it's been so fascinating but
you're correct White's pieces all defend
one another the only piece loose is the
bishop on E1 so Queen E5 that might be
an option for white just make sure
everything is defended firstly similar
idea but apparently wrong for some
reason could it have something to do
with rookie eight no Eduardo goes Queen
F5 in the night but F5 oh my goodness
each side hanging as well Bobby finds it
of course Bishop takes H6 is the threat
in addition to F6 no Eduardo there's no
way he's gonna be able to survive this
is there no way at all Fabby could
actually involve uh some of the
Supporting Cast here with a move like G4
that's very much fabby's style to keep
the tension get this Pawn up the board
he's got a minute he's managed his time
really really well I'm calling it G4 is
going to happen and now he's down to
under 50 seconds himself so Fabi it's a
nerve-wracking situation he plays G4
great call by you because G5 it looks
like your king is a bit exposed but the
queen SC2 there are no checks that's the
good news F5 would be loose though so
don't push that jeep on just yet but the
good news for white and he goes King F2
what a calm collected move from carwana
that's a great move stepping into the
pin but getting off of the first rank so
that you can take on D5 and there would
be no check at a word of trying to go
there and here and pin White's pieces
and this is not over Fabi has to be very
precise here Robert because Queen to C6
is a huge threat that could turn this
game around Fabby with 20 seconds
fantastic calculation so far can he
finish it off we'll see but there is a
game that's over Nicholas Theodore did
win with the black pieces we will update
you on all here turn
oh my gosh Queen E3 was the only winning
move there oh my goodness he just hangs
a piece they're pieces no Galore wait
Queen
but Bishop C3 I think oh I think he went
the wrong way there Bishop C3 wouldn't
give him the chance with that F Pawn
being pinned Fabby is reeling from that
blunder but the game is not over he has
to keep himself in this contest by
getting the queen active and going for
some sort of Perpetual that's what he's
doing but he could get checkmate at
first queen C2
there are no checks against the black
king queen D5 and where does that go now
oh that's nice defending and it's even
better wait to see three oh he forced
resolution you see it turizaga with the
fist pump and he gets the dub that was a
crazy game look at him he can barely
breathe and he steps away from it and
Fabiano will want to forget about that
game but as we look at the other two
boards huge leads huge advantages for
the players with the white pieces the
left side of your screen white with the
advantage the right side of your screen
wins for the players with the black
pieces
it's over in the top left we see that D6
was captured and a resignation occurs
Benjamin Bach wins so let's go to Alice
Lee's game she has mere seconds on her
clock she just dropped the pawn she's
trying to survive but it's not looking
to she has five seconds a dead lost
position hey everything is possible this
is one of the craziest PCL matches that
we've had today the Fabi game was one of
the craziest individual games that we
have seen I can't believe that Eduardo
ended up winning that but we'll talk
about that later right now let's focus
on Ibarra as he snaps off the pawn on D5
oh gorgeous tactics lovely pressure down
the e-file and Black's entire position
collapses like a house of cards rookie
seven and you're gonna lose the queen
after Knight F6 yeah it's a force
sequence and a win for a baron a very
calm little fist pump wasn't a big one
but he is happy because Alex Lee is a
dangerous player and Dania it was two to
two in that round so for The Maniacs
trims I mean it could not have been more
important for ichirizaga to get that
point he wins with black against Fabiano
caruana gets revenge from that classic
game that Checkmate I showed from back
in 2018 but Bach gets the job done for
the Archbishop against a lumpy show
theodoru does the same against the board
four but in the middle two boards for
the maniac shrimps Daniel they make it
work so it's still a close match a
picture-perfect start to this match for
Fabiano caruana everything was under
control and then things went completely
Haywire he loses out of the opening he
turns the game around and just when he's
on the cusp of delivering the final blow
Eduardo tourizaga is incredibly
resilient defense all credit to Eduardo
for not losing his school not losing his
Verve and he pulls off a massive win
that changes the landscape of the match
completely Robert because it gives the
Spanish Maniac shrimps a lot more leeway
they would be down seven and a half four
and a half which feels so so different
from the one point deficit that they are
staring at right now it is still a
deficit St Louis is still a Powerhouse
and I think they still should win if
they keep their composure but you are
not allowed to go anywhere because if
this final round is anything like what
we've seen so far we are in or one of
the most epic final rounds that we have
seen thus far in the PCR Robert but you
are super spotted on there that a
three-point deficit you're not coming
back from that that means you have to
beat car one up Bach and Theodore but
now the manuscripts just need to get one
win and hold the other boards and then
we will see a top break they could even
win a regulation but that remains to be
seen we're gonna take a short break when
we return it's more from this crazy
match between the Spanish Maniac shrimps
and the St Louis Archbishop do not and I
mean it do not go anywhere we'll be
right back
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why in the opening plays such an
important role in modern chess the
opening in chess is like coming prepared
with a battle plan you play a move but
it's part of a larger strategy you want
to have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level move 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved starting the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it simple series every received in award
this year the author of the year what I
invite you to do is go to chessable.com
and check out how to play the opening
better get fun positions and win more
games
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them choose
from over 35 lessons created for all
skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a one-point lead for the St Louis
archbishops could have been more but
could have would have should have that's
the thing of the past Donna you have
something to show all of our viewers and
it was a pretty cool sequence well it
was a game that featured more swings
than the scariest roller coaster in the
world I wouldn't go on any roller
coaster rather than watching this
incredible game the final moment came
here Fabby with his last 30 seconds
found the first decisive move F6 he has
two pieces for a rook in a game that
Eduardo should have finished with
Checkmate and here he had to find an
incredible only move to win the game
which was the ridiculous retreating move
Queen to E3 the idea it's not to take on
H6 when white runs out of checks no it's
to check on E8 to check on E7 and black
cannot avoid getting forked and not only
does he get forked but by capturing The
Rook white defends what is now is extra
Bishop this was the only move to win
instead Fabby panics and with his last
seconds opens up the F5 Square gets
forked loses his Knight and shortly
thereafter lost a shocking game that
keeps the maniac shrimps in this match
yeah and Eduardo terzaga scores a very
important victory for the Spanish Maniac
shrimps he has two and a half out of
three you see him there on board too but
guess what his opponent for the final
round will be Benjamin Buck because all
boards uh play the same assignments on
the other team
so the board twos they're leading the
charge here four threes are even as well
and then it's the difference is board
one and board four half a point
Advantage for the archbishops man oh man
are we in for an epic final round
Fabiana carwana really The X Factor to
me can he push that incredibly lost
behind him he's got a game with black
against Allen picho and Robert Allen has
not inspired confidence thus far I feel
like he's mismanaged his time he's
played a little bit too fast and I
really think that Fabi needs to try to
pounce if Fabby can win his game going
to predict that the archbishops win this
round I think that game might very well
be the decisive one but we know that
each game matters exactly the same one
point each
and our biggest feedback and let's call
it criticism of Alan P show is he's
playing too quickly in critical moments
now he won't do that because he's
playing Fabiano caruana so there's no
way to force you to sit and think before
you move like playing carwana so I think
that you know for peace show he's
capable he is such a strong player he
gets the white pieces I dush any
decisions
and he rushes his first move how dare he
not spend two minutes on one call and
let's see we're gonna get a real Lopez
Alan P show is a very very experienced
rui Lopez player he's been playing this
opening for his entire life and an early
decision here for a lot I've seen him
play D3 but this time he goes for the
main lion and Fabi meets him at the top
with a line that has surged in
popularity once again recently the
Archangel variation
yeah no this one has been in faguna
karuana's repertoire for a number of
years not played very often at the
highest level because if you prepare it
from the white side it can be super
sharp and scary for black but you can
already see show thinking that's not
acting I think he just doesn't have that
much experience against this variation
this is a move that often slips through
the cracks of even the most experienced
through Lopez players almost everybody
plays the Marshall or the Briar or one
of the lines uh that features Bishop E7
I think Fabi choosing the opening very
very well and a lot has to make a
general decision for us does he want to
go down the main line which is C3 and D4
or this you want to deviate and go for
something less theoretical you can do
that by playing the move D3 without C3
and using the C3 Square for the Knight
I've played like that and that Dodges a
lot of the theory but it doesn't really
challenge black theoretically
and there is an opportunity for white to
play the move Knight takes E5 and after
Knight takes back on E5 it looks like
you just gave away a piece for a pawn
but white has the very thematic a fork
of Pawn to D4 at the end
yeah that's the center fork trick as it
is often known it's possible here
it was possible on the last move and you
also need to decide whether you're
taking on B5 and who that benefits it
seems to benefit white but perhaps white
shouldn't rush that move
no I mean there isn't a huge rush
especially because it's a forcing
variation so I think that for pisho he
does go for it it's the principal
variation but now you take and play D6
at the end and you have to watch out
because C5 hits the queen and then C4
tries to not win the bishop it has the
A2 square but nobody likes a bishop on
A2 with a pawn sitting on C4 so we're
just seeing preparation from both sides
I'm pretty sure I've seen some Peter
Fiddler games in this variation no idea
what the moves are don't remember but I
just feel like this has been played at
the highest levels in a number of games
yeah I feel like I've vaguely seen this
in some linaris tournament seven years
ago with some nameless super GMS
definitely this position has occurred
before but a lot of show has his work
cut out for him you were absolutely
right he is most definitely not rushing
in fact if anything I think he might
experience problems on the clock the way
that this game is going I could easily
see him spending a couple of minutes on
the next few moves
and in this game there's going to be
some thought as you said the next few
moves won't be easy to figure out so why
don't we zoom out to our other games and
I just want to take stock of something a
Eduardo terizaga has only drawn three
games all year and has lost zero in the
Pro chess League he's making a strong
case for League MVP it's hard to call
someone an MVP when their team might get
eliminated early but that's a really
wonderful performance
it most certainly is and he's also won a
series of incredibly clutch games I
think you'll remember his game against
solemn solid where he was dead in the
water and turned the game around to
score a crucial point of course his game
in the last round against Fabiano CaRu
one of merely adds to his MVP case here
he's got his work cut out for him yet
again the white pieces against Benjamin
Bach they're in some sort of an English
slob setup shall we take a closer look
or are you more attracted by the lower
left game between theodoro and Ibarra
my eyes are taking me all over the place
it's hard to pick just one game I mean
look in the top left for example the
last move played from carwana was Rook
B8 to B7 to save his Pawn that's not a
position you see every day but carwana
moving so quickly I know he's in
preparation so why don't we go to that
bottom left game because that looks
extremely combative Nicholas Theodore
taking on Jose Carlos Ibarra Ibarra has
been solid thus far his first game was
Bach he was worse with the white pieces
but he's made three draws so he's kind
of been under the radar
he just won against Alice Lee and he
lost a previous game all right
yeah he did that was an interesting game
we got some dude named Hikaru in the
chat by the way offering up uh some
insight that Abby's position occurred in
a title Tuesday game between ikaro and
carwana a couple of weeks ago so that
adds an interesting layer to that game
that means that Fabi is for sure in his
preparation more disturbing news for P
show but let's unpack this position
uh Nicholas Theodore needs to find a way
to unpack the queen side because he is
down a pawn and the more I look at this
Robert the more skeptical I am about his
compensation clearly he wants to play E4
but that move in and of itself what does
that really give you
um the answer might not be all that much
and and you play E4 you say great I have
the center that should be good for me
but the D4 Pawn is a bit loose and once
you push upon two squares to E4 then
it's gonna remain that way the bishop on
G2 is shut down a bit by having the pawn
on its path and E4 to E5 you gain space
you attack the Knight on F6 but it may
give the Black Knight the D5 score to
hop to and it's impossible to kick it
out of there so Theodore doesn't look
thrilled about what's going on right now
but he is ahead on the clock Danya yeah
he looks exasperated you know he is such
a dangerous player and he has very high
expectations of himself I know that uh
from being friends with him he wants to
go four out of four every week it was
not meant to be but he has a chance to
deliver what would be an incredibly
clutch victory for the archbishops he
secures the bishop pair and if theodoro
procrastinates on castling white could
park this bishop on B4 although even
then I could deploy this Knight to Asics
and Chase the bishop off of the diagonal
so it's alibara here and he could even
put his Queen on D5 and really cement
that battery and keep the Knight
Paralyzed Love Queen D5 that's a great
move for black White's best moves to
take the Knight that was just captured
and put it on C3 I think that would be a
really nice option but Queen D5 it makes
it hard for white to even move in that
position so I I like it I like ibarra's
position I think that his really good
chances and they need him the managers
need him to at least hold a draw on this
game for them to have a chance
absolutely and Ibarra will contemplate
his next move he is down on the clock
both of these players uh can definitely
play Fast they're incredibly strong at
Blitz but it's quite clear that Ibarra
is in control out of the opening let's
swing back to the bird's eye view
because we've got more clarity on some
of the boards and a lot less Clarity I
think in a long piece shows game against
Fabiano caruana which continues to
percolate whether you look at the center
or the king side or the queen side there
is a white piece on A8 that's a rook
there's usually a black Rook I ate last
time I checked Robert yeah Grenade in
the initial initial board or am I
forgetting how to set up the pieces and
is that a rook on B7 or a bishop what is
this
let's go to the top left quickly because
there there might be a funny Queen trade
at the moment you see the last move
played in the top left was Knight to B6
and that hits the Rook on A8 but can
white play Queen takes be and he just
did yes yeah great call
okay so the Smoke Clears what do we make
of the send game
probably no worse for black I'm looking
at this position I'm seeing the pawn F4
perhaps a bit overextended The Pawn on
B5 also a bit overextended so there's
some weak squares in White's position
but pishot has the pair of Bishops
that's good news and now he can maybe
create a problem on the D6 Square you
can isolate a pawn for black that's not
good news
and his last move was accompanied with a
draw for this adds a really interesting
wrinkle what is Fabiana going to do
before the game I think he would be
relatively satisfied with the draw I
mean he's got the black pieces I draw
brings the archbishops who hold the one
point lead one half Point closer to the
Target and a half points Abby's gonna
give this some thought if he declines
Robert I think it will have something to
do with the time situation
yeah he is up
three and a half minutes doing quite
well in the clock but I just don't see
how fabina can play this for a win the
move D5 just to avoid getting an
isolated Pawn that gives the opponent
all of the dark squares and only the
show has a dark Square Bishop so I feel
like the move D5 that's really playing
for a loss more than it's playing for a
win and if that's the case maybe there
will be a series of Trades that
liquidate and I guess Dundee is probably
really that upset with a draw he's the
black pieces against a strong gym your
point up heading into the round it's
pretty good stuff
and what you do right now if you're
fabulous you look at your teammates
games and you decline the draw you play
Knight F5 what a gutsy call by Fabiano I
think his decision was also influenced
Robert by the result of his previous
game he was mad he wants to prove
himself and I don't know if this is the
wisest decision because I think Alan is
better it's got the bishop pair would
you second the idea that white is
objectively uh perhaps slightly but with
E6 on the on the on deck and Knight
takes P5 threatened this could spiral
out of control for Fabi I feel like
white is significantly better E6 is an
automatic move right now uh but there is
one downside the we keep talking about
the bishop pair and it looks good but
the bishop on C1 can't really get out
especially with the Knight on F5 and if
you're not looking out for it Knight F5
to H4 could hit you where it hurts on G2
so white does need to be a bit careful
I'm a little bit nervous about his clock
so Dunya he took our words to heart he
started thinking more and more and more
but now we're going to be critical in
the other direction like is he in danger
of thinking too much and getting in time
trouble yeah what do commentators want
first he's playing too fast now he's
playing too slow but he is playing
confidently E6 is on the board
apparently the top move was G4 we cannot
blame him for a second uh that he didn't
resist the temptation I think what Fabi
should do is calmly sidestep this with
the King and after he takes F7 obviously
that pawn is a major problem but it's
also a Sitting Duck and black could
Target it with Knight H6 takes F7 so I
actually think Fabby could stabilize his
affairs with King f8 but boy does he
need to be careful in the next couple of
moves as long as he doesn't take that
pawn on E6 he should be doing okay that
would blunder the Knight on F5 because
the bishop recaptures the check so while
Fabi spends some of his time he is ahead
on the clock let's go to our bird's eye
view we have all four games still
underway the archbishops with a one
point lead the shrimps need to get wins
from somewhere in the bottom left we
looked at the game earlier still an
extra Pawn for Jose Carlos Ibarra in the
top right we have not tuned in there
iterizago with the white pieces against
Benjamin buck that one looks pretty
level and the bottom right that may be
even material but there's an isolated
Pawn for Alice Lee but it's also a pass
Pawn so Dania I'm gonna throw it to you
I'll let you choose where should we go
look at Alice's Alice Lee's game because
if she can score a victory I wouldn't
say that that guarantees a win for the
archbishops but if Fabi can avoid losing
his game in the top left and if Benjamin
Bach can squeeze out a draw there it is
that's a win for the archbishops and
Alice Lee just always seems to be better
Robert every time we look
Alice Lee seems to be better I mean it's
crazy and she's got massive pressure on
black center and most importantly we
pull up an analysis board why can't
Sabrina take the pawn on D5 she actually
maybe can but I boy would I never go for
a position like this the engine seems to
make it work but I'm not touching this
ball and I think neither will Sabrina
no that's way way way too risky with a
pin down the D file but if you don't
take that pawn White's still gonna play
Rook to D1 okay that pawn will stay on
the board and it's a passer the bishop
on D6 is not a great block hitter we
typically like Knights block hating past
pawns because they see over the pawns
into the enemy position so I think Alice
is playing a great game by the way Donya
we have not said this all day so piso
down for the first time of the clock
Alice way ahead on the clock I think the
first time all protest League season
and she's not just up on the clock she's
up five minutes on the clock and the
hardest part of Sabrina's defensive task
is very much ahead of her in fact her
defensive task is only just beginning
Bishop G5 by the way is an incredibly
nasty move that could tip black over the
edge because the threat of Bishop takes
F6 is utterly devastating your Bishop is
under Fire you might just get
overwhelmed and overextended in the span
of a couple of moves H6 might be the
only way really to stay in the game for
Sabrina but whatever she does she's got
to play fast down to three minutes the
Spanish Women's Champion is in Dire
Straits here right out of the opening
and done H6 okay you stop Bishop G5 Rook
D1 is pretty automatic then what right
this Knight on C3 is it about to hop to
B5 to get that Bishop out of there will
white play Pawn to B3 and maybe try to
take that Bishop 1 D6 and get a bishop
to A3 because Bishops are bad block
haters Queens are even worse block
haters because as soon as it's attacked
it has to move so I really don't like
this position for black uh you know
strong International master from Spain
but Alice Lee is just putting all of her
pieces in good places and she's up now
nearly six minutes on time Rook C8
played at long last Bishop G5 you
mentioned it it should be played this is
a sizable Advantage for Alice Lee
Alice Lee developing attacking
maneuvering pressuring winning and
Bishop G5 really comes close to tipping
black over the edge the game obviously
not over yet Sabrina will defend tooth
and nail and try to pull out at least
half a point for the maniac shrimps I
mean how many turnarounds have we seen
today yes so many but we have to go to
our board three oh look in the bottom
left here Nicholas Theodore has given up
a minor piece but his Queen is out near
the black king and I just want to say
that this game could end in a draw if
black plays Pawn takes Knight on E5 we
will see a repetition Queen to G5 check
Queen H5 Unstoppable check back and
forth so a draw is essentially being
offered over the board but if you are
Jose Carlos Ibarra you say let me play
for more he actually moved on it he
didn't take the 95. he would Queen takes
Pawn on D4 that's surprising to me
it's surprising to me as well what on
what in the world is going on here does
white have Knight G6 oh that's what he
overlooked and Nicholas theodoro is
going to force a crucial draw Knight
takes E5 and black was simply up upon or
almost no compensation the queen could
have swung to G5 instead bang bang is
what he should have played Robert am I
over stating the case by saying black
has great winning chances here maybe not
Queen G5 maybe something like C5 and
White's Queen alone is not going to
cause black any harm Knight G6 played
instantly
and Ibarra he can't believe it he is
exasperated this might be a decisive
Half Point yeah you can see how upset he
was he completely overlooked it it is
immediately a draw uh because at the
bishop on G2 is also hanging so it's not
just the queen AJ Checkmate the Knight
attacking The Rook at the end of a lot
of sequences the bishop on G2 will be
lost so if you're a bar you just have to
make this draw now he's really upset
with himself had he played uh the
capture on E5 Donya it would have been
better for black very very far from
winning but of course he was the only
one with winning chances now a draw will
be agreed there's nothing else besides
Queen H6 back and forth so I think we
can leave these two I mean a bar is
going to be disappointed but for
theodoro it's an important Half Point
getting the archbishops closer and
closer but let's look across the boards
now in the top left five minute car one
with the black pieces the eval Bar says
level we see Bishops of opposite color
in the top right we see a position where
both sides have a queen two Rooks and
seven pawns the pawn structure is a
little bit of obscured but the eval bar
hovering in the center and in the bottom
right Alice Lee's Advantage is growing
after she did make the bishop G5 move
the game board three has been a draw on
the bottom left you just saw the
repetition and the Hat Point has been is
going to be added to the team scores but
Alice Lee in the bottom right I mean
it's not the Clincher just yet done yet
but it's going to lead them well on
their way
it just gets worse and worse for Sabrina
on the board and on the clock she is
down to 54 seconds and as we were saying
the defensive task uh is only just
beginning I think if Alice can maintain
her composure avoid the temptation to
play too fast and try to flag black
which he is clearly not doing she is
investing valuable time to play
accurately if she wins that game she
puts the archbishops within half a point
of bagging this match and avoiding
elimination Benjamin Buck I think it's
all up to him can he hold his own
against the tourizaga I most certainly
think he can he's got a very solid
position but where do we go I mean
Abby's game looks like it's sharpening
up as well
man I don't know where to go yeah that
game the top left between Fabiano
caruana with the black piece of Olympic
show he showed down under a minute on
the clock and so is Sabrina on board
four so I I just so many interesting
games let's tune in here 94. who did
Bobby Bobby offered a draw with this
move oh wow and if you take on e4 the
king gets up to C5 and the show kind of
needs to play on for his team uh his
board four is in big trouble down to 54
seconds left so he plays Bishop B4 but I
think once the knights get swapped on
you where are the winning chances gonna
come from
I don't think they're gonna come from
anywhere and I just have to commend Alan
P show right there he did what Alice Lee
did in the first match it's always great
when the players put the team's interest
above their own a draw with Fabi is a
great individual result something to
hang your hat on but a lot of people
show knows that he needs to burn all of
his Bridges here and try to generate
chances you want to play Knight F2 here
right what about Rook G1 there
um Knight F2 Rook G1 it gets he keeps
you the pawn and the King's going up to
C5 next uh apparently actually he's the
one who offered to draw dungeon of just
getting word of that uh that he offered
the draw so maybe he's not the team
player we thought he was but no it also
apologize you know you live in this
position the kids swear okay go ahead I
don't swear there's a family friendly
show so no swearing but Bishop goes back
to D7 and maybe bishop offered a draw
knowing that Fabiano wants to play for a
win but this one really is kind of
anyone's game over Rook takes E4 King
takes D5 Rook takes F4 the pawns are
being mopped up so I really do think
that this one will result in split the
points let's get out of here because
board four becomes all important because
if this game is drawn and Alice Lee can
win her opponent does not have much time
it does look like Benjamin Bach he's
holding steady on board two up there
with Queen C4 his last move in the top
right but if Alice Lee can just win this
game the match is effectively over she
bags the match with a win on the
strength of that incredible save by
theater let's go to Alice Lee's game
because Sabrina now down to 17 seconds
and Alice is not letting up the pressure
in fact she's stepping up the pressure
she's keeping her foot on the gas pedal
and that pawn it landed on D6 right in
Black's Grill I apologize by the way for
uh the misinformation regarding the draw
for I could swear uh that I saw draw for
by uh Fabby but I think that game is
going to end in a draw anyway there is
the pawn it lands on D6
and how does Alice finish this off well
I think the danger for Alice is that she
plays too quickly she has a great
position she may just win this game in a
few moves but you know what I'm talking
about Donya when your opponent's in time
trouble so you want to try to flag them
there is increment in this event two
second increment but look at Alice's
position she knows she doesn't need a
rush she's taking her time right here
it's not about flagging at this point
she's just gonna win over the board
yeah I think young players watching the
PCL who want to learn from these top
players notice Alice he's taking 15-20
seconds on our move so she guess she is
putting pressure on Black's clock but
she's not playing a single move
instantly and so many games are lost
when a player forgets about the position
and plays for the clock I think Knight
takes a seven might be a tactic worth
exploring but I would also advocate for
the simple and Powerful Rook ac-1 I was
looking knight takes A7 as well it looks
like the Knight F5 is loose and you're
also removing the block hater after
Queen takes a 5 D7 will happen next and
they've played honestly finding tactics
bang bang and D7 is going to decide it
after the run the night that pawn is
simply Unstoppable black has to give up
the whole house two seconds one second
is he gonna move off she gets the move
up it doesn't matter you have to give up
that Rook on D7 and it is over Alice Lee
takes the game she beats the
international master from Spain we see
the comments she was an absolute steal
yeah I think she's a bit underrated just
13 years old 2300 plus but I think the
sky is the limit for Alice Leah she
walks away from the screen with a
victory in her back pocket so two games
remain here Donya or no the archbishops
have officially won because Fabiana
carwana drew that game the match is over
Alice Lee has decided it it was no joke
we thought this might happen there's one
game remaining it doesn't affect the
match score Dania Alice Lee secures
victory for the archbishops
what an incredible performance and what
an incredible final game that was
textbook right from the opening
culminating in a beautiful deflection
sacrifice and how fitting it is that
that d-pawn uh which was a menace when
it was on D5 decides the game we flipped
on the final game of the round but as
you said this is purely cosmetic the
Archbishop stormed through the final
round to bag this match and get to 2-2
Robert if they win the next match if
they make their way into the playoffs
what a ridiculous comeback that is going
to be
I think you know the Croatia Bulldogs
who face off against the archbishops
next week they already know that Alice
Lee will be in the lineup they can start
their preparation now she has been
phenomenal for them Benjamin Bach has
also been great Eduardo turizaga
deserves a ton of credit for the Spanish
Maniac shrimps he's two and a half out
of three he took down five on a caruana
but Donna even if
the match wasn't already over and only
you know a draw was needed to win the
match for the archbishops I think
Benjamin box getting that half Point
yeah he's not about to just throw this
game away or resign it uh even if the
team captain has communicated by a zoom
chat that the match is over you want to
perform well individually you want to uh
make your captain believe that you will
perform in crunch time and next week is
going to be major crunch time for the
archbishops because everything is going
to be on the line Benjamin Buck is such
a stellar he's solid he doesn't get too
high with the highs doesn't get too low
with the lows he just shows up and
always seems to perform when they need
him so a very well constructed team and
St Louis finally showing the true colors
Benjamin has a little bit of Defending
to do here
typical Robert with White's Pawn
structure as crippled as it is
yeah because white is up upon it's five
to four but you can't create a pass Pawn
you've double pawns you're gonna have to
try for F5 that's the one chance but
look at what Benjamin is doing he's
gonna give you a check on F1 or on A3
the white king will not be super active
and thus the game should conclude
peacefully Benjamin Buck great defense
uh from the start of this one he never
was worse and so eternizaga he's still
has not lost in the protesting season he
is not going to lose this game and it's
just not enough for The Maniacs ribs it
is not enough Benjamin defending this
confidently white has no way to make
progress black will keep tying himself
to the E4 Pawn shuffling between E2 and
F2 it's only a matter of time before
mystery tourizaga has to acquiesce to
the draw
yeah there's no progress the King on H3
is stuck over there so it's just a back
and forth they are going to repeat moves
it would appear yeah they're just doing
that now and the draw will be in the bag
that means the final score will be nine
to seven this spin a Spanish the St
Louis archbishops I was going to call
them the Spanish archbishops because
that sounds more historically accurate
uh they are going to move on nine to
seven final score Benjamin Buck he can
finally relax itarizaga gave them all
they could handle but unfortunately the
Spanish Munich shrimp season is done
and what a season it was so many bright
spots from Eduardo iterizaga's MVP level
performance to the way in which they
qualify by the hair on their chinny chin
chin do their Sunny victory over yes the
Charlotte cobras descend them back home
but it was not meant to be the
archbishops are a nightmare matchup at
one and two just a nightmare to play
when you've got a losing record the
archbishops are on fire abiano caruana
doing what needs to be done and Alice
Lee cooking with some fish oil as she
scores the decisive victory in the final
round
yeah what a game from her uh what a
performance these last couple weeks and
the Saint Louis archbishops take the
final round two and a half one half and
they take the match by a score of nine
to seven you look at the performances
from board to board boards two led the
way for their teams Benjamin buck and
Edward uturizaga both scored three out
of four carwana chipped in with two and
a half out of four that's a plus score
but Alice Lee look at that one half out
of four for her opponent zero out of
four Sabrina Vega Gutierrez just wasn't
her day such a strong player but Alice
Lee outscored by a point and a half and
that was a huge difference maker
doggy dog world out there in the St
Louis archbishops were the aggressors
today the trifecta carwana buck and
Theodore where they have high
expectations for themselves Nicholas is
going to have to step up his game if he
is to play next week I think a plus
score would go a very long way toward
helping the archbishops make the
playoffs of Atlas Lee just needs to
continue doing what she's doing and if
she can keep scoring one and a half out
of four or even one out of four Robert I
feel like the archbishops are nearly
Unstoppable
what do you have Fabiano caruana on the
top board and your board four scoring oh
wait this is a dangerous team and
speaking of super GM Fabiano caruana
we're actually gonna take a break and
we'll return we'll have him in for an
interview so you don't want to go
anywhere the match score is written down
it's in the books but five minutes will
share his thoughts about his team's
Victory so we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
mm-hmm
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we are joined by super Grand Master
Fabiano caruana who helped his team the
St Louis archbishops win their match and
Stave off elimination Fabi how does it
feel a second straight match Victory
you're still living in the protest
League
yeah it feels good it's especially nice
when your teammates carry most of the
weight for you and today I didn't
perform very well but uh but my team did
really well and I I had like this weird
moment in the last game because I
couldn't access the other game so I
didn't know what was going on there was
like some sort of error in the in the
zoom and so I was like I want to play
solidly because I have no idea if I need
to make a draw or not but I don't want
to
but I don't want to
um like give up all winning chances as
well
so I was a big tour in that game but
luckily everyone else pulled through so
I made a draw and it was enough
Abby could you share your brief thoughts
on that really nice uh second round game
against sibara and is it fair to say
that that was the best game of the day
for you
oh yeah for sure I was really happy with
that game
I thought I was winning and then it took
me like a minute to see that I had this
queen H6 so I was wondering like how
what's the best way to do it and I
figured if I played Bishop D4 he's
probably gonna go into it because
otherwise he just loses like very
mundanely down upon with with a bad
position uh so that was a really nice
finish and then I had this moment where
I was like I can take I can take the
Rook on A3 and then continue to attack
him up a piece but then I saw bishop h8
and that was that was especially nice so
I I really like that game
unfortunately the game after was like
one of the worst games anyone has played
probably this year but uh at least it
was exciting and it didn't cost us the
match so so that's good
well Bobby you know we don't want to
talk about things that make you upset so
let's talk about something that makes
you happy Alice Lee she's been a star
for the archbishops what can you say
about the chest that she is displaying
and the performance she's shown for the
archbishops
yeah it's really incredible I I mean
that she's so young she's like 13 or 14
I'm not sure exactly and she's already
at that level like I think she has very
good chances of becoming a grand master
um
and yeah like the last match he
basically won the match for us winning
in the the first uh round against Blue
Ball and then I was watching the games
today and I saw that she was very very
close to holding the first game then the
second game she held and then after I
finished my last game I ran up to see uh
like what's going on in the other games
and I saw that she was crushing with
like a lot of time on the clock so so
it's a super confident performance
um and she she seems like a very calm
players which is especially useful in
like these fast time patrols so yeah
yeah really really great asset to the
team
that'd be a question about your opening
choices you played a sicilian in round
one it was super fun to see you play
that is it fair to say that you give
yourself more leeway as far as the
openings go in the PCL and other rapid
tournaments and do you ever get the
temptation to kind of play a proverbial
maybe not a bong Cloud but do you ever
get the temptation to kind of Let
Yourself Go in the opening and try out
new stuff
in Blitz I sometimes do that
um in Rapid I try not to I try to keep
some control like in Blitz I think you
can get away with a lot of stuff maybe I
don't think I'll get away with a bond
Cloud that's more like
for Hikaru or people who can like really
recover from terrible positions and and
I don't know if I'm ready for that yet
but
yeah playing some like I I especially
like the two nights Tango and Blitz
because I played it a lot as a kid and
it's like D4 Knight of six C4 Knight C6
and so I occasionally play it in uh
title Tuesdays usually get a bad
position but the results are not so bad
so and it's fun you usually get fun
positions
um but today I played the Sicilian I got
a really really lousy position out of
the opening so I don't know if that was
a good experiment
well the experiment worked out even if
it didn't start as well as you would
have hoped and well we're talking about
openings preparation so first of all
two-part question what kind of
preparation do you do for these matches
and because the matches are elimination
your team has to win do you help your
teammates especially Alice who you know
she's still so young she doesn't have
that experience do you help a player
like her prepare give her some opening
ideas
no I haven't been in touch with any of
my teammates and I also didn't prepare
myself for any of the games which sounds
a little bit uh careless but I really
didn't have any time like this morning
everything was just uh we had a lot to
do and
um didn't get any time to look at the
games I just like uh checked the Trees
of the recent games for my opponents
just to make a decision the opening so I
decided I'll play
um Sicilian I would play E4 against the
bar I would play the Catalan against
Victoria saga and then I didn't even
decide for the last game because it was
already
all right I was already out of time so
uh not much prep went into it
um Fabi you have improved tremendously
in Blitz and rapid in the last couple of
years and it's been amazing to see uh
your results have been really Stellar uh
would you say that there are any general
changes that you've made to your
approach to Blitz and rapid in the last
couple of years or is it just sort of a
matter of attaining more practice
I think I took it more seriously at some
point I also like I would play these
tournaments and and score very badly
like in the grant chess tour back in the
day and then I would just hate myself
and I was like losing game after game
and at some point I realized that it was
because I I just wasn't taking the games
very seriously from the opening onwards
I was playing lousy openings
um and you can't really get away with
that against the top guys
so just generally
um being a bit more serious and not
tilting if things go badly I think is
that was the majority of the change like
I I would go on massive tilt streaks and
now if I lose a few games I tend to take
a more measured approach which
um I think that's also experienced
because you see
sometimes people start very badly in
tournaments and then they still do very
well I mean anything is possible
recoveries are always possible so that's
that's just general advice it also
applies to classical but In classical
you get a bit more time to recover
mentally
I can play one game and get one game a
day and then you have the evening if you
played a bad game to at least
you know see what went wrong and realize
that things aren't so bad uh just like
let your emotions settle a bit in Rapid
Blitz that's that's very difficult
because it's one game after the other
very often so so that was one of the
main differences
that makes perfect sense probably you
know having time to settle down is
important and you do get a little bit of
time before your team's next match you
are going to take the Croatia Bulldogs
on how do you feel about that matchup
and about the crochet Bulldogs team
I'm not familiar with all the players on
the team I saw that Irene
secunderabadwayi and the last match they
played
um
but I don't remember I think sarich the
but not even Sarge antesars just on the
team yeah and they have dance I'm not
like they're a top board Dash is their
first board okay so yeah that's a very
tough team
um I have only a tiny bit of experience
against all of them like I don't think
I've ever played Irene ante Sarge I
played in like 2007 and I lost so
hopefully I'll
probably 16 years later hopefully I'll
make a comeback if I'm playing against
him
and dance I've only played
in a futile Tuesdays and one classical
game in the Romania Bucharest um super
bet tournament so not too much
experience I'll have to to do a bit more
prep I think and figure out what I'm
gonna do
I have a quick pun before I ask your
final question uh my final question to
you Fabi uh how do you apologize in
Croatian
uh I'm sorry H okay now the final
question was was that your worst pun or
is it is that up there as like one of
your worst ones I think I've stooped
even lower uh
this probably is bottom five though I'll
definitely get arrested for this one
um Bobby final question for me because
you offer your brief Reflections on uh
the American Cup which is starting soon
what are your expectations for yourself
and how excited are you uh to play
another OTB event
yeah look looking forward to that one uh
all the top us guys are playing
um first round I'm playing Ray Robson
and that'll be interesting I I like
playing as Ray he's a super exciting
player he's also playing a tournament
right now the um Armageddon series I
think it's called in Berlin
or or he might
um that might have already finished
but yeah Rey is always very fun he's not
forgetting to time trouble a lot uh so
we might have some time scrambles last
time we went to when I played Jeffrey
last year I went to an Armageddon and
ended with me flagging Jeffrey so I
don't know if that'll happen again but
I'm ready to flag some people if in case
Armageddon happens and yeah looking
forward to it
well we'll definitely be watching you in
the American Cup first next week's Pro
chess League action so Fabi will let you
go but congratulations on the win today
and good luck in the match next week
thank you thanks guys
That's Heavy heard from Fabiano caruana
super Grand Master he has led his team
to a 2-2 Mark they started owing two but
these are the five teams that have
clinched their spot in the playoffs we
have the Indian yogis the Gotham Knights
Shanghai Tigers the levitov chess
Wizards and the Norway gnomes the other
teams still in contention have to play
next week so Dania these St Louis
archbishops they're one of those teams
oh Fabiano
let's talk to him while he's there oh no
bring him back
that was awesome
that's hilarious I I wanna I want like a
cut out of fobby now just like him in
that exact pose and you see him just
like frozen there it's like a perfect
image it's like perfectly centered got
the great background it's like great
lighting you know this should be used as
like a template you know he has good
posture and right now the St Louis
archbishops are posturing for a full
spot there too
they started oh out of two and it has
not been smooth sailing for the
archbishops all their matches seem to be
really tense but now they're two and two
they're gonna face the Croatia Bulldogs
Fabi you know familiar with a couple
names on that roster he of course knows
them he just isn't sure who's in on
their team because he's so focused on
his own opponents but now that they play
the Bulldogs done do you think the
archbishops are gonna make the playoffs
I think they've got an incredible shot
and I will Pat myself on the back when
they were oh and two I did say that of
all the open two teams such Bishops had
the best chance and obviously I based
that off of their roster so the
archbishops are going to be facing their
Arch enemies in the Croatia Bulldogs
with their back against the wall for the
third straight week I think they're
feeling pretty darn confident they
pulled it off twice third time's the
charm we will see but a good Mater's
team is not going to give up easily they
are solid they've got some young and
exciting players like Leon levich and
Auntie sarich who it's going to be a
fascinating one but not the only match
we've got a couple other 2-2 match-ups
between the chess bras and the Blitz and
the Garden State passengers and MGD one
Robert next week's going to be amazing
it certainly will have a double header
on Thursday and then a match on Friday
so I'm gonna put you on the spot so it
seems pretty clear you think the Saint
Louis archbishops are the favorite how
about in the other two matchups how
about in the other two matchups so I am
going to have to go with the chest press
particularly if someone with the
initials MC will make an appearance I
think Magnus is gonna go 4-0 and carry
the match for the chess bras passers MGD
one is going to whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa I'm gonna I'm gonna call you out on
that one so the blitz who feature
Alexander grishook and Maxine vashir
lagrav you're gonna sit here and tell me
that Magnus is gonna sweep that Squad
you're gonna sit there next week on
Thursday at around 12 30 PST and you're
gonna be patting me on the back I'm
calling it okay let me amend this I
think Magnus is gonna get at least three
and a half out of four next week
I have spoken to the chess gods and they
have imparted the wisdom to me we'll see
I'm sure this will age as badly as most
of my predictions hey when the Warriors
and we're down 3-1 against the OKC
Thunder I called their comeback that was
the only prediction I've ever ever made
correctly hopefully hey don't I'll get a
second one don't call it a comeback
you've been here for years and wow
that's a huge statement and in the final
game between the pastors and MGD one
some fan favorite Sam Sevin he leads the
way for the pastors Alex lunderman
played great for them and we saw Arjun
aragaisy and his Squad uh they you know
had a tough go of it today but Hurricane
Valley put excellent chess with a plus
score on board three and a reminder to
everybody that Daylight Saving starts
this weekend in the US but not in Europe
what is with that why don't we just get
some normalcy in the world but I will
talk about that later so it's an hour
earlier for Europe so make sure you look
at your time zone conversions get that
right you will not want to miss anything
in the Pro chess League because we have
16 teams still fighting it out for three
playoff spots it's gonna be a lot of fun
and speaking of fun what's happening
before we get to the pro chess League
final matches it will be a play-in
tournament a very important one because
the Champions chess tour is probably
just about the biggest thing in chess we
love seeing the top players duke it out
so next Monday and that's just a few
days away now we will have a play in for
the chessable Masters Dania any final
thoughts before we send this one off
into the weekend and come back to the
processing next week what an incredible
match we saw today two matches that had
their distinct signature their distinct
characteristics and next week we are set
up for three more matches with every
team having their back against the wall
what I love about the PCL is that each
and every team even the ones that are
eliminated are approximately equivalent
in strength so it's all about the form
that the players display and as we get
further and further into the regular
season you can almost feel some of the
play players sensing that team
camaraderie carrying their team on their
back and these individual story lines
right the individual players who make
their teams succeed and who make uh
their teams get into the playoffs are
what makes the PCL tick and boy is it
going to tick hard next week this was
awesome and it certainly was with some
great performances from players on the
bottom boards we saw buddy pranav lead
the way for the Norway gnomes earlier
today then Alice Lee who's quickly
becoming the most popular person in
chess she scored one half out of four
she helped contribute to her team's
Victory the St Louis archbishops remain
in the Pro chess league so we're gonna
say goodbye we're gonna say have a great
weekend but Monday will be the Champions
chess tour playing for the chessable
Masters and then Thursday we'll have a
doubleheader of the protesting you one
want to miss any of the fun so be on the
lookout come back join us thank you so
much for watching and we'll see you next
time
thank you
foreign
[Music]